I
to
e
they
the
This Ain't
Noise
who all right turn uh turn your things
to the your uh name plates to the front
the
folks
so so folks will know who who's speaking
can you hear me
now
okay all right uh well we all rise and
we salute the flag
you all please join with me in a pledge
to all
glory Alle to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
all thank
you all
right about to start the hearing on uh
House Bill
1562 relative to personal watercraft few
things uh members of the
committee
uh if you need to get up you move around
it's going to be a long hearing you
don't need to ask permission just get up
and go and you you need a break or
anything like that uh this is a public
hearing we're here to listen to
the
public uh is we will be the members of
the committee may ask questions not this
is we're not won't tolerate
argumentative uh
Behavior Uh we just everybody has a
right to speak but you know also we have
a right to Courtesy so uh with that I
think I'll uh get the get it started
any anything else from members of the
committee if not thank you very much
chair
run thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you committee um I'm I come before
you to introduce House Bill
1562 um as background some of you who
were here in 2018 2019 may remember
legislation that was introduced by
representative Jason Javin from Seabrook
he um was very concerned about an issue
in his district where uh personal
watercraft that were um enjoying the
Hampton seab Brook Estuary were
disturbing and destroying some of the
environmental features of that area
specifically clam beds and Marsh Grass
so he introduced a bill to restrict the
travel of those vehicle those machines
through that area and at that time he
brought forward a definition which is
you know integral to legislation to
Define what what is being uh the topic
of the reg of the
regulation um about he defined it as
personal watercraft which has come to
commonly be accepted in New Hampshire
and throughout the world as two or three
Cedar individual watercraft so an
expansion of the what was historically
one Cedar standup jet skis or jet craft
so he introduced this definition because
those were the machines that were
causing issues in CBR
Campton and I clearly remember as if it
was yesterday the testimony of Captain
dunlevy from Marine Patrol who when we
were when the committee was questioned
ing him about these types of craft said
that the statutes are filled with
conflicting definitions obsolete
definitions different
terminology and
um I got a sense that you know he
realized this this was an issue and um
on that bill on representative jamin's
Bill we had a subcommittee and I was a
member of that subcommittee and we
decided not to address those other
definitions like we were just going to
look at the substance because it was so
confusing so when I had been hearing
from people in The Lakes Region and
advocacy groups about the fact that um
New Hampshire statutes address the one
seaters but there's such a gap in
statute about addressing the two or
three seeders unless it came from Senate
uh representative Jan's bill which did
eventually get passed into law um or
another bill which pass pass a year or
two later from Senator Sherman which
applied restrictions of of those crafts
in the Rye Estuary and and around the
New Castle area and some of you may have
been on the field trip we took to
actually look at that area um that that
definition of the two and three seeders
are not included in statute except for
that they are just kind of out there
they're considered as boats if you've
ever seen one of these machines they're
a lot of fun to ride I've ridden on them
and they're great but they are not a
boat I guess that's a matter of
opinion but um so I I took it upon
myself to kind of clarify the statute
address some of the current concerns
I've been hearing from people and
Captain dun love really underestimated
how complicated this is in statute it is
like trying to straighten out a bowl of
spaghetti um but so HB 1562 is an
attempt to do that and um I do want to
say that there has been a lot of
misinformation about this I have been
and I'm sure you have to have been
getting emails opposing this bill
because it's a ban on indivi on these
personal watercraft but I want to say to
you that HB 1562 does not ban personal
watercraft where such banned exist so
unless there's an existing ban on the
one seeders this is not adding a ban um
to a lake or water body where no such
ban exists for those personal watercraft
so I just want to state that up front
and um to go about
the um so if I and I sent you my
testimony um on Monday and there were
hyperlinks in there so you could just
kind of showing my work about um how
this is going to imp impact current
statute so if you go I went line by line
in that testimony and if you can on page
one of the bill um if you look at line
seven8 and nine uh and you'll see
there's no new language in this bill but
it is it's it's just modifying current
language and statute so it's taking
current language where we refer to ski
craft and it's changing that to personal
watercraft um and and but on lines 10
and 15 um it deletes the definition of
personal watercraft or ski craft for
machines that are less than 13 ft in
length um and that um hold two writers
and it inserts the definition on lines
15 to 17 the definition that was used in
representative janen Bell um and so it
it it brings it up to the typical
machine that's Now using in New
Hampshire Which is less than 177 ft and
may have two or three or any number of
riders um and then we see more on line
18 on page one where it it does update
that terminology from to uh personal
watercraft and if you look at any um
commercial or trade Association websites
you will see that personal watercraft is
the common term um ski craft is used
more in referring ref ing to a branded
machine um so and then line 21 it's just
making a grammatical error uh removing
the space between water and craft as
it's used as one word and it adds a
description um of the paragraph for what
is going because that paragraph is the
prohibition in amher in Hampton sa Brook
so it's just specifying what that
paragraph is
about and on lines 22 and 23 it removes
the definition since it is already
throughout chapter so the goal of this
bill is to move forward on a common and
consistent definition and
terminology of any in personal
watercraft that is um used in New
Hampshire waterways um and and propelled
by water
jet um and then we're I think there's a
lot of
confusion and um and a lot of emotional
reaction is when we get to the bill on
page the page two of the bill um you
will in the in the first RSA that's
modified um there's changes in the
terminology from ski craft to personal
watercraft this is when it comes to boat
fees but it only um boat fees are exempt
if the craft is less than 10 feet so it
really this that that RSA doesn't apply
to usage as much as it applies to um the
the the fees that are placed on that uh
that vessel and then in RS and then the
next paragraph it changes the
terminology um and it updates the de
definition that I explained on on the
first page using um the the definition
when representative janen brought his
bill
forward now um the real gist I guess the
heart of this bill comes down to when
there are people on a lake that want to
petition the department of
safety um oh actually let me back up a
27074 um the bill changes the
terminology from ski craft to personal
watercraft in the heading but in
addition to existing requirements for
personal watercraft 12T or shorter
watercraft longer than this but less
than 17 ft now those machines have to
apply um or or have some additional
regulation that was never applied to
them before as a personal watercraft one
is the operator has to be 16 years or
age of older only operate between the
hours of sunset and sunrise and sunset
require the operator to wear a flotation
device device um and then not operate
where watercraft are prohibited by law
or by the department specifically
prohibited in RSA
270 um sections 75 and 109 and I and I
want to point out that those sections in
particular because there have been bills
um in in in the last few decades where
there would be a legislator that would
um file a bill that would specifically
restrict to prohibit a what we would
call as a personal
watercraft from a specific Lake Pond or
river so for instance there could be a
legislator says I this bill shall
prohibit this or restrict this machine
from Sunrise lake or uh babus lake or
something like that a very specific
statute and if that passed into law
this um and it if it used the term ski
craft those larger machines would now be
under that statute but many restrictions
on New Hampshire Lakes have occurred
because of a petition hearing a
petitioned hearing with the Department
of Safety and this is where 10 or more
residents of a community they could be
Lake residents they could just be in the
town petition the department of safety
to hold a hearing whether to restrict
water in personal watercraft from that
Lake and in that statute for um those
hearings the definition that is used is
those single seaters it's the less than
12 feet
um um but there's no um ability in that
statute for those for those members of
the public to ask the department of
safety to consider a restriction or a
ban on on personal watercraft that
exceed that length um so what this bill
would do would be allowing those
residents um the opportunity to have a
public hearing with the Department of
Safety to enable them to make a
determination whether those larger
crafts should be restricted or banned
from that water body at that hearing the
there's several considerations that have
to be made one is the impact that the
personal watercraft has on the
environment the shoreline and Wildlife
um to the surface area of the lake river
being considered the uses which have
been established for that Lake Ponder
River the depth of the water the amount
of waterborne traffic but the hearing
officer must always and this is in
statute consider the necessity of
ensuring access to and use of the lake
Ponder River for all individuals and
their rights to appropriate use of the
lake so so the the the the individual's
right to use that those state waters has
to be a consideration in in that hearing
and then safety is always going to be a
consideration at the department of
safety hearings so those considerations
don't change but now they can be applied
to watercraft that have an extra two or
three seeds to it and the reason these
hearings and this part this statute is
so important is that every Lake Pond
Road River in New Hampshire is different
we have a thousand of them some are big
and shallow some are small and deep some
have a lot of Coes some have are are in
an area where there's a lot of
recreational activity and so these
herings focus on the specific features
of that water body and its uses and so
instead of having blanket regulation
across the state on how these machines
can be appropriately used and safely
used for health and environment these
hearings are important because they hone
in on the specifics and the uniqueness
of that water body and I think that's
really really important that we maintain
this ability in our state to not have
blanket regulation or blanket laws that
apply to everything no matter how
different those things are and so the
the the nice thing with the hearing
officer and that public hearing is that
brings in those stakeholders to that
water body and it looks at all those
specifics of that water body and makes a
sound judgment on the appropriate use of
these
machines so I just wanted to update that
the other regulations um um you'll see
there's there's still there's there's
one RSA that where the terminology is
changed um so that it would pre it would
um prevent those larger machines from
modifying their muffler system
to change their noise levels um the RSA
270 colon
113 that's an important one because
that's one of those specific rulings
that um bans personal watercraft from um
the the Canon Street Lake and that this
is where if those smaller machines were
banned now those larger machines are now
banned because they go back to that
definition um and then RSA 487 colon
16-3
changes the defin the terminology from
ski craft to personal watercraft um
holding now those larger machines to
regulations as far as the spread of
aquatic invasive species right now they
are not um they are exempt as personal
watercraft from being um restricted or
or being in violation of the spread of
those um invasive species so I just want
to State again that despite right
misinformation that you may have heard
or read HB
1562 does not ban personal watercraft
where no such ban existed
before if personal watercraft is allowed
on a water body it will continue to be
allowed um and for those water bodies
that restricted personal watercraft by
Statute those restrictions will extend
to the personal
watercraft um if hp1 1562 is passed um
now back in December when I was working
on this bill I reached out to the
Department of Safety to their attorney
and I wanted to clarify that if there
were restrictions or bans that were the
result of the Department of Safety
public hearing would this bill apply
retroactively so for exence if there was
a lake that banned the single Ceder um
ski craft would would that ban now
extend to larger machines and at that
time um attorney Christopher Casco from
the Department of safy said no that
there would have to be specific um
language in the bill that would make it
retroactive and I told him that was not
my intent and um but I did ask him to to
clarify that and provide testimony and I
I don't know if this um I think this
email went to everybody um it it came in
very you know right before 9:00 but I do
want to read um a key part of this and
I'll make sure all of you get it um I
didn't have time to print it out but it
said because there was a public hearing
process resulting in the adoption of
administrative orders prohibiting ski
Craft on some lakes ponds or Rivers a
future statute like this one unless it
specifically seeks to do so should not
replace those rules without a new
hearing the public is entitled to a
hearing before a change the prior rules
prohibited ski craft not personal
watercraft and the two terms are
distinctly different consequently there
should not be retroactive application as
doing so frustrates the intent of the
prior
legislation so if there is a lake Pond
or river that the public seeks to
restrict um the use of the person
watercraft these larger machines even
though they may have a prior Banner
restriction on the smaller one they have
to petition the department of safety
there has to be a new hearing a new
consideration under those those
considerations I read to you before that
that Banner restriction could go in
place on these larger
machines so um I hope I didn't confuse
you more I know this is very complicated
and um definitely Captain dunlevy was
correct in 2019 when he said that the
statutes pertaining to this is very very
confusing um it it was an understatement
but I would be happy to take any
questions that you
have thank you representative we have
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um
representative BR um so you're like you
said you not intending to ban watercraft
did you get uh feedback from uh
residents that this is important so it's
not just a clerical bill but this is you
know there's concerns about personal
watercraft on New Hampshire water
bodies I'm I'm sorry I couldn't hear you
could you repeat the question I'm sorry
representative
Darby thank you um I um what I was
trying to ask representative Rong is I
understand you're not trying to ban uh
water C personal watercraft but did you
receive uh concerns from um from uh Lake
users uh on the use of personal
watercraft which is which brought which
uh which is why you brought this bill
forward yes thank you very much for the
question representative um I I've heard
from a lot of people about this and
there are people um and I I truly
empathize with them they they spend a
lot of money on these personal
watercraft and this this this bill is
trying to close a loophole because
historically we think of personal
watercraft in statute as less than 12 ft
single seeders some of them are standup
and so there's been a loophole since the
market has now included these larger
machines and so people that have been
concerned about the use of the smaller
ones that their concern extends to the
larger one and usually their concerns
have to be around erosion of the
shoreline um they they may be um
disturbing aquatic plants that may be
important to the Shoreline um
ecosystem um those are mainly the the
largest concerns and so the it in their
minds there's not a difference between
the single seater and the two or three
seater they see that as the same machine
it's just an evolution of the technology
that allowed these larger machines to be
manufactured um so that's the main
concern but those concerns if if people
have had those concerns they have to
have a new hearing they have to petition
again because if they had those concerns
and success in restricting the smaller
machines under under the
27074 they would have to go through that
whole process for the larger machines
and and then some of the the and and I
know people that that use these machines
on leges and they use them very
responsibly they're not um some of the
you know restrictions or you know um the
no wake zone or using flotation devices
they're doing that anyway so having to
comply with the the regulations we have
on the smaller craft I don't think a
responsible personal watercraft owner is
going to have an issue with that because
that's just being responsible but now
they fall under the definition of um
machines that have to abide by that I
did I answer your question okay thank
questions representative mq thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative R just to
clarify for myself and for the audience
this this bill like you said doesn't
enact a new ban on lakes where no ban
currently exists
but it does expand the band the ban to
include more types of
watercraft boats jet skis pwc's whatever
on lakes where a ban already exists like
Lake kosaka for for instance and others
do I have that correct and it also makes
it easier to add bands on lakes through
the hearing process which already exists
this adds that hearing process to other
types of boats do I understand it
correctly uh yes I believe you do
representative so for instance if you
you brought up lake kisaka lake kisaka
back in I don't even know could have
been 89 early 90s went through the
hearing process they filed a petition
they had a hearing with department of
safety department of safety looked at
the depth of the lake the size of the
lake the impact on Shore and made a
determination that single SE or ski
craft which were defined at that time as
single Cedar were not allowed on Lake
kosaka now since that time the larger
craft the two and three seeders have
become popular they're pretty much what
you see in the market today um they
still have full use of the lake I don't
know I have not heard from anyone from
Lake hanasaka even though I do have a
summer Cottage on there I have not heard
it is not the concerns about this have
not come from anybody on that Lake um
so I don't know if people on that Lake
would go through the hearing process to
restrict it we do have those larger
machines on the lake I have no problem
with them they they go in the Deep areas
of the lake they stay out of the
shallows um but there may be some lakes
that have gone through the hearing
process have had single
Cedar um ski CFT band and now they may
they may want to go through that hearing
process to have that a ban on the larger
machines that's really up to them that's
democracy if the public really wants to
have bring change about they have that
opportunity through the hearing process
to do that they they can have that and
the hearing officer would have to look
at all those considerations and one of
them is the rights of the individual to
have use in Access of that water
body follow up so
so this bill would would ban those
larger crafts on lakes like kisaka that
currently have a Chet skki ban right
because of the change of the definition
it would include them the issue the
issue I think you mentioned was
retroactivity and that is a little bit
unclear yeah um no what what um the
attorney from the Department of Safety
in
his his uh testimony that was submitted
this morning I don't know if all of you
got it I got it right before the hearing
um and I know Captain dunloy is here he
may be able to speak to it as well um if
a single cedar or the old definition of
um ski craft was banned or restricted on
a lake through the hearing
process that does not apply to these
larger machines it does not apply that
was an administrative decision if larger
machines should be banned if there are
people that want to have restricted or
banned they have to start from scratch
with the hearing process to do that so
this does not if if there's been a ler
water body where there has been no ban
on the single Cedar this does not apply
a ban on these larger craft for those
water
bodies thank you Mr chair representative
Dar thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question just to just to uh
use examples like like uh kinaka I think
you're saying that since that was banned
through the RSA 27074 a process that it
wouldn't be
retroactively um it wouldn't be at
retroactive but Laurel Lake which is in
Fitz William which ski crafter banned by
RSA
2774 explicitly banned by Statue it
would be retroactively is that what
you're saying
um yes if there was a specific statute
that said this bill bans ski craft from
Lake
X
and now these larger machines would be
banned from Lake X because that was a
specific statute on a specific body of
water and I would recommend that if
there are people that disagree with that
that they don't believe that those craft
should be banned from that specific Lake
um there should be a bill filed to
resend that statute that's usually what
we do in in as legislators if there is a
law in place that has a specific ban or
restriction uh and we don't want that
anymore we just resend the resend the
law followup thank you Mr chair thank
you again for taking my question so the
email that you referenced from um Mr CCO
um also mentioned that it may be
appropriate to have an amendment to
clarify the um that that's not
retroactive would you be open to a
subcommittee to um to work on such an
amendment oh absolutely um I would be um
because it uh attorney
CCO had that opinion in December it's
it's confirmed today in this in this
document but if it helps the the
committee bring more distinction to the
legislative intent I would be happy to
um another another issue that's Arisen
through this and and we have to think
that that hearing process that was a law
that was uh the result of a bill
filed in
um
1989 by the late Senator Susan McLean
and former Congressman Charlie bass when
he was a New Hampshire representative so
talk about a blast from the past um and
in that bill that set up the hearing
process it required 10 residents or 10
citizens to file that petition and I do
agree that an amendment could include
changing that to 20 um so I'm I'm really
too I see no other questions for the
representative thank you for your
thank
you
the chair calls uh representative uh at
Coker
to speak
against the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you members of the committee so for the
record my name is Matt ker I represent
the town of Meredith in bellnap second
district and uh I am uh rise in
opposition for uh House Bill
1562 if you do look down and notice I am
a co-sponsor on the bill um so I
remember I was talking to a local
business owner and she said hey I'm kind
of curious why are you signed on to this
bill and I can't read Pete after she
brought up a couple details about how
expansive this was and some of the kind
of like side roads that this bill took
into the 270 74a in the hearing process
I I can't repeat exactly what I said but
I was like I I made a mistake um so um I
generally tried to support uh any
legislation that is going to help our
Lakes out and you know the lakes for a
lot of people in here that's their
source of income and for the town of
Meredith that's a huge revenue and a
huge boost to our local economy so I'm
always down to uh take care of our Lakes
but this bill is just not the right way
to do it um the biggest issue that I
have with it is it it it it isolates one
group of craft that don't I I I haven't
seen anything convincing that they're
uniquely bad for our lakes or cause any
kind of damage that um that other
vehicles don't pose and there are some
sensitive areas I believe that we need
to protect and I think there's solutions
that we can do to protect them but this
this bill is a hammer and taking from
the uh Prime sponsor uh you know these
the rsas around this are I think she
said spaghetti they're very complicated
it's it's really mixed up I think the
the original bill was in was put in in
1989 um I was three years old in 1989
the the the market the for these types
of vehicles was completely different so
I think just changing a definition is
going to open up a can of worms that's
one unfair to people who bought these
vehicles with a certain expectation of
where they're going to use them uh it's
way too broad and I think it's going to
really harm law- abiding citizens who
aren't causing the problems um again I
think a very surgical solution for
pretty much
any I guess uh boatcraft that are or
personal watercraft that are on the
water or any boat that's causing
problems in sensitive areas is a better
solution than just something like this
because again you know I've heard three
different opinions from three different
lawyers if this is retroactive we didn't
talk about the acreage of the Lakes this
bill would retroactively knock out any
lakes that are would knock these um
craft off on any lakes that are 75 Acres
or less you know then that they might be
deep Lakes there's there's there's a lot
of just questions that this brings up so
I think a better approach to this would
be to itl this bill and if there's
specific issues that that need to be
addressed it should I think kind of the
hard task of really reaching back and
and
redoing things where there are issues is
a much better approach than to just
change the definition and just cause 200
more problems so that's about it if
anybody has any questions I'm more than
willing to take
committee representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you representative Koker
for taking my question
um do you do you believe that um
personal watercraft um that don't have
sides for example gun gunal on their
boats should be um should be regulated
like boats or more like similar
watercraft um you know that's that's a
hard question I I don't there's I I mean
having sides I mean I think that's more
of like a safety issue for for
individual people
um I I don't think it's an environmental
issue and this bill is more focused on
the environmental aspect of it okay
thank
you any other members of the
committee I'm I'm glad I wore this my
neck is going to be hurting if they go
forth I I should have wearing
mirrors chair swivel chair yeah don't
even have that
okay any see no one else thank you very
much thank
you
uh the
uh actually what I normally do is I
go one for one against one for one
against well there is one other person
who's here four so I will recognize uh
Michael
Wright speaking for the
Bill thank you chair thank you uh
committee
members uh my name is uh Michael Ry and
I reside in Littleton New Hampshire um
as a a lifelong resident and an Ardent
Boer on our state's waterways I strongly
advocate for House Bill uh
1562 this bill is vital for addressing
the the unique challenges uh that are
posed to our state by personal
watercraft while ensuring that local
communities retain the ability to
regulate them responsibly or at least
have a seat at the table HB uh 1562 will
update the definition of personal
watercraft and state law and essentially
closing a regulatory loophole and it's
necessary to enhance safety and
regulation on our lakes and water bodies
throughout the years I've enjoyed
various watercraft uh watercraft
activities in New Hampshire in fact um I
first learned to water ski behind an
aluminum boat when I was 12 years old
with an 18 horsepower motor uh I enjoyed
sailing uh paddle Bo boating fishing and
canoeing however over the last dozen
years I've witnessed firsthand the
increasing challenges and risks posed by
the proration of personal watercraft
particularly particularly on the smaller
lakes and the narrow waterways I believe
that Public Safety should be a Paramount
concern while undoubtedly enjoyable
personal watercrafts often off operate
not everybody but with little regard to
safety and regulations and the
well-being of other boers and Lake
users uh many operators fail to observe
markers some markers even denoting
underwater rocks putting themselves and
their passengers at risk their tendency
to operate too close to Shore and danger
swimmers creates potential hazards for
other watercraft and accelerates uh lak
Shore
erosion the rising presence of personal
watercraft in New Hampshire especially
on the smaller Lakes has become a source
of public nuisance and safety of other
boers such as kayakers and canoers
limited passing room in small Coes and
narrow areas exacerbates the problem
leading to congestion and unsafe
conditions for all
users moreover the lack of Marine Patrol
presence on many of our Lakes has
allowed personal watercraft to operate
unchecked turning our Lakes into chaotic
and potentially dangerous environments
this indiscriminate use of these
watercraft particularly by inexperienced
operators poses significant risk to
Public Safety in the Integrity of our
Lakeshore House Bill 1562 offers a
crucial opportunity to address these
pressing concerns by updating the
definition of personal watercraft in
state law the bill clarifies terminology
and ensures that regulations keep Pace
with advancements in the watercraft
technology I want to EMP ize and many
people have done this already today that
house bill 1562 does not impose as many
have suggested a blanket ban on jet skis
or or ski crafts but it simply out
updates outdated rules to allow
municipalities a seat at the table to
regulate personal watercraft more
effectively by empowering communities to
petition uh the department of safety the
possibility exists to create targeted
personal watercraft regul ation
according to the local needs the
uniqueness of the lakes and other
priorities this legislation Fosters it
more of a collaborative approach to
watercraft management it enables
communities to keep Pace with
advancements in personal watercraft
technology and address the evolving
challenges posed by their use on our
lakes in conclusion I urge the committee
to support HB 1562 and I recommend its
passage uh to uh to the New Hampshire
House of Representatives as ought to
pass by enacting this legislation we can
take a significant step towards
safeguarding the safety and enjoyment of
our lakes and waterways for generations
to come thank you and I'm open to taking
any questions if you have
committee thank you see none okay thank
you do you there your testimony do you
want to have it in the record of yes I I
have a few copies here should I just Dr
yeah we can at least put it in the uh in
the hands of the clerk or if you can
pass yes sir bring it
down and hand it to the representative
and he'll pass it to the
clerk who's oh he's got some at least
some to the clerk was actually right
behind
us
I don't
pass
okay chair recognizes Jody grimas
representing the New Hampshire Marine
trades
Association thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee can you hear me
okay I'm not used to
this get Clos y okay got it for the
record my name is Jody RIS I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association in strong strong
opposition to House Bill
1562 um I will politely disagree with
the sponsor of the bill on what the bill
actually does when it comes to personal
watercraft we believe it does include
significant bans and opportunities for
future bans on personal
watercraft um if the sponsors choose not
to uh require the bands on the on the
bill excuse me let me start again if the
sponsor of the bill do not apply to
attend apply the current
administratively enacted band on ski
craft to the broader definition of
personal rocraft we believe the bill
would need to be amended but we ask you
not even to go that far let me just
start with what we believe the bill does
the bill singles out three and four
Cedar personal watercraft that have been
registered and regulated as a boat in
New Hampshire for over 30 years and
reclassifies them to the most
restrictive category of vessels cons
called a ski craft it's a significant
change in operation and
restrictions this is not a simple
clarification and a change of definition
this is a major change in policy on how
personal watercraft are treated under
New Hampshire laws and how it impacts
Public Access for those who use them
pursuant to house bow 1562 we believe
the following restrictions in banss
would be applied to personal
watercraft all lakes under 75 Acres
which there are 390 bodies of water in
this category would be baned and
pursuant to chapter law 283 of the laws
of
1988 the first bill on this topic that
passed into law was in
1988 and that was the bill to Define ski
craft and establish those restrictions
so all bodies of water under 75 Aces
would immediately be restricted and
banned to personal
watercraft number two operating
restrictions there would be new
operating restrictions as the sponsor
said regarding safe passage instead of
150 be 300 in various CES
ETC number three it would be banned from
bodies of water prohibited by law again
pursuant to chapter law 283 laws of 1988
there are 15 additional bodies of water
that ban ski craft including Squam Lake
one of the largest lakes in the state so
if you
are the Squam Lake bands ski craft today
under that law it would ban personal
watercraft as of the result of this
bill and again the the contention
different In Contention is banned on
lakes pursuant to the hearings under RSA
27074 a now in our research of the bill
we had talked multiple times to Marine
Patrol about our reading of the bill
that that would be included we talked to
a senior staff attorney at OSS who also
agreed that that would be included in
the bands so I think what I'm finding is
that if you ask a different attorney you
get a different answer so it's clearly
not clear there are n 90 over 90 bodies
of water that have full or partial bands
that were ordered by the department of
safety as part of these administrative
hearing process those may or may not
depending on if there's a potential
Amendment apply to personal watercraft
so we're looking at 390 bodies of water
plus an additional 15 plus the Canan
Street Lake so there's
406 plus these that's almost 500 bodies
of water that would be banned to
personal watercraft depending ending how
you decide to move forward we ask that
you don't um I would note about the
hearing process we do not favor the
hearing process when you look at what
happened two RSA 27074 a the hearing
process was established by law in
1989 between 1989 and 1991 three Summers
70 bodies of water were banned through
that process so it is a quick turnaround
for a petition process personal
watercraft are not subject to that
hearing process they would be under
house B
1562 so two thoughts on that hearing
process one and we've discussed this in
Prior legislation before the committee
if you are going to pass this bill and
establish this hearing process for this
new type of craft personal watercraft
there is no fiscal note on the bill and
the department of safety has already
said they would need additional hearing
officers to accomplish this goal they
have one hearing officer in the bureau
of hearings that does watercraft
hearings because there are less than a
handful each year this would create many
more so if there needs to be if you're
going to pass this legislation you need
to find some money because there is
nothing in this bill that gives an
appropriation for those additional
staff also on a broader perspective we
believe the issues relating to Banning
access to State bodies of water should
be debated in this
legislature 6 months of hearing process
through the house house through the
Senate with a decision by the governor
that is what should be required for the
weight of taking law-abiding citizens
off a state body of water not a one-day
hearing with a department of safety
petitioned by 10 people with a decision
being made by a hearing officer and a
commissioner that's not
fair finally let's talk about the
history of this issue and why it brings
so much passion from
voters between the years of 1991 to 20
2003 there were at least nine pieces of
legislation whose premise was the same
as House Bill
1562 at the heart of those debates was
the definition the proposals to ban and
restrict personal watercraft and the
rights to Public Access many of those
hearings took place in this chamber just
as we are here
today um I have to admit I was involved
in many of them I've been doing this for
30 years and I started in
1995 these bills were fiercely debated
and they never passed the legislation
so in my opinion the legislative intent
is to leave it alone they are boats and
they should be regulated as
boats in 2019 there was specific
legislation to carve out the Sea Coast
the estuaries and the marshes it should
be noted there were additional pieces of
legislation in 2020 and 21 to expand
those particular restrictions broader
the governor vetoed one of those bills
because he was concerned about public
access in 2022 as mentioned before
Senator Sherman brought in a piece of
legislation to correct what was
currently passed in the 2019 law on the
Sea Coast because actually a selectman
from the town of Hampton realized that
he could no longer use his personal
watercraft in Hampton Harbor so they had
to make sure they corrected that Public
Access restriction and made it very
specific to the marshes in the estuaries
and that is what was become
law there's strong opposition to the
bill from the boting public as
demonstrated on the online portal I
think it was over 800 to around 50 in
support 800 opposed 50 in support and
here's why people work hard today life
can be difficult and stressful so when
you find something that brings you peace
brings you outside gives you a mental
health break and time to spend with your
family you don't want to see government
take that opportunity
away we believe that there's no
justification for changing the
classification of personal watercraft
from a boat it should remain the same as
it is today we believe that it would uh
risk Public Access or ban Public Access
um impair people's boat in their
Investments and really turn a popular
form of recreation into just Jeopardy
and not non-existent so if there are
problems we truly ask that we consider
further education and certainly we all
know we need more law enforcement in
this state for the Marine Patrol um I'm
happy happy to take any questions I do
have a copy of that 1988 law I will tell
you you cannot find it on the um system
because it only goes back to 1989 and I
had to go back to the books at the State
library to get that chapter law where
those bands are in place so thank you
very much and I'm happy to answer any
questions any questions by members of
the
committee representative representative
Derby thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question um so most of the
many of the concerns you raised were
with respect to
retroactivity um I understood that uh
representative rang was willing to have
a an amendment or subcommittee to talk
about to amend the bill to avoid those
uh uh retroactive uh retroactive cases
so
what can you quickly enumerate the
concern concerns that would be that
would not be alleviated by sure thank
you we to be very clear we would oppose
we oppose this bill and we oppose any
amendment that even addresses the
retroactivity um for two reasons one
there's about 4 six lakes that are not
considered retroactive they are
statutory bands those would take place
immediately as the the Lakes under 75
Acres that are currently in statute as
well as the 15 um lakes in the can
Street Lakes so there's about 4 106
there um with regard to the 90 over 90
bans that have come through
administrative hearing we oppose the
administrative hearing process being
applied to personal watercraft personal
watercraft have been considered boats
for 30 years there's no reason to put
them under a new hearing process I don't
see the support for it and we think it's
idea thank thank you I one thing any
representative who's out of my site and
you want to make a you want to have a
so representative
Lon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so do you believe
that in cases where the department of
safety through a hearing process has
already banned jet skis and um do you
believe that they're wrong and that
there is there are not situations in
which it was appropriate to ban the jet
skis or possibly other
watercraft I don't think those I'm not
going to aine on something that happened
in
1989 to 91 I wasn't there at those
hearings I don't know what was said but
here's what I know when you're Banning
people from a state body of water it
should be a legislative decision it's
not that I we work with the Department
of Safety all the time they are some of
our closest Partners but this is a
decision that's meant for the the
legislature you're taking law-abiding
ciens and telling them they cannot use
something on the water I think it's a
legislative decision it shouldn't be at
the department of safety um followup
question for a
followup
um but well one I I don't believe that
we're Banning individuals from the water
but uh do you see any relevance
to trying to be very specific
to not say we're going to have one ban
which is not a ban but one set of rules
for a very small pond versus Lake wiip
pasak do you see any um point to to
local control and looking at very
specific
question these are State bodies of water
um they are held in any any body of
water 10 acres or more in the state of
New Hampshire is held in public trust by
the state for the use of everyone here
in New Hampshire I do think that the
decision- making should stay at the
state level which is the
legislature okay thanks thank you any
members seeing none do you have a copy
of your testimony we passed out the red
packets and so there's information the
only thing I will get you though is this
um this chapter law because again I
couldn't okay if do you have any other
Library so I will forward that up thank
you okay Amy is it
Landers uh Lake Region uh tourism
Association thank you nice to see you
and speak really loud okay and I say
that also rather the other members of
the
committee my name is Amy Landers and I'm
the executive director of The Lakes
Region tourism Association for the past
24 years the association represents over
450 businesses in The Lakes Region as
well as central New Hampshire we promote
the Lakes Region and central New
Hampshire instate out of state and
internationally in order to welcome
visitors from all over the world to New
Hampshire I'm here today to oppose House
Bill 156 2 relative to the personal
watercraft and later this afternoon
house build 1390 relative to wake boats
and wake Sports recreational boating is
an important aspect of New Hampshire's
tourism economy our recreational boating
industry contributes approximately 1.4
billion annually to New Hampshire's
economy and supports over 6,000 direct
and indirect jobs here in the state New
Hampshire is one of the top states where
the outdoor recreation economy
represents significant percentage of the
state's GDP according to the Bureau of
economic analysis on outdoor recreation
in
2019 generally boating and fishing
contribute top sectors of our outdoor
economy when visitors choose where
they're going to spend their summer
vacation they have a choice a broad
choice of activities offer by our region
is to attct many different demographic
of consumers to the state of New
Hampshire a strong summer tourism is
important for the state as well as this
is our second leading industry here in
New Hampshire bills like H House Bill
1562 and House Bill 1390 will ban or SE
severely restrict certain segments of
our boats from our New Hampshire's Lakes
Banning personal water craft ra as a as
proposed in House Bill
1562 is a mistake these watercraft are
popular and have been used appropriately
for over 30
years there has been no outcry of safety
concerns among this popular family
activity wake Sports have also been
popular in New Hampshire for at least 20
to 30 years again with no outcry of
safety and very popular among amilies to
ban these sports or severely restrict
people's abilities to enjoy our state's
public bodies of water is inconsistent
with the messages that we're promoting
to the public there is a better bill in
the senate senate Bill 431 that seeks a
buffer and to help with the safety
versus Banning for weight surfing we
should prefer this less restrictive
policy when it comes to regulating
voting activities not the most
restrictive choice to tourists have
means having the ability to enjoy our
voting in voting throughout the season
they can also enjoy a hike up Mount
Major or perhaps a rainy day going to
the arcade or one of our beautiful
museums but again these are choices this
is what makes New Hampshire special and
attracts visitors to our state if we
take away these choices we harm our
tourism economy which will impact the
state of New Hampshire and have a great
tax again legislation that bans certain
segments of voting like House Bill
1562 and House Bill 1390 send the wrong
message that New Hampshire is unfriendly
to boating and therefore unfriendly to
visitors these bills could negatively
impact the real estate market in New
Hampshire people choose to buy a house
here and this could change where they
decide to buy their home with these with
these regulations in place less
residents mean additional loss of
workers which as we all know is a big
struggle here in our state these bills
are not good for New Hampshire not good
for our local residents and especially
not good for our instate and out of
state
visitors we do not want to hurt our
tourism economy if these issues need to
be addressed please consider policies
that increase education and enforcement
of the current laws Banning boats will
be bad for our businesses please oppose
House Bill
1562 and House Bill
1390 thank you for your time today and
questions any questions by members of
the
committee represent representative Derby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um is the Tourist U tourism
Association assoc uh interested in
encouraging all forms of um boating
activity and fishing activity including
kayaks canoes um other sort of uh loow
impact um water uses and are they
concerned about conflicts between um
between personal watercraft and those
lower impact uses
we have not had any safety concerns and
complaints relevant to being able to use
the waters using any type of um vessel
whether it's a uh as you mentioned a
canoe kayak or one of the bigger boats
um we also work with many of the Lakes
Association and the Mariners in order to
provide education through our website
and our printed materials and happy to
assist in any way to provide those
any other
questions thank you for your time thank
much this isn't yet calling I'm yet to
call on Kevin Dunley but we he will
eventually be up here I want to tell the
members of the committee if you have
some questions I think there are some
around interpretation and and things
like that on the law uh we can we can do
I won't not right at the moment but
write him down because I will be calling
that I know uh Dan
Bennett from the New Hampshire Auto
Dealers
Association there's nothing to do with
cars right uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh Dan Bennett
New Hampshire Auto Dealers Association
we're a trade group for the motor
vehicle industry here in New Hampshire
about 500 businesses 14,000 citizens um
car truck motorcycle snow wheel ATV
powerport construction farm equipment
dealers so um today I'm here on behalf
of about 40 or so of our powerport
dealers um in opposition to
1562 um you're going to hear from and
you already have heard from a variety of
speakers on a few different issues I'm
hopefully going to inject a new one um
to that discussion and and attempt to
not be uh repetitive um and the
Chairman's right typically you hear
about from us about uh roadway safety
issues and ohrv safety issues uh the ban
on texting while driving uh defending
safety inspections motorcycle rider
education uh but today what I want to
talk to you all about is um safety on
our Lakes okay it's our belief that this
bill will make Lakes certain Lakes less
safe in New Hampshire what you will do
is in fact increase congestion and
traffic which will likely lead to more
accidents injuries and even just
uncomfortable confrontations be it with
someone on a standup paddle board
personal watercraft or a larger boat so
we all know that our department of
safety of which Marine Patrol is part of
is is significantly underst staffed so
this increased burden on them um will
will not be a positive scenario so um in
the discussions that you all have and I
hope the conclusion that your reaches to
to vote inexpedient to legislate on this
particular bill um I hope you'll take
that safety concern um in into the
decision-making factor that you do so
with that being said um I'll take any
questions if any and also get a copy of
some written testimony to the
committee representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um since you're representing
the um powers Sports dealers can and
we've heard a lot about education and
how important that is can you can you
describe maybe how um the dealers of
personal watercraft are um purporting
safety measures for when they're selling
these craft yes so you know as mentioned
um you know safety is a primary concern
for dealers um we always include at all
of our dealers the digests that come
from um whether it be fish and gamer
Department of Safety that promotes
education certain manufacturers have
safety programs we do have a Boer
education program in the state that our
dealers are actively supportive of so I
think it's a it's a um it's a primary
concern and it's a messaging um that
that we always do be it be it boats snow
machines ohvs um it's constant amongst
our
membership any questions other questions
by members of the
committee seeing or hearing none thank
you very much thank you Mr
chairman
John
Association is that okay all right good
morning everyone my name is John Wally
I'm the general manager at Silver Sands
Marina and the president of the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association we
strongly oppose House Bill
1562 prior to my role at Silver Sans
Arena I worked at my family's power
sports dealership I grew up around
personal watercraft and has also called
jet skiis um I was able to see the
progression of The Craft and the
improvements and also see how they are
now recognized as boats in the state of
New Hampshire it's funny to be here
today because my dad Mike
wall um excuse me for a moment was
elected to the state legislature because
he felt as other a need for people like
himself and his customers to have
recognition and support there's a bench
behind you uh that's dedicated to him as
he was the House minority leader up
through 2008 before he passed away and
he felt it was a critical element to our
state New Hampshire to have Public
Access of our parks and our lakes and
personal watercraft include those
they're considered boats in the state of
New Hampshire I can tell you a funny
story my mother God L she's intimidated
by boats and she didn't want to drive a
boat with a propeller so she would
refuse to take my sister and myself
water skiing when my dad was at work so
because of jet ski is considered a boat
in the state of New Hampshire I be able
to go for a ride with her spot my sister
would water ski and I would water ski
and she would spot so because that was
considered a boat in the state of New
Hampshire they gave myself my sister
opportunity to SP top of my mother and
water ski and recreate in our Lakes as
all the other kids do too so don't take
that away from anybody please and
consider this and oppose
you any questions by for uh represent
for
representative I knew your father too
much I'm gonna start spreading out with
uh
individuals uh
George
okay yes this George Mullen my name is
George Mullen uh I live in Amherst New
Hampshire and I'm a uh opposed to this
bill House Bill
1562 um along with my family we own saan
Valley
Motorsports uh franchise multi-line
powerport dealer established in
2005 uh and we're located in Milford New
Hampshire nowhere near any body of
water we sell and service um I'm going
to call them pwc's for
ease motorcycles dirt bikes etvs and
utvs so Valley Motorsports is currently
responsible for providing income to 21
individuals and Families so as a
business owner I view this bill as a
threat to my
business while not the biggest dealer in
the state these products provide
significant Revenue during the summer
months through sales servicing and
providing the parts accessories and
safety equipment necessary for these
units by restricting PWC usage
on 90 Plus or whatever the number is
number of lakes I will be forced to
either turn in my um dealer for these
products dealership for these products
um and all the revenue that goes with
it in due to loss of
demand as a result we'll no longer be
able to support our current
customers um needs for servicing their
pwc's passing this bill
will have a significant negative impact
on my
business my customers and other
residents of New Hampshire who find this
form of recreation affordable and fun
will also be affected for those who
don't own waterfront property and that's
quite a few people the PWC provides an
affordable and easy way to access New
Hampshire lakes and waterways pwc's are
a versatile an easily transported way of
allowing people to travel and enjoy the
many different lakes throughout our
state don't discriminate discriminate
against families who don't own
waterfront property by restricting their
Lakes lastly I know of I know of no
study or report that states that a
personal watercraft has any more adverse
effect on Lake environments than a
typical propeller driven craft
pwc's due to their Hull design produce
very little weight and would affect and
would not affect shoreline erosion pwc's
are not the reason that algae or other
invasive species are
spread any more than from other powered
watercraft
or for that matter the runoff or of
contaminants from Shoreline
properties I think the thing to do is to
focus our attention legislative
legislatively possibly on the
enforcement and education uh of exist
existing laws op educating operators of
pwc's to lessen inappropriate behavior
any watercraft in in the hands of an
irresponsible operator is always going
to be a problem I'll open to questions
any questions by members of the
committee representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um in in other hearings on
other water sports we've heard about how
dealers um in try to um uh educate the
public uh educate um the purchasers of
the watercraft dra on how to uh coexist
um amicably with other users of the of
the water um does as a as a a dealer of
these um pwc's do you have a similar
education
program for the uh um p uh personal
watercraft we don't have a specific
educational program every unit that
leaves the store we do go through um an
education with the the purchaser of how
to use the watercraft how to safely use
the watercraft and what to you know you
need a a life jacket as an example so we
do go every
individual uh purchaser um our
dealership does have um
educational
um uh we do education of ohrv and
snowmobiles through the uh fishing game
department we do offer that but not with
the power
questions see no other questions thank
you very
great thank
you back
work
minutes good morning my name is Jake D
Silva of Meredith New Hampshire I'd like
to start off by saying thank you for
giving me the time to explain why I
oppose House Bill
1562 I'd like to point out today how
many folks are here to oppose the bill
as well as over 800 online who have
already opposed the bill um hb1 1562
will impact more than just where I can
ride my personal watercraft or known as
a PWC my family and I own multiple
businesses that would be directly impa
excuse me impacted by House Bill 1562 to
Silva Motorsports has been a New
Hampshire business for over 25 years
with two PWC dealerships in New
Hampshire as well as a PWC rental
business and I also own a food truck D
Sila Motorsport services and sells over
1,000 pwc's a year our PWC dealerships
are in Hamstead and molteno New
Hampshire house bill 1562 will ban pwc's
from 50% of the state's water bodies to
Silva Motorsports Hamstead location and
its customers are at risk of losing
seven lakes and ponds within a 10 mile
radius of if HP 5062 is passed to Silva
Motorsports molteno location and its
customers are at risk of losing 19 of 22
lakes with in a 20 M radius if HB 1562
is passed this is not just a change of
use but a full ban of personal
watercrafts the other Three Lakes within
the 20 milei radius of D Sila
Motorsports in molten bro wi basaki op
and Newfound Lake will will still be
impacted by 1562 with restrictions to
PWC
usage through the pandemic we understood
how important it was for outdoor
recreation where people could engage
along alone or within their Inner Circle
results from a Rec recent Penn State
study indicated that nearly half of
adults from across the United States now
to participate in outdoor recreation on
at least a monthly basis and
approximately 20% may be new to outdoor
recreation during the pandemic pwc's
opened the door for so many families to
get out on the water and enjoy the
beautiful state that we live in and
participate in outdoor recreation people
have invested in purchasing pwc's and HB
1562 does an injustice to these people
limiting where they can use their
machines with our rental company we
travel to different lakes in Southern
New hampsh Hampshire to the Lakes Region
to deliver pwc's to customers HB 1562
would kill over 50% of our business this
would force us to shut down the PWC
rental business the windy juice box is a
smoothie truck operated in Meredith New
Hampshire that like many others depends
on tourism as we all know tourism is a
large source of income for the State of
New Hampshire pwc's play a large role in
the tement to the Lakes Region pwc's
contribute to over 30% of new sales and
boat registrations in the state of New
Hampshire with HB 156 the decline in
sales would be a great would be a direct
correlation to the decline in tourism
the tourism we rely on as a community
will greatly devastate businesses
Statewide this will not only affect the
outdoor recreation business but our
hotels restaurants gas stations retail
shops and the small mom and pop stores
will be impacted by HB
1562 I can only imagine how poorly this
will affect the Lakes Region my industry
and thousands of other families that
call to Live Free or Die State of New
Hampshire their home HB 15 62 would not
only impact my family's business but
also the livelihood of our 27 employees
and their families please oppose House
Bill
committee representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um I uh I understood that you
Al part of your business is renting
pwc's um can you talk about the
education for um uh the the rentals in
particular in particular education about
reducing conflict with other water users
so whether you're purchasing a new cedu
or R we're renting a cido everybody that
rents or purchases to legally use them
in the state of New Hampshire has to
have a New Hampshire boers license so if
you are somebody that does not have a
New Hampshire boers license when you
come to rent them we you have to take a
license or a test to get your temporary
license so one of our employees is
authorized to give you the test so you
have to take the test and if you don't
pass you can unfortunately not rent the
SEO so everybody that is out in the
water should have their boer's
license and as Mr Mullen said every cido
that we sell and or rent we also go over
how to correctly use the machine they
have all proper safety gear on a on a
PWC there's no horn so a whistle a fire
extinguisher and um you know a life vest
obviously representative har for a
question yes thank you for taking my
question could for the record could you
tell us what your average sale price is
on a personal water CFT
um it's it's right under $155,000 or you
know I would say between we have some
that range at $6,000 and go all the the
way up over $20,000 and then with used
product so just uh we obviously sell a
lot more new product than than um than
you so the average is right around there
thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very
much chair calls Richard
Bono uh for two
minutes hello thank you for uh allowing
me to speak to you um I'm a personal
owner of myself of a personal watercraft
and I came to oppose uh
1562 um I just like to point out a
couple of things I looked at this myself
I kind of have a little bit of an
engineering background I tend to try to
look at things logically or at least in
my mind um looking at the original uh
rsay in the uh bill here uh the ski
craft mentioned in the original bills
they're very significantly different
than the modern personal watercraft that
most of us are talking about and
modifying this these rules uh most of
those ski craft I don't know if you've
ever been on one um they significantly
they operate significantly different I
want to point that out they tend to be
designed to be or they originally
designed to be very small light and
Nimble if you ever see one of these on
the water people are doing flips and and
tricks and all kinds of things on the
water having fun with them um as such
they they tend to be written that way if
they're if you try to ride them slowly
they don't have a lot of control and
when I say slowly I mean like in a no
wake zone I don't know how many of you
may be boers who have been on the water
and understand that in a no wake zone
you have to be as slow as you can those
things they're almost sinking when
they're going at a no wake speed so
they're almost impossible to control at
that speed and the operator has half
their body in the water because the
things are sinking at that speed um so
that's very
contrastingly different than these pwc's
the PWC operates as a boat you see many
families on them um mothers fathers with
their kids sitting between them driving
along and enjoying the environment is
significantly different um the current
Mar uh three-person PWC uh has a
fourstroke engine which is very quiet
very friendly to the environment matter
of fact mine is EPA rated is uh I think
they call it Ultra clean or something
like that I don't know all the exact
terms there's a decal right on my boat
saying how it does not pollute the
environment because it's an ultra clean
engine like modern engines are the old
jet ski types or these these uh uh older
ski craft tended to be two-stroke
engines very noisy very obnoxious so
when people saw them out in the water
they went oh I don't like to hear that
so they're very noisy um so that's one
thing the other thing is with the modern
PWC Mayan I literally there's a button
on it I can slow this thing down to 1
mph boats can't go that slow I can go
through a no wake speed so
slow boats behind me are almost honking
their horns saying get out of my way
because they can't go that slow they
have to put their engines into neutral
to go as slow as I can I can hover in
one spot it does not disturb the
environment it does not make a lot of
noise you wouldn't even hear me come up
behind you if you if if if I did uh
they're very quiet um so I'd like to
really emphasize this point the
difference between these older ski craft
which the original rsas uh uh had made
rules for because of many of these
concerns about speed noise uh pollution
and so forth the modern pwc's do not
have that problem they're very quiet and
efficient and can be ridden very very
slowly matter of fact uh um I'd invite
any of you if you wanted to witness this
yourselves it's not the right time of
year now but come on up in the summer
I'll be happy to take you for a ride and
let you experience this yourself because
they are very quiet fun and so forth
when operated safely um as as the PE
other people have mentioned you need
your uh life jacket and other safety
equipment um I strongly oppose this 1592
1562 I'm sorry any questions I'll be
happy to answer from a average
user any questions by members of the
committee
Sports good morning and thank you for
giving us this opportunity to speak
today regarding HB
1562 I'm Lisa miles um one of the owners
of HK Power Sports in hookit and Laconia
uh 48 years ago my father Steve Wally
and John's father Mike Wall-E opened our
power sports business and we've been
doing business selling Power Sports in
New Hampshire since
1976 um I actually was here 25ish years
ago and helped jod actually demonstrate
on the lake uh the differences between
these one passenger and two passenger
machines versus these three passenger
machines and why they are considered
boats um that obviously never passed
then and in my opinion should not pass
now and I am here to oppose HB
1562 this proposed bill would
drastically change the ability to use a
PWC in the state of New Hampshire today
three passenger watercraft which are 90%
of the personal watercraft that we sell
are considered boats in New Hampshire
which is a huge difference between a one
and two passenger that is considered a
ski
craft I would like to point out that
three seeder personal watercraft make up
30% of new boat sales in the state of
New Hampshire which is a very large
number
they're popular because they are very
affordable low maintenance easy to use
and easy to transport to smaller Lakes
if you aren't on the
waterfront um people purchase them now
even for fishing um people use them to
go out to dinner you don't get wet on
them anymore and they're extremely
environmentally friendly than even 30
years
ago pwcs are safe and have no risk of
propeller injuries like other boats and
they're easy to get on and off of um
people water ski behind them and tow
behind them learn how to water ski on
them we've done law loan programs with
fire departments for rescue because
these machines can get into places that
other machines cannot for years we sold
um watercraft to a program that UNH puts
on for teaching people with disabilities
how to water ski and they had to have
two watercraft to be able to get people
um up water ski or back into the
boat in 2023 our two stores alone sold
over 600 personal watercrafts in one
year because they are considered boats
we sell very few one and two passenger
ski craft we sell mostly the three
passenger and people seek them out
because they are considered boats and
because they are affordable to use our
average price is about $144,000 so
people can get on the lake in a boat
with three passengers for
$14,000 changing this law would hugely
limit how these families could get
accesses to lakes and New Hampshire the
result of limiting their use not only is
one of the many restrictions being
considered for boating in New Hampshire
but will affect the economy on and
around all of the lakes in this state
with the ever growing costs associated
with boating and lakefront homes
personal watercraft have remained the
most affordable boat to purchase and use
on many New Hampshire lakes and they
would be restricted on these smaller
lakes that you cannot use a one and two
passenger
watercraft I'd also like to speak on how
personal watercraft operate mechanically
so everyone has an idea of how they work
when considering the environmental
effects pwcs are fourstroke three
passenger crafts with a jet drive system
that is completely inside the hull
there's no exposed prop there's no lower
unit they draft only 11 Ines of water
when they're sitting and even less when
they're moving so you you have nothing
hanging into the water and disturbing
aquatic plant life the the propulsion is
at the very surface of the water and
they're very light craft so they do not
boats please consider the large effect
that hb1 1562 will have on boating and
recreating in New Hampshire and how it
would affect the economy if personal
watercraft are subject to the ski craft
restrictions and bans of the past and
then be open to more restrictions and
bans through the hearing process in the
future it singles them out for different
treatment than other boats I compare it
to if we wanted to restrict motorcycles
on certain certain roads in New
Hampshire it just doesn't make
sense it will severely limit
accessibility on more than half of New
Hampshire lakes and continue to take
away boting rights in New Hampshire
thank
much Alex
katsis from the Silva
Motorsports
three
minutes good morning uh I just wanted to
give a little background on myself um
when I was little around 10 years old my
family being an only child tried hard to
get me into boating nothing I ever
wanted to
do um with them uh 1999 we purchased our
first PWC and they figured maybe I would
like going on the water with my mom and
my dad doing that um and immediately I
did like that um we were able to go out
on a variety of different lakes growing
up we were never having a waterfront
property so we would always have to
trailer our boat or
PWC uh to each launch um so my family
were able to do that we went to a
variety of lakes a variety of lakes that
would be under the new band um we would
go to walki WAN in Meredith we would go
to Squam Lake um and so on so it
provided my family and I a great way of
getting out um something I did all
through High School uh and even College
one of the reasons why I went to
Plymouth State University was so that my
friends and I could still go out on the
water um May and uh in the fall
September uh when school is in session a
lot of the younger uh my younger friends
were able to purchase pwc's financially
over a boat um it's something growing up
that I was able to purchase myself even
through college um my average PWC cost
uh was around $5,000 per machine at the
time um so owning a boat if it wasn't
for PWC wouldn't be an option for me um
even once I met my wife uh we would go
out do our day trips um just provided so
much entertainment for just her and I to
just go to a lake go out for the day and
then be able to Trail her back home and
not have the extra cost of a boat um now
I have two young children both actually
prefer going out on pwc's over our
family boat now that we have um they
like that usually I'll take my daughter
out who's seven and my wife will take my
son out who's five and uh on a separate
machine um and we have a great day doing
that so they actually prefer going out
on the pwc's over the boat um the other
thing too is my wife who got her boers
license about 10 years ago I got mine
immediately when I turned 16 um she got
hers about 10 years ago she can't drive
a boat to save her life um with the
motor the steering wheel boats are a lot
harder to drive than pwc's and she can
drive a PWC very comfortably um most new
ones have brakes on them which boats
don't have um so her being able to take
my son out or um eventually as they get
a little bit older um is possible due to
a PWC she can't drive a boat even to
this day um so just about the financial
uh cost uh of it you know being a young
middle class having a young middle-
class family it's something we can do on
the Waterway we could not do it um most
of my late teens and early 20s if there
wasn't for PWC just I think with the
average price of a boat plus needing a
bigger vehicle to Trail her to the
different ramps and everything like that
so it just wouldn't have been
possible um I think another thing too is
some of my friends that got pwc's around
the same time I did they now boat so
pwcs is also a nice entry way for um
boating or it gives more of like that
middle class family a sense of being out
on the water that wouldn't be possible
without a
PWC um in terms of
also use I can be out on my PWC for
almost an entire day for around $50 in
fuel um a boat is at least double that
same thing with insurance same thing
with a vehicle to tow uh to the launch
um so it's just all around cheaper I do
believe it's safer um obviously I I
believe the law is uh children under 12
have to wear a life jacket if they're in
the boat or on a PWC well everyone on
the PWC is wear life jackets um so if an
accident was to ever occur you know you
have a life jacket on a boat you don't
uh yearly I'll hear about uh boating
fatalities because maybe a person fell
overboard and they drowned um maybe the
um propeller on the boat um every year
unfortunately you hear about a a young
child that usually is a fatality because
they get caught in the prop of the boat
with pwcs that doesn't happen um I don't
know the statistics off the top of my
head but I know very few PWC accidents
per year even I think if there was a
study done on
that um I think that's really it I just
wanted to just provide a little bit of
perspective from somebody that really
didn't like boating growing up as a
child I was able to do it with my family
immediately when they we purchased our
first one and then all the way through
now I know my family still prefers it
now um with our hectic lifestyle being
able to easily go out after work or um
you you know with the family is
something we can do and especially under
this new bill there would be lakes that
unfortunately we can't go to that my
children do like going to whether it be
Squam Lake Lake
wakwan um and a variety of other lakes
and rivers um that we use
currently any questions any questions by
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh maybe about time U um
is there are there questions on the
committee for uh Captain
Dunley I'm seeing some heads bob up and
or you really didn't want to hand out
that card
right
Captain Tim dunlevy Department of Safety
Marine
Patrol uh actually if you have any
comments uh that you want to give or do
you want to go right into questions uh
at this point I'm happy to entertain any
questions that you may have uh at this
time Department of Safety is not taking
a position on the bill okay thank any
questions by
representative by members of the
committee representative
Darby thank you Mr chair you read my
mind you might want to get closer to
your mic too it's okay thank you Mr
chair thank you uh Captain for taking my
question um I we've heard about some
concerns that this bill would ban um uh
ski Craft on lakes under 75 Acres from a
1988 law I looked at the um Department's
list of lakes where ski craftter banned
both by Statute as well as by um as the
hearing process and I only see 15 lakes
that are banned by Statute um the vast
majority would be banned by of ski craft
are banned
by the uh the hearing process are you
aware of other restrictions that would
apply that would have ban that would ban
um personal watercraft based on this
Acres I am not uh there are legal
opinions out there as to retroactivity
uh I'm not a legal Mind by any means so
uh I would defer to them on that uh but
I'm not aware of any other restrictions
that would would uh take
place
for a followup thank you Mr chair just
just um to make sure I'm we're talking
about the same thing um there's the the
department publishes restricted bodies
of water that lists um lakes that don't
allow um petroleum uh Outboards for
example or um or have speed limits or
number of other criteria is that the
would is is it safe to assume that the
department of safety uh does their
enforcement based on that
list yes so if a personal watercraft or
a ski craft or an outboard motor an
inboard motor where to fall into a
category of uh a body of water that is
restricted by horsepower or by speed
limit that is going to apply to all
Craft um specifically to personal
watercraft or ski Craft um again absent
the retroactivity uh concerns
um those those restrictions are in place
specific to craft uh identified by
either the commissioner or by the
legislature if that answers your
question sir I'm not trying to dodge
just just take resp for another for
another F thank you um right I I was I
was incomplete it also that same um
website also lists the the personal
water or the the ski craft the the
bodies of water that ban ski craft I was
just using that as other examples it's
sort of comprehensive but I but my
follow I try to keep it short I know
you're um we've all been here for a
the we've heard that personal watercraft
not um differentiated from ski Craft um
are really distinct from ski
craft as I understand the um the
safety regulations safety restrictions
with respect to boats which I guess this
Falls within only um only uh riders or
operators um 12 years old and under
would need to wear a um life jacket
although one would have to be on board
and um it appears that if the uh
personal watercraft has a motor
equivalent to under 25 horsepower than
somebody under 16 years of age could
also operate a personal watercraft can
you comment on those safety measures for
with respect to personal
watercraft so as the crafts are defined
today a two person machine a one and two
person machine is required by Statute to
have the operator wearing a life jacket
while in
operation because any machine with a
capacity of three or more it is
considered a boat and unless you are 12
years of age and under then you are not
required to wear the life jacket but you
use and the other part of that was the
as I understand the restriction on age
limits for
watercraft
um uh people 16 years or older are
restricted for 25 horsepower or above
but not for smaller horsepower boats so
how does that apply to these threers uh
personal
watercraft so a three person personal
watercraft I'm not aware of any that are
less than 25
horsepower uh so if a child someone
under the age of 16 wants to operate
that like any other boat they have to
have a responsible adult on board 18 and
over with them who is also serving
certified and had has taken the safety
course it's only uh that is the caveat
that exists for a person under 16 to
machines dony for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Captain um noted
earlier from jod from Marine Association
she mentioned there's no fiscal note to
this particular Bill do you in your
professional opinion do you think this
will increase your staff's um
requirements for Marine Patrol and do
you have enough staff to be able to
manage this bill with the new
requirements currently we are managing
restrictions at exist
today again absent the you know whether
we're talking about retro active or not
any new uh additions are going to be
treated by our Patrol staff uh on a Case
by case basis call by call basis I think
what has been discussed earlier would be
the impact on the hearings Bureau within
the department of
safety uh if there
are circumstances where new restrictions
are looking to be
added to existing restrictions
then certainly depending upon the
Public's wish to have a body of water
considered for a restriction may
increase the demand on the hearings
Bureau that's undetermined that's that's
going to be based on what a body of
water at the local level is going to
want uh for or not want on their bodies
restriction before we go on I'd like to
recognize as fourth graders up in the uh
gallery what we normally do in uh when
we're having a what we're in session the
representatives all rise and give you an
Applause because because you are the
[Music]
people
from iank
Franklin
Brentwood okay very good well well
welcome as you can see it's kind of
it thank you any other questions by
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman let's
continue
then as you can we only got a few left I
was shuffling them I could see somebody
like look at he shuffling yes because
just take them as they
McIntyre um good morning my name is
Charlie McIntyre conquered New Hampshire
and Ash Cove
molteno um I'm fortunate enough to spend
summer on the lake in mboro on ash Cove
I own property a small camp on the water
I have for four
years own watercraft all Manor
pwc's kayaks paddle boards and outside
my house virtually every morning is
every version of watercraft battle
boards
kayaks fishing boats mostly because the
bass fishing is really good outside my
house and we share the water right so I
usually ask the folks who are fishing
how are they biting as I'm drinking my
coffee and my sons actually had their
license for boating before they had
their license for driving I grew up on
the water outside Boston I've taught
them water safety and through the use of
personal watercrafts far more so than
boats I've taught them the lake
how the markers Works where the rocks
are all those stuff and so it's an
important part of our education and
usage of the lake um and so I'm here to
oppose it as a citizen and happy to
answer your questions you
committee seeing none thank you very
chairman uh
Lui I'm sorry if I bet you their name
but with a name like Rulo what do you
get I'm used to it thank you um thank
you Mr chair and committee uh my name is
Ted stachelski I um am from plasto New
Hampshire I've lived in Rockingham
County most of my life outside of
serving in the Marine Corps and for the
uh the United States and the state um I
want to give you um you may have seen me
speak on safety issues uh my back ground
not only in veterans issues and
Engineering is also about public safety
and the Brain Injury Association Lobby
um so not only I'm always looking at
safety not only for kids and sports
concussions um but and Veterans issues
with safe equipment but also like with
um everything's always modernizing and
getting better and faster and stronger
for the purpose of safety um so like you
may have seen things come across your
desk about these new o ohvs where they
you know they have no car seats so
that's my background where I'm coming
from and also through the legislative
training that I've had over at the uh
legislative office building is um you
know tell a personal story okay I grew
up on Arlington pond in Salem New
Hampshire where me and my three brothers
unfortunately we lost our mentors and
one of my mentor is Richard champy and
he's a former New Hampshire state or he
was a New Hampshire state trooper who
died in the line of duty and he on the
memorial outside the Legislative Office
Building um he wasn't there for me and
my brothers when we were growing up on
Pond um I proud we're proud to be
Granite Staters and Sportsmen we're not
only involved with boating but in New
Hampshire to live here you fall the
season so you own a snowmobile you own a
boat you own um you do hunting you do
fishing what is my connection to and I
hope I can wap tie this all together
what is my connection to you know
Rockingham boat Dockside Marina Irving
marine and so forth is there was a great
person on Arlington Pond he was a Entre
entrepreneur engineer back in the 1960s
and70s his name was Robert or Bob berson
he started uh Land and Sea Incorporated
Landon C Performance Center in Salem New
Hampshire uh he took me and my brothers
under their wing uh under our under his
wing uh we got into not only Motorsports
but one of my first jobs was sweeping
the floor of his uh engineering and
sales department which is all about
Motorsports uh including back then in
1985 we called them jet skis uh he
spring he was my mentor in springboard
to go into the Marine Corps I did I uh
worked on Advanced a traffic control
radar systems um when I got out of the
Marine Corps in 1995 these jet skis were
now called
pwc's and I built engine D dynamometers
and propellers for boats and and all
kinds of things in the background and we
did a lot of communications with not
only locally in rockenham County across
New Hampshire but internationally uh
sales service and so forth so what am I
here talking about now jobs jobs tourism
engineering Ingenuity in continuing that
going and when I read this bill and it
was given to me last night by a friend
who used to be an um a machinist for
land and sea and let me talk about that
too land and SE Bob berson actually when
he prior to he died he built his
Flagship building right manufacturing
facility an engineering facility right
here in in conquered New Hampshire so
we're talking more about you you know we
might talk about
pwc's but Bob berson when I'm 15 years
old I'm cranking on a two-stroke engine
in his shop at the age of 15 years old
that grows with you and I've been able
to and um train people and meet people
all across the world and all across
Motorsports um and support my family as
they have been able to support their
families here in the state of New
Hampshire it makes us who we are Granite
Staters we're leaders in industry we
will find a way to make things better
and brighter and faster and in fact in
the end Bob berson took his little
working on jet ski engines and he was
actually working on engine dynamometers
for Abrams Tanks which are now in the
war in Ukraine this is huge this so I
want you to look at it on the through
the lens of of National Security you can
look at it as engineering you could look
at it as tax dollars and I'm going to
end that right there what I'm talking
about as tax dollars from being a little
kid growing up in Arlington Pond there's
always a bad egg or more that's zipping
around a pond or a lake and I think
that's what we're talking about here you
got people who are really upset and I
was as a kid and then as an adult living
on angle Pond and have actually last
year having a seasonal RV uh and Big
Island Pond you see a mom with the kids
in the couch being pulled by a PWC and
there's three little kids and there's
only one Spotter and people are on the
shore going don't do it don't do it
against the law she thumbs the nose at
everybody go excuse me I'm sorry uh
could you focus on the
bill right well okay so my point is is
that we as taxpayers pay tax money the
legislator takes the that money and the
governor they give it to the Department
of Safety and they're not there or if
they are there voters over on especially
on pwc's and these people come back to
the shore and they're like yeah I got
pulled over with a warning I think we
don't have a PWC problem we have a
police patrolling problem that needs to
be addressed with ever increasing tax
dollars as homeowners that we give the
government so don't kill jobs don't kill
engineer Ingenuity don't kill our
infrastructure that we have and be World
in World leading leaders in
manufacturing we need to talk to our
governor and legislators about how we
can get the police who have the power we
can't police our own Bad Eggs we need
the police to actually when they pull
somebody over on a on a lake or a pond
to actually throw the book at them and
set an example instead of letting them
walk so that's my story and all this I
greatly oppose this bill and if you're
going to deal with pwc's don't just take
it and lump it into what used to be a
jet ski because it's not we've come way
too far advanced in technology make your
own set of laws or just leave it alone
like boat I greatly appreciate your time
thank you very much any questions by
members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
Alex hi thank you uh my name is Ed loes
thank you for talking to me I've been
voting for 45 years I'm an avid
Outdoorsman fisherman Hunter I expect I
like the environment like everybody else
um um it's it's not a jet ski I've had
jet skis in the early 80s I hate them um
as far as safety and water skiing and
tubing there's no comparison as far as
safety between tubing and jet skiing
behind a jet ski and a boat which we
have both jet ski or the P PWC is much
safer a line of visib visibility is
better there's no prop um it's just a
safer vehicle as far as erosion if you
look at a boat in a jet
it's there's no comparison to the wake
it's not even close um economically
obviously I think this is going to be a
disaster for New Hampshire so thank you
thank you very much any questions for
the by members by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
Carol hi I he you my name is Caitlyn
Carol I live in molten Boro New
Hampshire I'd like to thank you for
allowing me time today to talk to you
about why I oppose House Bill
1562 I have been a resident of New
Hampshire for four years and I've grown
up coming to New Hampshire at a year
round family Lakehouse I currently live
on Lake winaki during the pandemic I
moved to the lak house full-time and I
love being one with nature I have a boat
that I purchased and a couple of seos
that I purchased from the Silva
Motorsports in molteno my boat is
beautiful but it is 26 ft and I'm not
comfortable taking the boat out by
myself to expl floor but I will take the
C out by myself when my boyfriend is not
around New Hampshire's motto is Live
Free or Die I will lose some of my
freedom if House Bill 1562 is passed I
just spent over $30,000 on SEO wake Pros
for the enjoyment to being able to go
out with multiple people that I won't
fully be able to use if House Bill 1562
is passed one area that I won't be able
to visit is greens Basin which is a
three minute seu ride from my Dock and
where one of my best friends lives I do
ride over there frequently to visit my
friend and will now need to drive over
which defeats the purpose of living on
the lake unless my boyfriend is
available to take me on the boat I will
also not be able to se you over to
Winter Harbor which is an area that I go
to with my friends to enjoy the calmness
of the lake and time
away I used to take my nieces out in the
seedu tubing as it is much easier for me
to tube with them than it is to take the
boat out something that they gratefully
enjoy I am afraid that others will not
be able to have the same experience with
their children and young kids to get
them to enjoy the boat in the
lake I couldn't wait to turn 16 to be
able to drive the jet skis as my parents
would allow that over driving the boat
it was something we all look forward to
in fact I was more excited to drive the
jet skis and get my license which did
take me a little bit of time it was how
I was able to get to friends houses and
enjoy the water I watch my niece do the
same as she is counting down the days to
drive the jet ski between my house and
my parents who also live on the water
personal watercrafts allow for the ease
of exploring the lake and getting used
to your surroundings and navigation they
allow a quick dip in the lake or a
Sunset Cruise I frequently take mine out
after work work for someone who works
from home it is nice to get out and
enjoy a ride at the peaceful end of the
day in addition they allow a budget
friendly way for families to explore the
lake if you are not directly on the
water you can easily trailer them place
to place and enjoy time with your family
on the water they also don't take up as
much space in terms of dock space for
those that do live on the water and want
the availability to have those I am in
fear of losing additional Liberties and
freedom if House Bill 1562 is passed
what's next will you ban me from having
a personal watercraft on my dock
everything else that I could have
discussed today has already been
addressed I thank you for your time and
I would kindly ask that you reject House
Bill 1562 I'd also like to suggest that
there is a mass email to sign up for
important information that is
distributed to all of those who have
registered personal watercraft so they
are aware of the impact their decisions
have on them I do not believe that
everyone in this room are the only
people that this will affect thank you
thank you is there any
questions members of the committee
seeing none thank you very
much James
Hamstead still morning good morning Mr
chair and the members of the committee
my name is Jim
Dennison I moved to New Hampshire 33
years ago and have lived on Big Island
Pond in Hamstead for the last seven or
eight years where we built a house in
2015 Big Island Pond it's Lake of 500
acres in Hamstead Dairy and Salem it's
one of those Lakes where ski craft are
currently
banned so therefore I'm here to strongly
opposed house built
1562 you know I do care deeply about the
environmental values of Big Island Pond
and all of our New Hampshire Waters I
also own and enjoy using a personal
watercraft
I know there are property owners who are
strongly opposed to personal watercraft
mostly because they're annoyed by them
and they would like to see only
non-motorized Craft on the waters but a
guy like me I'll be 70 in a few
days so each year as we get older the
physical limitations of using a kayak or
a canoe make it tougher and less safe to
use those those
boats so at 70 the personal watercraft
is a GameChanger it allows me to get out
and have safe and fun
access on the lake and banning this
personal watercraft would severely
restrict my access to the Waters of Big
Island Pond and completely exclude many
others New Hampshire should not be
restricting access to personal
watercraft I think we should be
promoting access to our
Lakes so I just want to thank you and
respectfully request request that this
committee vote to kill this Bill thank
you any questions by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
Murphy going once going
Murphy
finally sorry to it's tough to be the
Street my apologies but somebody got to
be the last and I was shuffling them
here they saw me it's a privilege to
speak thank you very much um my name is
Steve Street I live in molbo New
Hampshire I don't believe I'll use the
full three minutes and I don't believe
I'm being redundant but thank you for
your service to the state and caring
about our Lakes um I've had the
privilege of enjoying New Hampshire's
lak since childhood when my mom and
family would take me here to the lakes
for region to boating on wiip
during my Plymouth State College Years
and 2016 I was fortunate enough to buy a
waterfront home on wiip deepening
my commitment to the preservation and
safety of these Waters I do care about
these Waters living full-time in small
Winn pasak Cove we witness the
activities of pwc's jet skis wake surf
traditional boats every single boating
season day despite frequent traffic from
all watercraft types and the result in
waves we've observed no shoreline
erosion or damage to the Natural
landscape
I've never once seen one tree in the
nearly 3,000 ft of wooded conservation
tree line across our Cove fall into the
water should I ever see evidence of
Sherine erosion I will Advocate to
mitigate it the challenges we face on
these waters are not due to the
watercraft themselves but stem from the
lack of adherence to existing
regulations every watercraft entering or
leaving our Cove creates a three to four
times wake the size of a PWC wake as
they come on or off plane get getting
into our small Cove through a noake
channel every boting seasoning every
boting seizing day we witness the
existing 15ot rule get violated right in
front of our house uh making this
supporting this bill and making it more
complex by adding different distances to
different watercraft will change nothing
the issue lies not with the Marine
Patrol whose efforts are commendable
given their resources but with the need
for more resources boting education
rather than additional regulations and
there was a lot of questions around
education and who's doing what I'd like
to answer that even though I wasn't
asked that question the greatest
education I got from voting on wiip
came through great voters that that I
had the privilege of teaching me how to
boat but through the state programs when
I had to become certified that taught me
about the laws and how to operate on
this I have a great dealer in molten
Boro they've done a lot to help me
understand how to be a good Boer But
ultimately we have a program program in
place that teaches our captains how to
boat safely on this water I'm not a
training expert but if we're going to
educate everybody on how to be a better
boater we probably need a significantly
larger program to do this I would argue
that the best way to do it is to support
Marine Patrol uh more give them what
they need to enforce our existing
regulations and it will educate captains
on how not to violate
laws 80 waterfront homes live on our SM
Co small Cove I estimate 40% % have
pwc's if this law passes all of these
homes will have to abandon their pwc's
and as my son pointed out some of these
folks this may be their only way to
enjoy the lake that they live on so you
might be removing their ability to go on
the water at all I have two PWD C's
myself and for the past several Summers
with great pride I've watched my son's
ride a PWC to work at the local marinas
if this law existed these memories would
not have happened for my wife and I or
my sons who love this Lake my son's
experience is working at local marinas
accessible by pwc's are cherished
memories that underscore the importance
of these waterways to our community's
fabric last summer out on the bigger
waterways of wiip a 30-year-old on
a PWC violated the existing 150 fot Rule
and broadsided our boat causing $99,000
of damage to my boat luckily no one was
seriously injured you would think
because of that I would support greater
regulation on pwc's but I do not that
was a violation of an existing law that
is unable to be enforced currently I
believe that more stringent laws would
not have prevented this incident instead
we need to support the Marine Patrol
more effectively maintain access to more
affordable recreational opportunities
for New Hampshire families I I urge you
please to consider the implications of
further regulations and oppose this bill
ensuring our Lakes remain a vibrant
accessible treasure for all thank you
for your dedication to our state's
natural
resources thank you any questions by
members of the
committee seeing n thank you very
much I'm all out of pink cards is anyone
anyone wish to uh to
speak
speak if someone wish to speak you'll
have to fill out a pink card I can fill
out a where do you me to do that oh when
you can you came in
that I thought you said I wanted to
speak if I forgot no no
uh no do you want to you want to speak
yeah sure all right but you'll have to
fill the card out after you finish I'll
do it I absolutely will okay my name is
Joanna Russo I live in molor I actually
live in the same Cove these guys live in
um my biggest concern after hearing
everything today sounds a lot like
what's going been going on in the North
Country this winter we haven't had a lot
of snow we've had more snowmobile
accidents if we don't have a lot of
water we're going to have a lot more
pwc's on just the waterways they can go
on will have more accidents will have
more issues because there'll be more
congestion you take away the right for
people to use all these bodies of water
and they're going to be going to one
place there's not been a lot of snow all
those snowmobiles that have have been
out riding all the around the state when
in a good winter are now in Pittsburgh
or in coldbrook and there's more
congestion you take all these pwc's and
you stick them on a few small lakes or
on the few big lakes that are left to
ride on and we'll have more congestion
that's the one thing I hadn't heard
today so that's M that's it any
questions by members of the
committee thank you seeing that be
card thank you very much it's been I'm
going to call the hearing I'm going to
adjourn the hearing I appreciate your
coming I think uh still this is we don't
do this all every day in this size room
but we do do it quite a bit so I
appreciate your
adjourned
okay
okay thank you very much this is the
part two of uh
our hearing uh schedule this is
scheduled for 1:00 it's House Bill
1390 uh first off uh there are some uh
papers that have been put in the speak
pockets on the in front of you on the
various chair uh and I think it's the
first floor rows uh please do not take
them with you don't disturb them they're
for tomorrow and the well Sergeant arm
is a big guy and I w't want to mess with
him so uh I appreciate it just don't
don't uh leave those alone other than
that I I'll start the hearing on House
Bill
1390 relative to regulating weight
voting and wake Sports and the first
person who will
speaking uh chair recognizes Linda tan
representative Linda Tanner who is the
Prime sponsor
representative Tanner the floor is
yours if I can get the mic low enough
for me here thank you thank you for the
record I'm representative Linda Tanner
uh I represent Sullivan District 5 the
beautiful towns of sopy and Springfield
and I'm introducing
1390 in my district there are 10 lakes
and ponds with Lake snipy being the
largest lake in area lake snipy is the
center feature of our town and its
source of its drinking WI water it's an
exceptionally Clear Lake and has dodged
the bullet of the introduction of many
invasive species Lake spip and all the
lakes and ponds in my area are the main
attractions for tourists home buyers a
main source of income of the local
economy and an Irreplaceable natural
resource in the past few years the
comment I've heard consistently from my
constituents at Gatherings and meetings
is quote can you do something about the
Wake boats and wake surfing unquote with
our high water issues this past summer
those requests and complaints
increased the issue most the issues most
contentious are sherline erosion damage
to Shoreline
ecosystems damage to inwater
structures dangerous encounters with
small recreational craft interference
and concerns with sailing
riatas and and fear of import of
invasive species disturbing the bottom
of the lake causing turbidity algae and
cob bacteria blooms and the effect of
wave action on all other Recreation
around the
lake wave surfing is an ocean sport
that's been around since boards humans
and ocean waves came together on
freshwater lakes and inland waterways
water sports have largely consisted of
sports like water skiing wake boarding
tubing and about anything that could be
towed behind a power boat once they had
power boats towboats depend on Bo boats
reaching a speed that both the boat and
what's pulled behind can ride on top of
the water called
hydroplaning these boats create waves
typically 3 to 6 Ines
High sometime in the late '90s early
2000s some enterprising and very clever
Engineers start started working on a
boat that could produce an ocean type
wave on a fresh water lake or a
Waterway these ocean-like waves would be
larger with more volume and energy so
that they could support a person on a
surfboard instead of sleek fast towboats
which are designed to ride on top of the
water these boats have witer bottoms or
hulls to displace lots of water they
have up to three tanks ballast tanks
across the stern that pump water in and
out to create up to 5,000 or even more
pounds of weight to weigh down the stern
which is the back of the boat so the
boat won't plane but pushes through the
water the engine and propeller are
designed for maximum power to be able to
push and displace a huge swath of water
this displacement of water then rebounds
behind the boat to create two and half
to 3ft
waves that have enough force and volume
to support a person on a
surfboard on the UND side of the of the
newer boats near the back are metal fins
that can be adjusted by computer to
change these ocean-like waves to fit the
surface size and
preference we have distributed a graphic
which shows the weight boats in wake
surfing mode which illustrates the
unintended consequences of running these
boats in two shallow water too close to
shorelines and other structures in boats
and on lakes and ponds that are too
small to support
them wake surfing boats are made for fun
they're decked out with cool racks neat
sound systems computer controls and
they're very
expensive I've water skied for many
years and taught water skiing so I
imagine that it's fun and challenged to
Surf behind on these waves and this bill
is not intended to ban wake
surfing in New Hampshire all natural
bodies of fresh water are held in the
public trust and allowed reasonable use
regulations and rules allow for safe
shared use of our water to help prevent
damage to property and wildlife habitat
and to help maintain the water
quality if the shoreline and the quality
of the lakes and ponds degrade we will
lose our tourists proper values will go
down our economy will suffer licensing
registration Boer safety education are
important but have not addressed the
major issues with wake boats we need to
act in the form of regulations and guard
rails for safety and to maintain the
quality of our water and
ecosystems HB
1390 is is based on current science and
reflects regulations on wake surfing
that have been enacted in other states
it has three requirements that are
really minimum requirements in terms of
safety Shoreline protection and
maintaining the health of the lake these
guard rails for a wake surfing Zone
include a lake or Pond must be at least
50 continuous Acres the depth of the
area must be at least 20 ft and the
distance from the shoreline or
structures must be 5 100
ft there will be people here testifying
that can expand and illuminate the
science beside behind the need for these
three minimal components 500 ft distance
200t depth and 50 acres or more we have
provided the committee members with the
types of maps that can be produced that
outline wake surfing zones on lakes near
you under these
regulations enforcement will follow the
same procedures as you used today for by
Marine Patrol for infractions of no wake
zones they already list uh exist on
lakes mandatory onboard flotation
devices 150 ft from Shoreline and other
boating rules and
regulations passing this bill and making
rules through the department will help
preserve our Vital resources our lakes
and make them safe for all who use them
for recreation we all love our Lakes
let's use them respons responsible and
committee don't all ask at
once I've seeing no questions thank you
chair chair
recognizes uh Eric
you my name is Eric Herr thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the opportunity to testify this
afternoon in support of hb13
1990 public policy interests have marked
my entire career including focusing on
New Hampshire's Water Resources first as
a member of Governor Shaheen's uh
shorefront protection task force and
more recently as a water quality monitor
for the Newfound Lake Region
Association as a shorefront owner on
newfound Lake and water sports
Enthusiast including wake surfing I live
the balancing of Lake Recreation and the
health of the lake its shorefront and
water
quality others more export than I can
speak to the science of the impact of
wake surf boating my wake surfing
experience however confirms that the
power of wake surf waves and of the
turbulence produced in the water column
requires a sort of protections crafted
in HB
1390 I strongly support this bill that
said let me add two uh thoughts for your
further consideration first moing Fields
extend as much as 200 feet into Newfound
Lake from the shorefront kayakers paddle
boarders swimmers and swim platform
users including my own young
grandchildren enjoy Newfound Lake up to
100 feet or more from the
shoreline shouldn't they be afforded the
same protections from the power of wake
surf waves equivalent to those provided
by HB 1390 for the shorefront
second the interaction between the
proposed contiguous area and the
shoreline distance requirements of HP
1390 should be considered in narrower
bays and channels for
example the Bay north of Wellington
State Park on newfound lake is large
enough and deep enough to meet both Bill
requirements yet wake surfing in that
bay and the turns required to wake surf
there would produce waves that would I
believe make the Bay virtually unusable
for kayakers paddle boarders and even
other
watercraft I know I've wake surfed there
and concluded that it was unfair of me
to monopolize the Bay now I exclusively
wake surf in the largest most open parts
of Newfound
Lake wake surfing is a wonderful sport
candidly it's a part of the bribery that
gets my family and my grandchildren to
visit us on
newfound however the recreational benef
benefits of wake surfing must be
balanced appropriately against the
interests of other water sports and of
the immediate and long-term health of
New Hampshire's lakes and shorefront HB
1390 is an essential is an essential
step in securing that balance in my view
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank
you thank you any questions by members
committee
see representative Darby
for thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question as a member of um the
Newfound Lake uh and water sorry new
found Lake Association region
Association sorry can you describe some
of the impacts that you've seen
firsthand from uh wake surfing either
due to erosion or um Wildlife impact or
things like
that uh I can speak to just two elements
of it uh one is uh the um I benefit in
in at my location I benefit from the
fact that the the the channel is fairly
low as we live on the West Shore near
mayew Island so there's not much wake
surfing near us but the the size of the
Wake that is produced if one is near the
shore is certain to erode the shoreline
and I have seen the effects of that as
regards the wildlife I can't speak speak
to that um I suppose I would be most
concerned about Lon habitat but I'm not
sure uh in uh shallow areas uh it's it's
quite visible that there is a sediment
impact uh uh from the turbulence created
col and no any other additional
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr
chairman
what I try to do because I've got people
for and people against they got two
piles of pink cards I'm going to try to
alternate
so that was a that was a for the bill
this
is
uh opposition to the bill John Wall
silver SS oh excuse me U New Hampshire
Association
I'm glad they put that one up higher no
it's not high enough that might
work speak loud yes excuse me good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is John Wall I am the
general sales manager of silver saans
Marina and the New Hampshire Marine
trades president our membership includes
20 marinas and hundreds of employees I
would like to take this time to
recognize our opposition in the audience
in the over 1,600 people that voted in
testimony online we strongly oppose
House Bill 1390 we have passed out
packets or are passing out packets to
you that will include economic data
environmental information maps showing
how different lakes will be infected by
this bill and also the efforts to our
education and
enforcement the foundation of our
opposition lies in the public trust
doctrine that any Lake over 10 acres
should be held for the public to be used
we support Public Access houseb 1390
takes it
away this is the fifth year we've
debated wake booat or wake surf issues
starting in 2019 with the Wake booat
commission which I served on at the
conclusion of that the New Hampshire
Marine Trad Association committed
ourselves to do a wake responsibly
campaign much like that's done
nationally 200 foot setbacks reducing
stereo volumes and minimizing repetitive
passes but the supporters of Health 1390
that wasn't
enough they continued to recommend
legislation restrictions or bans never
coming to the table for conversation or
compromise over our last four years of
work the New Hampshire Marine trades
Association has hosted meetings
distributed signage at boat ramps
invested tens of thousands of dollars in
radio ads pamphlets and boats each
spring and an immeasurable amount of
time for personal instruction for new
boat
owners in 2021 we defeat we debated
House Bill 229 to define a wake build
that bill did not pass the house in 2022
we debated House Bill 1071 to establish
a 250t setback which was amended to 500
feet after a Minnesota study that bill
also did not pass the house we are back
today with the bill that both defines a
wake booat establishes a 500t setback
and an unenforceable 20t recommended
depth from our already depleted Marine
Patrol this this bill will eliminate
access it will create congestion in our
already busiest parts of our legs with
further unintended consequences due to
safety now let's look at house boo 1390
it creates definition of a wake booat in
your packet you will find multiple
different kinds of boats that have
ballast systems that create safe
opportunities for people to wake surf
but did you know a sailboat also has
ballast is a sailboat now a wake booat
it's hard to say it establishes a 500t
step back and a 20ft requirement
in depth these requirements like I said
are unenforcable and to create Maps
develop new areas for wake surfing but
at what cost and who will pay for this
the effective date of this bill is July
1st 2024 smack dab in the middle of the
summer that will create immense
confusion with our public and again
challenge our Marine
Patrol finally I'd like to talk about
the
environment New Hampshire's boating
season is only 2 to 3 months long unlike
most other states and our WG surfing
typically does not have the kind of
impact that mother nature does frequent
storms heavy rains High lake levels
strong winds and Ice have caused
significant damage to our
shorelines last Thursday and excuse me
last Thursday we taught the Winds of 50
mph on Lake a mostly unfrozen Lake
currently two to 4ft waves crashed on
our shorelines for a stain sustained
period of 36 hours and last summer was
our wetest summer on record according to
the National Oceanic Atmospheric
Administration which is kept in
1895 cob bacteria that has been in our
Lake since the 1960s and 70s according
to New Hampshire Dees long before any
wake boat was traveling on this water
and also sign of bacteria has been found
in lakes that do not have
boating most recently a s of bacteria
Bloom from Lake kisaka has throwed
through a flow through a river into Lake
winaki as late as October long after our
boating season is has come to an end a
major factor from s bacteria is storm
water runoff and there has been no
direct correlation from Wake
Sports sediment displacement can happen
through many different types of
activities people in the Water Swimming
paddling trolling pulling up an anchor
launching a boat off a trailer pulling
up to a dock to put it in forward or
reverse aqum bubbles that prevent ice
around permanent dock structures they
all
contribute lastly I'd like to talk about
our Loom population according to
articles in interviews the New Hampshire
Loom population has grown to 785 birds
in 2022 up from only 127 in
1993 opponents will say WG serving
impacts the birds but Studies have found
that the loom population could be 43%
higher if it weren't for the leading
kler of loons lead sinkers animals Birds
of Prey heavy rains that flood our nests
that kill our baby loons and eggs even
human development on shorelines those
are problems for loons not boats we all
care about our environment and our aren
is do especially our livelihood depends
on it but to pick one type of boat or
activity for bands restricts not
isolation what's next bass
fishing this morning personal watercraft
for the topical conversation and it
seems as though the tradition of boating
is under attack a passion of hundreds of
thousands of New Hampshire residents and
our visitors we respectfully request
that the committee find housef 1390
inexpedient to legislate and the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association
continues to pledge our education
efforts of the Wake responsib campaign
in support of the New Hampshire Marine
Patrol to continue to make our Lakes New
England the Crown Jewel of the country
thank
committee representative
run thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question Mr Wally um
earlier in your testimony you said that
a sailboat could be considered a weight
booat because it has ballasts um I I I'm
reading the bill and it says a wake boat
means a motorboat so do you consider a
sailboat to be a motorboat if it has a
motor H if it has a motor and sobs have
Motors okay and then
follow follow up thank you and then you
also mentioned Lake kisaka and that um
the major reason for their cyanobacteria
blooms was runoff are you aware of their
that in their watershed management plan
which was prepared by environmental
Engineers that it stated that the the
root cause of their blooms is from
sediment I meant to speak if there was
Mr I apologize that lake kosaka has a c
bacteria Bloom and it flows through a
river and cob bacteria as a whole is
from runoff not specifically kandaka so
you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um we've been
bombarded with all kinds of reports
Thank God I'm a tree farmer and I'm
happy to see the timber being cut thank
you um I have two questions sure in
talking with the members of the
committee and the sponsor do you think
there's any room for
compromise on what they have I will say
that we've compromised Now 50 additional
feet which is approximately 25% above
safe passage I can't speak to the
support um I've heard different things
that I'll leave out of this conversation
at the moment um because I I can't speak
for them sorry I don't I have heard that
there has been some conversation about
that but I think more conversation needs
to be had but the New Hampshire Marine
TRS Association has included incate Bill
431 an additional 50 ft for 200t setback
so we are compromise
in do you have a
followup can can you get closer to the
mic and repeat your question I know
you're tall and maybe you can just pick
the whole thing right up how's that
that's better that's
great can you repeat your your response
sure I'll say the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association is working with
Senate Bill 431 we're adding 50 feet
over safe passage so we feel that is an
appropriate compromise for now I can't
speak for the supporters and how they
feel about compromise um but I'm sure
conversations can be had but at the
present moment we feel we are
up all right what follow Sor this is the
third BL okay okay I'll ask somebody
else a question okay well I'll yeah I'll
be back to you repes representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my my question you mentioned the
4 foot uh waves on Lake wiam Baki the
vast majority of New Hampshire Lakes are
under a th000 Acres um are you aware of
four 4ot natural waves on an a th acre
Lake I can't speak the four feet but I
can tell you that I have the Good
Fortune I travel around the state
delivering boats to customers homes and
I've seen lakes that are glassy calm one
day and quite rough the next day and I
can tell you when I see those I stop and
look at it I've even taken pictures I
figured that question would come up so
yes I've seen larger waves I've seen
smaller waves I've in gassy conditions
but three to four foot waves on a blowy
day uh even on Lake kisaka there's a 45
M hour wi last year and it was rough
sure representative wolf you wish this
followup on a
question thank
you
I'm not sure which pile of papers I'm
going to believe in but are you willing
to take the risk that the Shoreline May
erode the bottom may come up and
nutrients make the lake unusable in due
course I'll make the statement that
mother nature makes waves just like
boats and she can work a lot harder than
a wake boat for a longer duration of
time uh anyone can use the lake whether
you're going to be put a boat in neutral
reverse and shallow water at a dock
you're going to turn the lake up
anything can cause turbidity in this
Lake and not specifically wake B so that
shouldn't be pinned into a corner as the
issues any other questions by members of
the
committee please don't make me turn it
around all the time just say
yes hearing none thank thank you very
time represent excuse me Carol R fos
autobond speak for three
minutes good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee um my name is
Carol Foss I'm senior adviser for
Science and policy at New Hampshire oton
where a Statewide environmental organ
ganization dedicated to protecting New
Hampshire's environment for wildlife and
for people um I had anticipated being
rather later in the in the order this
afternoon um but I'm will still be brief
because I think there are others in the
room who can address um some of the
details I do have written testimony that
I will provide to you um we strongly
support this bill um while there are
many responsible boter who will
voluntarily follow guidelines um the
importance of our Lakes to Quality of
Life in this state to New Hampshire's
economy um both locally and through
tourism are too great to risk and a few
bad actors can do a lot of damage um
we're particularly concerned about
shoreline
erosion um and about the turbidity issue
because that can make it easier for
loons and mergansers and Otter and mink
and other organisms that feed on fish to
see their prey
underwater um as well as stirring up
nutrients that can um cause algae blooms
as well as cyanobacteria blooms um so
I'm going to leave it there and leave
you with my written testimony thank you
very
much thank you is there any questions
committee seeing and hearing none thank
you very
the
in opposition Amy Landers uh Lakes
minutes thank you very much to for
having again nice to see you all again
my name is Amy Landers I'm the executive
director of The Lakes Region tourism
Association I've been at the association
for over 24 years now the association
represent present over 450 businesses in
The Lakes region in central New
Hampshire we promote the area in state
out of state and internationally to
bring visitors from all over the world
to New Hampshire you'll be hearing a
similar um testimony to what you heard
this morning that I'm here today to
oppose house build 1390 relevant to wake
boats and wake Sports recreational
boating is an important aspect of the
New Hampshire's tourism economy our
recreational boating industry
contributes 1.4 billion annually to New
Hampshire's economy and supports over
6,000 direct and indirect jobs here in
the state New Hampshire is one of the
top 10 states where outdoor recreation
and outdoor Eon economy represents a
significant percentage of the GDP
according to the Bureau of economic
analysis on outdoor recreation in 2019
generally boating and fishing are
considered to be top sectors of this
outdoor
economy when visitors choose where
they're going to spend their summer
vacation they want a choice a broad
choice of activities offered by our
region is what attracts many different
demographics of consumers to our great
state a strong summer economy of Summer
tourism is important to our economy here
in the state of New Hampshire our second
leading
industry house build
1390 will ban or SE severely restrict
certain segments of boting for New
Hampshire's Lakes Banning wake boats is
a
mistake wake Sports have been popular in
New Hampshire for 20 to 30 years to ban
these sports or severely restrict
people's ability to enjoy them on our
state's public body of water is
inconsistent with our message to promote
to the public there there is a better
bill as was spoken about earlier Senate
Bill 431 that seeks a buffer not a band
for wake surfing we should prefer the
least restrictive policy when it comes
to regulating boating activities and
activities for all of our families to
enjoy choice to tours have means having
days to enjoy boating maybe a Day hike
up Mount Major perhaps a rainy day at an
arcade or one of our beautiful museums
this is what makes New Hampshire special
and attract visitors to our state if we
take away these choices we harm our
tourism economy which will impact the
state of New Hampshire and greatly
impact our rooms and meals tax
legislation that bans certain segments
of boating send the wrong message that
New Hampshire is unfriendly to boating
and they're unfriendly to our visitors
bills like this could negatively impact
also our real estate market in New
Hampshire
where people choose to buy a home in our
state when there's Les regulations if we
have less residents we'll mean loss of
jobs for many of many of these people
our businesses will struggle because
we're going to lose workers that will
move to other states that don't have
these strict regulations these bills are
not good for New Hampshire not good for
our local residents not for our instate
and out of state visitors and definitely
not for our summer tourism economy here
in the state if there are issues to be
addressed please consider policies that
increase education and enforcement of
these current laws Banning boats boat
boting regul Banning boats and wake
boats is bad for our businesses please
oppose House Bill
1390 thank
committee seeing it hearing none sir
there is I thought you saw me Mr
chair you have for for a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um the committee rece or online
testimony received from New Hampshire
Lakes management advisory committee
which includes voting members of the New
Hampshire business and industry
Association New Hampshire Association of
Realtors and New Hampshire travel
Association and the Marine trades
Association support this bill so I'm
wondering my question to you is if um
you've commun you've discussed this with
other members of the business community
in The Lakes Region and if you and if
there's a dis uh disagreeing views on
the
bill um well we have a very very high
second homeownership so we do will find
that those second homeowners are going
to buy their second homes in other
destinations um we do coordinate with
other business segments um and work
closely with those Lakes associations to
support education and support getting
the word out on on these laws and the
education of safe and proper boating and
we also have worked with the other
tourism businesses with white mountain
attractions and New Hampshire travel
Council which both have statewide
membership that you'll see of also have
bill any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing
none thank you thank you very much
is there anyone from uh Dees
representing Dees in the audience yet I
don't see one I know we have Captain dun
uh from the from the Marine Patrol uh
but we keeping him in reserved for uh
any of really hard questions
so go moving on uh look for uh uh in uh
in for a support of the
bill uh Shirley
Enfield hi I'm Charlie green and I thank
you very much for this opportunity I
really appreciate it to speak about an
issue that's very important to the
health of our
Lakes
I support this bill and I support
environmentally sustainable Public
Access I live on Crystal Lake in Infield
my family's been there since the 60s and
we've always enjoyed the lake in
Recreation but still always taking care
of the health of that
Lake uh Crystal Lake is about four
approximately 400 acres and it has a
small area that about 50 ft deep the
average uh depth is 20 and I believe
it's really critical this bill is really
critical to restoring and preserving the
health of the lake in all of our Lakes I
have uh one example I'd like to share uh
as I said we've always tried to uh
protect the health of our Lake and one
of the things that we've tried to
protect is the shoreline from
erosion we've always let the wild Alder
grow in on the edge of the lake to
protect so that the shoreline wouldn't
be eroded and in the last two
years that wild aler that's been there
for a long time and kept the
the the soil and everything in place on
the edge is now the roots are totally
exposed you can see right back to as far
behind the roots and that's all from the
uh wake and wave action that we've been
seeing in the last two years and another
thing that uh my husband is president of
our association and I'm treasur so we
get a lot of questions from time to time
from people on the lake and people
visiting and the summer before last we
had someone called
and asked that they were thinking of
renting on a lake and they asked us if
there had been any cyano bacteria blooms
on our Lake and at that time I could say
no that we know didn't know of any and
if there were we would probably know it
and uh but I couldn't say that last year
our excuse me could you get closer to
the mic and tip it down a little bit so
that oh I'm sorry yeah
okay so I keep going okay so uh I don't
know if you heard we had a question from
someone who was considering renting on
the lake and uh they asked if there had
been a cyano bacteria Bloom on our Lake
this is summer before last and uh at
that time we could say no we knew of
none that had happened that changed last
this past summer there were three blooms
so it goes to show it really does it
will affect the economy and the value of
property around the lake if our
Shoreline is eroded and if there a cyano
bacteria blooms I believe in the
recreation we as I said our family has
enjoyed that Lake for many many years
but we've there's a balance you need to
take care of your Lake
too thank
you any questions by me for members of
much from in propositions of the bill
Steve
Street
and M Mr street L the last hearing you
had you were the last one when I found
your card at the bottom of the pile I
said no not not again so you're awfully
unlucky I appreciate it thank you but
floor is yours um hi everyone uh thank
you all for being here my name is Steve
Street I live in Molton Boro New
Hampshire and thank you for your
dedication to our state and the cares of
our Lakes I think everyone here is
because we care and this is important to
all of us so thank you um I've been
blessed with the joys of New Hampshire's
Lake since my youth from family Tings in
The Lakes Region to boating experiences
on Lake winaki during my times at
Plymouth State College in
2016 my lifelong love for these Waters
culminating the acquisition of a
waterfront home on wiip pasak residing
year round in a small Cove on wiip
were firsthand observers of the diverse
watercraft can you also get closer and
pull it up yeah you got it sorry guys
speak so residing year round in a small
Cove I'm wiip we were firsthand
observers of diverse watercraft activity
uh our small Cove attracts all boating
types every summer day for its calm
Waters but can barely fit one tuber or
one water skier at a time or one wake
surf boat at a time traditional boats
pulling tubers in their quest to deliver
thrilling rides weave chaotic patterns
across the water creating large waves
that while a source of joy for the
participants contrast sharply with B
behavior of wak surf boats I should know
I do both of these things wak surf boats
known for with their modest speed of
approximately 11 mph Traverse our lakes
and long predictable paths unlike large
waves sorry unlike their tubing
counterparts which at Double that speed
craft large waves and erratic patterns
to dislodge their passengers this
unpredictable Behavior while fun poses
challenges not only in navigation but
also maintaining safety on the water
this proposed law will not diminish any
of these large tubing waves and while
every watercraft category includes both
responsible and less cautious operators
wake surve driving Demands a higher
level of skill and awareness these are
not easy boats to drive this in turn
Fosters a community of captains who are
not only more familiar with the laws but
also more deliberate in their navigation
and prioritize safety I see it every day
in our Cove that has over 2400 feet of
wooded Shoreline or the larger Cove
where we wake surf that has a 3M Long
Cove of treelined water front front I
have never once seen an uprooted
Shoreline I care about our Waters I care
deeply about them should I ever see
evidence of shoreline erosion where I
boat on wiip I would Advocate to
mitigate it my son a testament to the
educational recreational value of wake
serve acquired his commercial captain's
license not just his regular boating
safety certificate last spring
dedicating his time to imparting the
joys of water sports using a wake surf
boat to Young campers at a weekl long
overnight camp on Mary meeting Lake
every weekend he and six of his
commercial boating captain friends come
to our house to safely wake surf on wiip
these young captains are far better
trained and have more advanced
certifications than most captains on our
Waters I urge you to oppose this law as
it will only undermine such valuable
learning experiences future New
Hampshire recreational boers but also
jeopardizes the livelihoods of those on
rely those that rely on wake surfing
industry
it will abandon hundreds of young
campers that come to our state to learn
safe and healthy water sports activities
this law will have no effect on the
amount or size of the waves that hit our
Waki shorelines and will only further
burden an underresourced Marine Patrol
with complex and difficult laws to
enforce the proposed legislation
overlooks the Nuance realities of our
waterways please oppose this Bill thank
you any questions by members of the
committee
thank you seeing none thank you very
much Patricia tarpe from Lake winaki
Association speak for three to four
Bill thank you um as you said my name's
uh Pat tarpy I'm president of the Lake
wabaki
Association uh we are a 501 c 3
nonprofit whose mission is dedicated to
protecting the water quality and natural
resources of the lake and its Watershed
we work through monitoring education
stewardship and using Science guided
approaches for Lake
management we strongly support House
Bill 1390 because we believe the science
and the physical documentation is clear
wakes generated by wake surfing are
having a detrimental effect on water
quality an aquatic
habitat we're not against wake surfing
this bill doesn't look to ban it it just
looks to establish better areas of the
lake in which it should be
conducted we know um from over 40 years
of data that phosphorus levels in the
lake are increasing we know that
cyanobacteria blooms are increasing in
frequency and
duration we know that boating on the
lake has increased significant ly since
covid we know that these wakes generated
are causing shoreline erosion they churn
up bottom Lake sediments and they do
present safety hazards to people and
children on the
shore disturbing Lake Bottom sediments
can cause clog fish gills kill fish eggs
cause turbidity as has been mentioned
and potentially tear up plant roots or
fragment plants like mil oil communities
have spent a lot of money to control and
manage mil foil
um let's see we know from the work that
we've done that mitigation is expensive
we've been conducting Watershed and
water quality studies on
wiip and we've identified over 270 sites
on land that need to be fixed to reduce
pollutant storm water and sediment load
into the the lake these are estimated to
cost at a conservative $2.8
million so hold on and the state knows
that mitigation is expensive because
you've just established a cyano bacteria
mitigation fund with a million
dollars
s many Lake management strategies are
difficult or expensive to implement
establishing a wakes Sports Zone is a
simple and reasonable measure that will
ensure the enjoyment of sport continues
while also protecting the sensitive and
vulner vulnerable Nearshore zones of the
lake along with the wildlife and Aquatic
habitat and the good news is this
doesn't really cost anything to do
having a buffer is not like these other
expensive mitigation things this is just
one source of exacerbation of what we're
seeing happening to our
leges and in my testimony I've submitted
we've also put out a map that shows the
150t distance on winaki and the 500t
distance proposed here and there's still
a tremendous amount of Lake to enjoy for
you is there any questions by members of
the
committee seeing none oh no
if you guys don't speak up I'm that's
just going to keep on going thank you um
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so in your written testimony
I just want to clarify the what's the
yellow and the blue line the yellow is
the current 150 ft setb
for no wake Headway speed and the 500
shows where the five the blue lines of
500 foot buffer okay thank you very much
chair for our
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um since you're
from uh the Lake winaki Association I
presume this is a like a Property Owners
Association that represents the property
owners and we heard earlier that there's
concerns about um property evaluations
is is your membership concerned about
property evaluations because of this
bill our membership is concerned with
property valuations um we know now that
uh approximately $16 billion are
property values on winaki we had a study
done two years ago that said the value
of wiip was 17
billion um we are concerned with water
quality degradation which will decrease
property values and decreasing property
values just means tax rate goes up for
everybody followup for a followup thank
you Mr chair
um have you or your members um
experienced any specific sediment um
disturbances because of um wake wake
boats and wake surfing in
particular so bottom sediments I can say
if it's directly due to wake boats I
cannot say that I can say that certain
strains of cyanobacteria over winter in
the bottom sediments so if you're
disturbing those
um that can stir that up and bring that
up into the water column I know that
there are some of our members here who
can speak to witnessing shoreline
properties any other questions by
members of the Committee hearing
you I didn't hear you Mr representative
wolf for a question thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to uh ask you the
same question that I asked to Mr Wall-E
do you believe that there's any room for
here um possibly but I do believe that
there's numerous scientific studies that
have been done that show 500 ft is the
you any other questions by members of
the
much Jeremiah Burke from good you good
you Boat Company speaking in opposition
bill good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee I appreciate
the time today uh to share some thoughts
with you I'm vice president of the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association and
general manager of good who Boat
Company uh you may I recognize a few of
you from uh as acting as a tour guide in
Wolf bro uh this last summer um good
Hugh we have four locations in New
Hampshire and employ a staff of over 200
people in the summertime that we oppose
House Bill
1390 I believe we live in one of the
most beautiful places on Earth I was
born here I grew up here my wife and I
choose to raise our five boys
here I love the lakes and everything
they have to offer my family like many
others create memories and family bonds
because of the time spent recreating on
in and around the lakes of New
Hampshire I assure you that is in all of
our best interests to protect the lakes
that are the lifeblood of our state and
local economies and create many jobs for
New Hampshire
residents while I understand the
intentions that led to the introduction
of the bill I firmly believe that house
bill 1390 is not the answer this bill
will restrict A specific group of boers
and water sports enthusiasts who have
the same rights as other users of public
Waters if approved then who will be next
the bill would also undermine the values
and traditions of New Hampshire which
are rooted deeply in Freedom House Bill
1390 is
discriminatory instead let us continue
to focus on
education our membership is doing our
part to educate with the lake wake
responsibly campaign information about
our efforts to promote best practices in
influence behavior is in your packet
under tab three
over the past couple of years we have
spent tens of thousands of dollars times
and resources on and energy on New
Hampshire wake
responsibly uh we have more work to do
there is also Senate Bill 431 that
promotes these efforts that we should
all
support another topic that needs to be
addressed is
enforcement we have dedicated members of
Marine Patrol patrolling th New
Hampshire's thousand lakes
but getting fewer in number did you know
in 2023 we only had 30 Marine Patrol
officers enforcing voting laws 30 and
come to find out about a third of those
are administrative staff not even
patrolling the actual
Lakes this is the lowest number of
officers in memory many remember when we
were concerned when we only had 60
officers now we have half that
number helping helping increase Marine
stream Patrol officers should be the
reason this room is
filled with more officers enforcing the
laws that we have there will be fewer
problems on the
lake finally let's talk about the
environment Mother Nature is the biggest
contributor to Shoreline issues the
phosphates and fertilizers septic
systems municipalities storm water to
name a few are what really causes issues
for water
quality in conclusion I'll give you one
quick example of how we can work
together and educate the
public uh we see things at the marina
that others do not
see uh we have seen boats come into our
boat launch that are not fit to launch
because in this example algae
growth uh is not healthy for our Waters
and and we do not let them launch until
fully cleansed and washed there's a
picture in your packet that shows an
example of what happened when uh someone
came to try to Launch lach their boat uh
so we cleaned their boat uh the next
year when that person came back for
their vacation they came back and the
boat was already cleaned and he came and
he found me out and he said guess look
at my boat I cleaned it before I came uh
so Education Works uh thank you for your
time and I ask you to vote against House
Bill
1390 any questions by members of the
committee I have one Mr
chair thank you representative rung for
a question okay thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question Mr Brook um
you talk about the values and traditions
of boating in New Hampshire can you tell
me when did wake boats get introduced
and when did just the regular votes get
re get introduced like what's the
timeline uh when I started in the
industry which was 10 years ago it was
prior to 10 years ago so I would i'
think it was probably 15 15 plus years
ago
ago any other questions by members of
the
committee representative thank you for
taking my
question I'm just listening to all of
this and maybe you're the best person to
ask how many wake boats are there choose
your Lake wiip
um walki Wan Squam new I mean how
on is has good hum Marines sold within
the last five years uh so we
sell I don't know the answer you know
but I can tell you from our experience
certainly there's other dealers um
around um we sell approximately maybe 30
boats uh a year uh between a couple of
dealerships it's not a huge quantity of
boats um by all means when you you look
at the amount of boat
registrations uh that are registered in
New Hampshire that total over 100,000
boats um so it's by by comparison it's
far fewer than than the rest of the
Boating that happens out
there any other any other questions Mr
chair over here
that representative Derby for question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I understand that Marine the
Marine trades Association or you know
related groups um have an education
Campaign which I applaud to um you know
to educate um wake Surfers one of the
things that I see missing um from that
is a concern about the depth um and the
impacts to the sediment and I'm
wondering if the Marine trades
Association is planning on um on
including that in their materials in be
since the propulsion is at a much
steeper angle than a traditional boat
such that you can generate the
wake uh as far as depths I mean
certainly it's that's not something
that's enforceable I mean how do you
tell what depth uh you know a boat is at
unless you have a transducer that
measures the depth in that area um and
and so enforcing something like a depth
uh it would be very difficult however I
I also believe the the setbacks of
um 150 feet and and what's proposed in
uh Senate Bill 431 of 200 feet you're
already passed a lot of those shallow
depths at that point um and so I don't
issue any other questions by members of
the
much in support of the bill Gary York
three
minutes thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Gary yor
from hopkington New
Hampshire this is not your grandmother's
Waker boat that we're dealing
with I'd like to refer to a study done
in Minnesota in 2021 later published in
February of
22 of which I will provide you with a
PDF copy all of you by
email in this
study they looked at four different
boats two of which were your traditional
fast ski boats Towing skiers
hydroplaning or uh Towing tubers the
other two boats are the new fangled
nuisance uh wave surf boats one of the
two having an
aftermarket uh U option which in fact
increased the wave height uh if it
wasn't high enough already by
33%
so for purposes of the study I would
just refer to the dimensions of the room
from window to
window and let's just say that's 100 ft
for the two conventional ski
boats uh passing by let's say going in
this direction comparing that to the two
wake surf boats at the same
distance and that is 100 ft
the wake surf boats compared to the
traditional ski
boats uh measured two to three times
more wave
height two to three times more wave
height they measured anywhere from three
to nine times increased energy in the
wave produced by the wak surf boats over
traditional boats three to three to nine
times more energy
the waves the WG surf boats produced 6
to 12 times more power when measured at
the analyzing
stations that gives you an idea of some
hard data that does
support increased effects of erosion no
one can deny that that amount of energy
and power increase is going to have less
of an effect this is going to have more
of an effect on erosion and everything
that relates to
that and as a comparison how does a how
does a wake surf boat compare to a
traditional speed boat as far as wave
propagation energy and so on so let's
let's now take this distance of 200 ft
between the
windows and the traditional ski boats
produce wave heights energy and power at
200 ft that measures
X to have that that
same characteristic wave in a wake
surfboat the wake surf boat would have
to be 500 ft away to produce that same
effect so that's clear evidence that
that is more energy more power creating
havoc on the shoreline creating Havoc
for uh small craft paddlers paddle
borders people in a canoe
more that
effort so in summary I would say that um
I
support uh the bill as it stands
although would be open to some
compromise as representative wolf has
recommend perhaps or
question um I think the main issue is
and I see it today on the lake
U uh enforcement so that's another issue
but should be another bill that would
increase funding for enforcement of this
thank
you there any questions uh for the uh
from the
can hearing
much in opposition to the bill Ryan
liberti
Liberty
don't tell me there's two people with
name for three
minutes hello everyone my name is Ryan
Liberty and I'm from B New Hampshire I
am in e8th grade and I go to B Memorial
School I have been wake surfing for most
of my life um we tried it on vacation
did you get closer to the
microphone um um we tried it on vacation
and my whole family has loved it ever
since we bought our own boat so we can
spend our summers in new boating in New
Hampshire now the best part about this
is that we get to be together talk
exercise have fun and have a break from
our screens I go to waterm camp on Mary
meeting Lake it is a sleep away camp
that I have gone to for the past three
Summers my little brother started going
with me last year um I hope to work
there when I'm old enough this bill
would impact that because of the size of
Mary meeting Lake this bill would also
impact the lake that my family spends
time on because of the 500 foot setback
because the 500 foot setback means we
can't use our Surf Boat there anymore a
500t setback will make any lakes wide
enough much more crowded for surfing
overcrowding will make it more likely
that people will get hurt because
everyone will have to serve together on
fewer Lakes the 200t setback for Senate
bill for 4 431 which I testified in
favor of would be a much better solution
to both increase the setback by also
allowing people to surf and keep us all
safe thank you for listening and for
your consideration please oppose House
Bill
much I understand there someone from
Dees
here
do they wish to
bill no you're just you're just here for
the entertainment
okay all right then we'll go right along
moving right
along in support of the
bill uh NJ
meding from Springfield
minutes good afternoon my name is Aaron
meeting I'm a resident of Springfield
New Hampshire chair of the Springfield
Conservation Commission and a lifelong
water and winter Ice Sports Enthusiast
on our Lakes thank you for the
opportunity to speak
today I stand before you to advocate for
the approval of HB
1390 we are blessed with stunning
natural resources that we have a duty to
cherish and protect this bill is a
crucial step in safeguarding our
environment the well-being of our
communities and supporting our economy
while continuing to ensure sustainable
Public
Access first and foremost wakes sporting
while thrilling and we've heard
testimony can be quite fun can have
detrimental effects on our precious
ecosystems
the powerful wakes can erode
shorelines disrupt wildlife habitats and
disturb the delicate balance of our
aquatic
systems by implementing restrictions on
these activities we can mitigate harmful
impacts and preserve the natural beauty
that defines our state while also
ensuring that access to Safe Recreation
continues to be enjoyed on our public
Waters the importance of this Bill
extends Beyond environmental safety and
recreational access
concerns as legislators we have a duty
to prioritize the well-being of our
constituents and the communities that we
serve by approving this bill we
demonstrate our commitment to protecting
the interest of all those who call our
state home we show that we are willing
to take decisive action to not only
Safeguard the environment but also to
protect the Rob robust economic benefit
that our public Waters
provide this economic benefit is one
which personally impacts my family as my
husband's company kitewing LLC a
handheld wind powerered wing saale
company that we use on our lakes in
summers and
Winters this is a part of the very
livelihood of my family and it depends
on the preservation and health of our
Lakes in conclusion HB 1390 is not just
about regulating recreational activities
it is about preserving the natural
wonders of our state promoting safe
sustainable activity on our waterways
and prioritizing the needs of our
communities our state's economy is
largely dependent upon tourism our
beautiful lakes and ponds are one of the
Priceless natural resources that attract
visitors to New Hampshire they provide
great source of economic prosperity for
many of your
constituents it is essential to protect
this economic and vital natural resource
for generations to come I respectfully
urge the committee to consider the
long-term benefits of this legistation
and to join me in supporting its
approval thank you for your
time any questions by me members of the
chair
you for for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question as a member of
the Springfield uh Conservation
Commission and I noticed that uh little
Sunny lake is in Springfield which is a
472 acre Lake I was wondering if you'd
ever seen 4ot natural waves on that
Lake I am not personally on that Lake I
do however interact with families that
own property on the lake um in my
involvement with lspa and some other
organizations um I have heard that there
are concerns um erosion is certainly a
concern I know that on our specific Lake
um contained entirely in Springfield
Lake kimok there are certain concerns
due to the type of lake that it is that
it does not have as much plant growth as
other a Lakes do and therefore any type
of erosion could be very detrimental to
representative wolf for a question thank
you Mr chairman and and if I'm out of
order please tell me um I see two
Representatives here from Department of
Environmental Services and I'm wondering
if they would like to comment on this
the okay they're off Mr
chair yes yes thank you um following uh
representative Wolf's comment I do know
that this is a bill that Dees is
tracking it's on their list um would you
mind asking if we are to expect any
written testimony from the Department
before we go into executive
session we're not going into executive
session today no but when we whenever we
do because it is being would you repeat
it so I could I only heard part of it
what exactly did you say to I know that
um New Hampshire Dees has listed this
bill among the list of bills that they
are tracking this year and I was
wondering since it is a bill they are
tracking if we would be um if we should
expect to get some testimony on on um
their opinion on this bill um before we
have to make a decision whether that is
in a week or two weeks or whenever
that's right now I don't think that
that's something before us they will get
something that information to us
day thank
you uh now is there any other questions
of members of the
much I next I will call in oppos
opposition to the bill
Peter
bous good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee you can hear okay not
as tall as
John my name is Peter McCallum I'm the
owner of mccallum's Boat House on
Northwood Lake in epim New Hampshire my
family has been family is my dealership
has been familyowned for three
generations
and is currently celebrating our 75th
year in
business I'm representing my dealership
but I'm also representing New Hampshire
Marine trade dealerships our businesses
work with DMV New Hampshire Marine
Patrol to register Vehicles vessels
promote safe boating in New
Hampshire we work with many Lake
Community programs to keep our Lakes
healthy our dealership's Collective goal
is to preserve a positive boating
culture for current and future
Generations
today I'm speaking in opposition to
House Bill 1390 due to its overreach on
restriction and if pass creat a wake
Sports ban on a significant amount of
Waterway within our state please know
that my industry is not anti-
legislation we are in full support of
Senate Bill
431 a more modest resolution that seeks
a foot setback a significant increase
over current safe passage
laws Senate Bill 431 promotes a buffer
and not a ban for Wake sports like what
three other eastern states have passed
Tennessee South Carolina and Georgia my
industry has studied with a civil
engineer to see how HB 1390 would impact
access to various bodies of water to
determine our
opposition if you'd please turn to tab
number two and look at the lake maps in
your packet that have been
provided the these six maps have been
engineer prepared to reflect the
difference in available Recreation space
on each water body in totality or simply
100% versus a 200t setback versus a 500t
Shore under that Tab and that map
collection you'll first see Squam Lake
in holderness out of 100% of available
Recreation space a 500t set back leaves
60.1% for Wig
Sports Puckaway Lake in Nottingham a
21.8% Northwood Lake in Northwood 500 ft
leaves
36.5% for
wakesports please note that Northwood is
my home Lake and this bill will affect
my staff's ability to educate instruct
and demonstrate as well as service
products
properly Pine River Pond in Wakefield
New Hampshire 500 ft leaves
8.2% cobitz Pond and Windham 500 ft
leaves
17.9% and lock Lake in Barnstead 500
feet leaves
1.9% of space for Wake
Sports please note that these
percentages speak to what is generally
available in Recreation areas for Wake
Sports if no other boats are in
operation on that body of water it also
does not address Islands other
structures or any depth requirements as
proposed in this house
bill if 1390 was to become law you can
see that all of these water bodies would
be restricted so the lake be populated
by one or two other water Craft on a
typical boating day the Wake sport
activity you enjoy as a family is simply
no longer Avail uh possible or Available
to You 1390 is simply a ban on Wake
Sports a allow me to put into context
what 500 ft looks like better yet what
1,000 ft looks like as 1390 calls for
that space 500 ft to Port 500 ft to
starboard 500 ft to Bow and
Stern in your packet under tab number
two you'll see seven examples of this
proposed setback distance should 1390
pass our new area of operation as a wake
Sports operator is 1,000 ft
wide this distance is 10 ft short of
three NFL football fields linked end to
end still can't picture the distance the
store Street Parking Garage in conquered
to the front steps of the legislative
office building is 1,000
ft picture the confusion created when an
oncoming vessel impedes this new
potential wake zone which boat which
operator is in the wrong and which will
be breaking a proposed
law our industry believes and stands
behind a more balanced solution in
Senate Bill 431 Senate Bill 431 is
currently working through the Senate and
can provide the pathway forward to
balance all the issues Public Access
economics environment and avoids
navigation confusion I urge you to vote
and oppose legislation in front of you
and find 1390
itl thank
you any any questions or members of the
committee Mr chair I have a
question yes okay or a question okay and
thank you Mr MCC for accepting my
question um you mentioned your home lake
is Northwood Lake I'm curious have they
experienced any cyano bacteria blooms
and have been has that been attributed
to any disturbance in the sediment or
erosion we we have Through The Years
this year is particularly bad due to 17
possible boating weekends and 14
weekends of
rain
committee representative L mon thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um certainly by looking at your
map some of the smaller Lakes especially
if they're narrow the the area for
recreation which you mean wake sporting
um is very limited but do you believe
that
many small and many small lakes that it
probably is unwise or inappropriate to
wakeboard
no I strategically selected those Lakes
because they're within the market that
my business
serves and to to be quite Frank I've
been battling this issue for over five
years and we're we're trying to find
home and and my efforts to create the
maps were to find an agreeable balance
but clearly 500 ft
followup but with many of these small
lakes um it doesn't prohibit other
Recreation on the
lake do you feel that in a small Lake um
if it's very small the wake boarding
really limits the use by other types of
um water
activities I I don't believe that uh
Wick responsibly speaks very clearly to
Safe passage and our industry supports
that
distance any additional
questions Mr
chair I don't have an additional
question um but I do want to um
representative Darby brought to my
attention that we did receive a letter
of testimony from Dees yesterday around
10:00 I I didn't have it in my um inbox
but I just wanted to alert the rest of
the committee that we have received
their testimony and they're not taking a
position thank
right any other questions by members of
the committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you very much we just been
doing some count C counting here folks
uh just let you know we did the first
hour we did 10 and I think we have
enough for three more hours so we'll
keep
Blondell
speak in support of the bill for three
minutes
somebody hopefully somebody does three
minutes I'll try thank
you I am David Blundell from wiam here
to support HB
1390 my graduate level education is an
ocean engineering and I was the torpedo
propulsion engineer for the US
Navy I have knowledge of propeller
design and wave
propagation I am
concerned about the environmental
sustain ability of New Hampshire lakes
and ponds being adversely affected by
the growing presence and operation of
wibo
Surfing I have lived on kobitz Pond
since
2016 each year I have seen a continuing
increase in the number of wake surf
boats and the increase in size and
displacement of these
boats I have had significant damage to
my Shoreline including five trees
falling into the pond due to shoreline
erosion from the large waves striking
the
shore I have been tossed while sitting
on my dock from the large waves
uplifting my dock from boats passing by
Within 200 to 300
fet when kayaking I need to stop and
brace myself for the oncoming
wave I have resigned to kayaking mainly
in the morning when the Wake surfboats
are at their docks
in addition the large waves churn the
water in the shallow areas less than 20
ft of water causing the pond B bottom
muck to wash
ashore I have noticed that when
considerate wake boers stay in the
center of the pond around 200 excuse me
around 400 to 500 feet from the shore
the effects of the Waves
diminished as a member of the car robbit
Pawn vlap teams since 2017 I have seen a
steady declining trend of water Clary in
increase in phosphates each year it
seems to coincide with the increased
presence of the number of wake surf
boats these boats are a detriment to
water quality and recreational enjoyment
on the
pond I feel bad for the poor loons
shoreline thank you any questions by
committee
see representative Derby for our
question thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question with respect to
kobitz Pond I don't have the exact size
in front of me but I bet it's about 450
acres 400 Acres something like that I'm
wondering if you've seen any natural
waves that are 4 feet high natural wind
driven waves so it is uh com it is made
up of two t two bodies of uh it's kind
of in a figure eight I think the total
acreage is a little over 300 acres so
the larger Pond uh area is around 200
Acres I have not seen 4ot waves uh other
than uh you know the the waves that I
see uh perhaps are three feet high
coming off the back of the the stern of
the of the WG boats thank
you
any other members of the committee
asking for a
question hearing none thank you very
much I think I saw just leave
representative Matt
Coker and if he's guys he might have
just stepped
person
Jody
representing well whole bunch of places
is hi I'm jod grimiss with the New
Hampshire Marine trades I'm going to be
very brief um I learned my lesson I
didn't bring a big box of paper
testimony for you um but I will hope you
note that on the online there is a lot
of online testimony that has been
submitted over almost 1,700 folks have
signed up in opposition to the bill what
I did say I would do I had two speakers
that were planning to come today that
got called away for work so I have their
testimony to present to you I'm not
going to read it but give you the
highlights um the first is Michael Hayes
from he's a resident of sunap he is a
combat veteran and a Bronze Star Award
recipient for Valor and a former
commander of the Navy SEAL Team too he
is is a big supporter of wake surfing he
has found that in his um duties he has
had injuries and he finds it is helpful
to his mental and physical health he is
asking for the committee not to pass
this bill um he has also has concerns
about kind of infra infringing on
people's freedoms that he has spent his
career fighting for and he's also
concerned about pushing wake surfing to
the middle of a lake where there'll be
more possibility for risks and injury
the second set of testimony is from
Steven Raymond he is a n Hampshire
native of gtown uh his family lives in
Manchester he is an environmental
engineer with 25 years experience one of
the big engineering firms in Manchester
um he wished he could have been here
today but his work takes him he focuses
on remediation and restoration of
wetlands and shorelines from New
Hampshire to across the country he
speaks specifically in his testimony
about the environment and what causes
Shoreline um erosion and BAS basically I
think you'll read I hope you'll read his
testimony because he's very clear that
boat waves are not the concern when
they're remediating and restoring
you you have this board F the
record okay do uh any questions by
committee seeing none Andrea
Lakes put here good afternoon members of
the committee I am Andrea Laro president
of New Hampshire lakes and I am here to
speak in support of
1390 as uh many of you know New
Hampshire Lakes were a Statewide
nonprofit organization dedicated to
restoring and preserving the health of
all of New Hampshire's 1,000 Lakes
we recognize that clean and healthy
Lakes are vital to our stakeholders the
general public Recreation business and
tourism in the overall
economy we represent many local Lake
Associations and Lake enthusiasts uh
throughout the state that support this
bill and I know you've heard from many
of them um New Hampshire Lakes uh I want
to set the record straight we believe
that wake Sports is a familyfriendly uh
activity for of people of all
ages we know that it's a fun way to
enjoy our Lakes we know that it supports
business we know that jobs rely on it we
have supporters that enjoy wake Sports
my family enjoys wake
Sports we know that boating in general
is good for our
families and drives their economy we
also know that clean and healthy lakes
in general provide families residents
and visitors overall throughout New
Hampshire even more in terms of
enjoyment and support to our economy
than boating alone yes boating brings in
a great deal of to our estate wake
Sports brings in some but overall at the
end of the day it's clean and healthy
lakes that are driving um our
tourism-driven economy and providing a
myriad of opportunities for our families
our citizens and our
visitors over the years New Hampshire
Lakes has been involved in economic
studies that show that people will
choose to stop visiting our state if
they if they determine or feel that our
Lakes are being degraded that our Lakes
are becoming unhealthy our economic
Studies have shown that jobs will be
lost property values will go down so
clean and healthy Lakes are very very
important to the
economy so I have some good news
experience and science has shown us that
when conducted far from Shore and in
deep water wake Sports can have minimal
impacts on our health of our
Lakes unfortunately in what you've heard
from many today when wake sports are
conducted too close to Shore and too
shallow of water inappropriate places
they are going to impact uh the health
the the shoreline the lake Bottom
endangering L health and causing other
sorts of issues to for other forms of
recreation and for property and property
damage you have heard a 500t buffer from
the shoreline and a 20 foot depth
minimum is supported by many studies you
have heard a lot today about a uh 200
foot setback as proposed in at Senate
Bill 431 this 200 foot setback to our
understanding is based on one study one
study in which the authors admitted that
um they did mathematical models that
were valid at one 100 ft from Shore but
the authors indicated that the model
could not be extrapolated to 200 ft
therefore rendering the the outcome of
that study uh potentially not credible
so we do not support or believe that
that 200 foot study is is something
that's scientifically
credible there's a growing wave of um
thinking throughout the country that
this sport um requires some additional
setback fact you may be aware that on
February 14th of this year Vermont the
state of Vermont passed a wake Sports
rule very similar to this rule but
actually more more protective in that it
also deals with aquatic invasive species
prevention and spread um the state of
Michigan just initiated um very similar
legislation to this on February 28th
establishing a wake Sport Zone of 500 ft
20t depth we are not alone
in throughout the country thinking that
this particular activity needs a little
bit more consideration for what it's
doing to the health of our
Waters there's one really particular
point I wanted to bring up today we've
taugh a lot talked a lot about economics
here today and I wanted to point out and
I've shared with you in my handout the
state of Vermont did a really extensive
2year review of the proposed law um in
that state it was originally a th000 ft
60 Acres of contiguous area in the state
of Vermont two different state agencies
there after several years of
consideration um and after two economic
analysis to determine that 500 ft there
was appropriate I found their economic
analysis particularly interesting they
conducted two scenarios with and without
the regulation in Vermont 10 years into
the future so they looked at if this
500t rule 20ft depth uh 50 contiguous
area rule was put into effect or wasn't
put into effect what would the outcome
be on the E economy economy for the next
10 years so what that study found is
that the analys showed that the economic
benefit of the Wake Sports regulation
outweighs the costs by 10 to one the
annual benefits estimated at 93 million
include the reservation of water quality
the the continuation of affordable
smallscale recreational activities on
the that form the core of Vermont's
water-based Recreation and the
protection of the tourist economy that
depends on clean and healthy
lakes that study concluded that the
potential annual costs of implementing
the rule was 8 million and based on and
based on the limitations that the role
would place on the growth of the wakes
boat industry so again the Vermont
economic analysis said implementing the
rule um Ben had economic benefits 10 to
one I would suggest
that the implementation of a lake
friendly wake Sports rule might also
have a similar economic effect here in
New Hampshire representative L earlier
asked you know what is the sensus how
many wake sport how many wake boats are
on New Hampshire's Lakes I certainly
don't have that answer
but I can provide you some sort of
anecdotal data many of you may know that
New Hampshire Lakes every summer um
implements the lake host program this is
a courtesy boat inspection program that
we provide to boter throughout the state
at 100 of the most highly used boat
ramps in the state generally speaking
every year we interact and teach and
help um anywhere from 90 to 100,000
voters per year um throughout our
history we've in interacted with um just
under 2 million boter what I can tell
you is whenever we interact with a Boer
we are going to record what kind of
craft they're in so what kind of boat so
um last year and actually I did this
over the past five years so at from 2000
to last year um generally speaking of
those let's Round Up to 100,000 about 3
to 5% of the boats that we come in
contact voters that we come in contact
with have a ballast boat um the rest of
them are all other types of motorboats
and paddlecraft so my point in bringing
this up to you is generally speaking
this wake Sports ballast boats are
fairly small percentage of the
recreational activity that we are seeing
going from Lake to Lake to Lake um and
we feel that you know all that what
you've heard from the supporters today
this relatively small form you know not
as small form of recuperation on our
Lakes is creating a
disproportionately large impact um you
know creating um problems for other
forms of recreation to Coexist on the
lake so I suggest that um it is
appropriate and I hope that you find it
reasonable to to uh support this bill
that there needs to be a better balance
and um again we are supportive of the
500t 20ft depth as it is based in
credible sign
so I thank you for that opportunity and
I uh to speak and we'll be happy to
questions Mr chair Mr
chair representative rung for a question
thank you Mr chair and and thank you Mr
lro for your testimony I have your your
written packet that was distributed and
I really appreciate um the objective
analysis because this is a very
emotional issue and I see that in
Vermont that they had an economic
analysis the Michigan report is is seems
strictly um environmental but you
mentioned earlier in your testimony
there question yeah it's coming right
now Mr chair thank you um you mentioned
earlier in your testimony about that you
had done an economic study or New
Hampshire right um do you have that I
don't have that here today I can
certainly get that to you all um it's
it's a little dated but it's still I
think it's can show you the different um
relative proportions of of uses and we
can also update it in these today's
dollars so yes thank you for that okay
thank
you for a
question thank you Mr chair let me take
this question thank you for answering
this question um so I'm curious about
the effects of erosion whether it's
twoot 3ot 4ft waves I'm hearing uh o
over and over again that these specific
boats always are at 4T weight waves they
only create 4ft waves or do they
actually have different levels based on
when they are you know whether they're
doing the sport or whether there's
cruising I'm assuming it's not always
the one thing also can you talk about
what the effects of erosion are whether
it's one foot two foot or three foot
wigs great question very technical
question I will do my best um my
understanding is that you know wake
surfing you can control the size of of
the wave so depending on um on you know
how large you want it um I would say
that the various studies you know
summarized there's a bunch of studies
out there and they all looked at sort of
different aspects and and they all
looked at you know different Siz waves
so it's hard to give you an exact oh a
three-foot wave causes this type of
erosion because it also depends on the
shoreline itself you know what the Shor
if it's a Sandy Shoreline a Mucky
Shoreline a rocky Shoreline it's really
going to depend it's a great question
and I really can't give you a more
definitive answer than
that thank
chair representative Darby for another
question thank you thank you Mr chair I
know surprise
surprise thank you for taking my
question I'm
stunned um so I understand that the um
you know the the 200 foot setback maybe
didn't have a Val
um scientific basis it also didn't have
um that the Senate bill that's been
discussed numerous times doesn't have a
depth comp
component I'm wondering um if you can
elaborate on why the depth component is
so important um to this B great thank
you for the question representative
Darby we think that a 20 foot depth or a
depth requirement um is is missing from
the Wake responsibly and should be in it
we also think that it's important for
this bill um I will tell you and there
are folks in this room can that can
testify to this that there are lakes in
New Hampshire that um even at 500 feet
from sure they're not 20 ft deep um and
various Studies have shown that we find
credible that uh you know the downward
as you mentioned earlier the downward
tipping um propeller can disturb
sediment anywhere from 15 to 33 fet
again you know no study is perfect and
they're all kind of looking at this a
little differently um but disturbing the
sediment is going to whip up the
phosphorus that is in the bottom of the
lake um and be available uh for again um
nut uh algae growth toxic cyanobacteria
growth uh thank you for the
question any additional questions by
members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you
something question I'm surprised
yeah I think I'll take two this time
from the opposition that that was the
support one have went so long uh the uh
Ethan heel helier from water sports
industry
Association is see
okay sorry it was a high over here uh in
an attempt to not keep us here till
dinner I will be very short uh as was
said my name is uh Ethan helier and I am
the government Affairs manager for the
water sports industry Association and
thank you chairman and members for
having this hearing today I am here to
voice my opposition to this bill um when
we've been talking about the studies
wsia is in favor of a 200 foot offset
for water sports because it is a number
that's rooted in peer-reviewed research
Naval architect kotti Fay found that
while wake surfing from 200 ft from
Shore waves still may wash up on the
shore these waves will not be carrying
enough Force to degrade shorelines
especially when you compare it to wind
driven waves there's been also a lot of
conversation about the Minnesota study
something that I want to point out about
the Min um something I want to point out
about the University of Minnesota and St
Anthony Falls lab study is that they
found that shoreline erosion is driven
mainly by wind generated wave energy the
St uh Anthony Falls lab studying
Nearshore sediment movement on the
shorelines of 460 Lakes concluded that
shoreline erosion is a result of wind
driven waves with no mention of wake
boats uh We've also talked a little bit
about wake responsibly today which is
something else that I want to you know
expand on we work with all sorts of
units of government whether it be at a
state or a local level as far as you
know getting these either in uh Boer
education or just like here in the in
the state of New Hampshire where you
renew your Boer Boer red registration
you are greeted with the Wake
responsibly tenants in there we also
work with our dealers where we've given
them tens of thousands of these tags
which all go in new boats um you know
again focusing on the three things that
we promote staying 200 ft from Shore
keeping music at a reasonable level and
utilizing the whole lake so the Boating
industry is uh committed to safety and
education um and with that I just ask
you to oppose this bill and I'll take
any
questions Mr
chair
representative Darby for question thank
you so much Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'd like to confirm
that the study that you're referring to
the St Anthony Falls laboratory is
quantifying wave energy on Minnesota
lakes because that boat that study does
not actually find as a result that that
waves are a result that erosion is a
result of wind driven waves that study
is about replanting um uh aquatic uh
aquatic vegetation for fish habitat
that's what that study finds what is the
question so I'd like to make sure that
I'm understanding that we're talking
about the same study quantifying wave
energy on Minnesota lakes chairman and
members yeah they've done two studies
one of them is where they looked or they
researched on 460 lakes in the state of
Minnesota and found that wind is the
main cause of shoreline erosion and then
the other one where they actually looked
at uh wake boats versus other boats you
know again they found that wind is the
main driver towards Shoreland erosion
and they studied wake energy but they
did not study wake Energy's impact on
helpful Mr chair any other questions by
members of the committee yes Mr chair
thank you um you mentioned earlier in
your testimony about the peer reviewed
studies that show that 200 feed is an
adequate distance could you provide us a
list of those studies do you have them
the name of the study I want to get the
correct name it's the one that U was
done by uh Endicott Fay um I don't have
the exact title of the study in front of
me but I have it I can get it for you
would you just email the committee with
it be great thank you I have an idea of
what the title is I just don't want to
get it wrong but I can share it with you
any other members of the committee who
question no one else thank you you very
much thank
you chair calls well first to see if he
Coker I guess he did not come
back he got out way out he got out I
guess he couldn't take it couldn't take
it all right uh Mr Barker uh Jason
Barker uh for three
minutes
uh good afternoon thank you Mr chairman
committee for listening to me uh my name
is Jason
Barker um I'm speaking against HB 1390
because important to me my wife my 8 and
10 15year old children uh my family
first purchased property in East
Wakefield on Province Lake in 1978 and
I've been there my whole life I've been
doing Water Sports on the lake since
1990 when my father first purchased just
our first family boat in 1996 I learned
to wakeboard and still do it to this day
I now have three kids and a wife who all
also wakeboard and wake surf in the last
10 to 15 years wake surfing has become
the big thing for all ages risk of
injury at 10 mph is considerably lower
than doing 20 mph or faster with most
other water sports had my kids on boards
with me before they could do it alone by
themselves and now all of us do this as
a family activity we spent hours upon
hours on the lake doing all of these
getting outside and enjoying the fresh
air instead of sitting inside this bill
passes it will take the way take away
the weake surfing and the weight
boarding will be next I'm confused as to
the purpose of this build they talk
about creating weights that damage
Shoreline capsize canoes you can't see
over the bow and it creates cyano
bacteria those first three have nothing
to do with a lake that's under 20 ft
deep which this law makes a point to
State all those can happen on any siiz
Lake
as this lak St as this law states I
can't use a surfboard wakeboard Hydro
foil or similar device to ride on or in
the Wake directly behind a wake booat
with or without a rope including wake
surfing it doesn't say that I can't go
out in a wake boat fill the ballast bags
and cruise around the lake creating the
same wake whether someone is behind the
boat or not before completely outlying
an activity wondering what else could be
done to minimize the harmful effects
they claim wake surfing has caused in
patrolling the Lakes better so that
people are actually keeping their card
150 ft away from Shoreline and boats
using
fertilizers that don't contain
phosphorus and nitrogen and having
waterfront properties putting in rain
barrels to catch runoff trying to limit
cyano bacteria
balloons thank you for listening please
oppose Bill House Bill
1390 thank you is there a question from
members of the
committee representative Donley thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question as a you a user of a wake boat
Y how frequently do you use your wake
Boo and is creating a 4 foot wave is it
every time you go out when does that
happen so that question that you asked
before no I can go out and that if I'm
going to wake surf yes you're going to
look for a bigger wake now somebody
that's a beginner is not looking for a 4
foot wake um but we can take that boat
out I ski behind that boat which I don't
want I tube behind that boat which I
don't want to wake
um so yeah they're they're going after
the person that's directly behind it w
surfing but I can use that boat and not
create a four 4ot wake um and I guess I
can create the 4-ot Wake with nobody
behind me we go
out if for there's 15 weekends in a
summer um we put the boat in Memorial
Day weekend we take it out Labor Day
weekend so and we maybe on a good summer
we get out twice a day on Saturday and
weekend any other members of the
committee have a question seeing none
thank you very
much Elizabeth Harper Lake sopy
protective
Association good afternoon chair and
members of the house uh my name is Dr
Elizabeth Harper I'm executive director
of the lake cipe protective Association
ation um and before joining lspa about 2
years ago um I was an environmental
science Professor for seven years at New
England college and prior to that I was
a professor of fisheries and wildlife uh
at Paul Smith college in the ader andax
um so I'd like to speak to some of the
science
today um I'm here today to ask you to
support HB
1390 um New Hampshire's Lakes are vital
to our economy they're vital to economy
when they're clean when they support
healthy fish populations and when
they're beneficial for
recreation they're natural resources
that belong to all of us and that must
be managed carefully to ensure that
they're not unnecessarily
degraded we all collectively have a
responsibility to use these resources in
a way that allows future generations to
experience our Lakes as we do today wake
Sports can be conducted responsibly in w
ways that minimize impacts to water
quality and Lake
ecosystems but when wake surfing takes
place too close to the Shoreline or in
Shallow Waters the impacts of the high
intensity waves and the propeller wash
um can be intense and they include
impacts including shoreline erosion
degration uh degradation of fish habitat
uprooting of aquatic plants suspension
of sediment reduction of water quality
and release of phosphorous which we know
leads to toxic cyanobacteria blooms
those impacts degrade the value of the
lakes that are important to all of us
and to our
economy and what I want you to take home
today is the fact that these impacts can
have devastating long-term consequences
those consequences are entirely
avoidable and that's what this legis
legislation is seeking to do is avoiding
those unnecessary costs um to our
economy um and to the resources that we
all hold dear HB 1390 proposes
reasonable limitations on Wake sports
that are based on sound
science the recommendation to limit wake
Sports to areas 500 feet from the
shorelines and depths of 20 ft on bodies
of water at least 50 acres have been
supported by Michigan's Department of
Natural Resources by Vermont's
Department of Environmental Conservation
and by numerous peer-reviewed scientific
studies the best science is summarized
well in a thorough literature review of
over 50 sources that were synthesized by
the state of Michigan's Department of
Natural Resources in July
2023 the recommendations are clear from
that study that that 500 ft distance is
important and that the depth
matters there's a study that keeps
coming up that I want to um clarify for
you all and it's this study that's been
referenced um by Fay at all 2022 that's
been widely cited by the Wake industry
to justify the 200 foot
setback um and I just want to read to
you a few quotes um from several
different scientists and these quotes
were compiled um by the Vermont um
Department of Environmental Conservation
as they were trying to assess what you
all are trying to assess right now so
these are some of the quotes this study
fails to provide the material and
evidence from which to make any sound
conclusions it appears that the authors
rely very heavily on false claims to
make unsubstantiated
conclusions it's hard not to question
the motives of publishing this paper
especially when some of the statements
made are clearly not supported by the
material presented in the body of the
paper you said three minutes apologies
for running over I'm very sorry my
apologies you could you complete you
allow you to that's all right I I will I
will conclude right there um but I just
wanted to be available to answer any
questions on the science if anyone has
any questions I'm happy to answer
those any questions by members of the
committee yes Mr chair um I was just
wondering if you have a copy of your
you I'm we going to be holding people to
the 3 minutes is going
then we're cuz we still got about a
left
and so all
right any more question any other
additional questions by members of the
committee seeing none moving right
along John
Shelly in opposition to the
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee I don't know
how you're staying awake but I
appreciate that I know some of you maybe
uh came in here with a decision made
already hopefully most of you have not
and you're listening to all the
testimony both before uh for and against
this bill I am personally against the
bill I'm going to keep this short I had
a much longer presentation but I am sick
of sitting here and want to get home to
this bill is not the answer it's really
what it comes down to um it it's
targeting it's targeting this particular
kind of boat um that supposedly makes a
4ot wake and by the way if anybody has a
wake booat that actually makes a 4ot
wake I want to be behind it because I
have yet to be behind one that that's is
that big I've got a very very nice wake
Boo and it does not get up to four feet
I'll tell you that um I think this is
really
more about being annoyed by the waves I
really think that's nobody's saying that
but I think that's why this bill is here
we're we're painting it as something to
do with uh protecting the shoreline but
I think it's really about being annoyed
we're all annoyed by it we're all
annoyed by plenty of other boats I'm
annoyed by pontoon boats cuz they're in
the middle of the lake in the way so we
have to swerve around them and they're
out there having their drinks I'm
annoyed by personal
watercraft I I think that's the
motivation behind this but that's a
personal opinion so that's perhaps not
worth anything because you're all
looking for faction figures but um I'd
like to point out that um that one of
the people that were was a proponent of
the bill was talking about how this is a
very small percentage uh that this kind
of boat is a small percentage of all the
boats uh talking about the economy well
if it is a small percentage then the
damage that's coming from all the other
boats the damage to the Shoreline is
going to add up as well I've owned owned
waterfront property for 20 years I live
on it year round all the time I have sat
out there ever since this these types of
bills have started coming up and I've
sat around and I've literally sat out
back and I've counted waves and measured
waves during a summer storm and looked
at the actual damage to my Shoreline and
I can tell you and this is my actual
testimony as if I'm under oath I'm
speaking as if I'm under oath I am under
oath it's the truth I see more damage
from one summer storm
than I ever do from an entire summer of
of uh boating activities all different
kinds including wake boats okay so you
can't pinpoint it on this one particular
kind of boat and furthermore we are we
are all self-regulating I go out there
and I talk to other wake boers and I say
hey you're too close to shore we're
getting it out when we first had
personal watercraft we all hated them
too and tried to litigate against them
as well but you know what we didn't put
a law up but people got more common
sense people got a little more whereare
we took care of it as boers as
responsible boers okay we do care about
your Shoreline believe me I don't want
to do any big damage to that but I don't
believe this particular kind of boat and
don't forget that you can sit there in a
boat without any ballasts and go around
in circles and figure eights just like
we do when we're pulling uh tubers and
make waves that are much bigger than uh
that from behind a boat my 3 minutes is
up and I yield and uh we'll answer
questions any questions by members of
the committee
you speaking in support of the bill
James alen A or AI h e n a
n what here how do you how do you spell
minutes I have a copy of uh my testimony
as well as a map of Province Lake my
name is Jim
Aken and I'm the current president of
the Province Lake
Association and I'm in favor of House
Bill
1390 to limit the specific use of wake
Sports in New Hampshire's smaller more
shallower bodies of water Province Lake
is not a small Lake it's about a mile in
diameter but its deepest point is 17 ft
so it's an example of a lake that really
gets churned up by any water uh boat but
specifically the type of boat that
churns the water more plows through the
water uh in
2023 Province Lake was under
cyanobacteria warning four different
times with a total of 85 days that's a
big part of our
summer cyano bacteria blooms occur when
excess nutrients are present our primary
source of nutrients at Province Lake is
from the rich sediment at the bottom of
our
Lake uh storm events do bring more
sediment in but all that does is
contribute to the
Loading making the sediment more
phosphorus
rich
erosion is another problem that it's
testimony and that the these boats are L
are more apt to create
erosion one thing that we're very proud
of at Province Lake is the fact that we
have no identified invasive species we
are concerned that boats with ballast
moving from Lake to Lake are
opportunities for invasive species to
catch a ride if these boats are not
properly drained
a Shallow Lake like ours would be the
perfect environment for invasive weeds
to thrive if
introduced we're trying to educate
ourselves and our membership on ways to
lessen cyanobacteria blooms the bottom
line is that we need to control sources
of nutrients getting into our
Lake and existing nutrients nutrients
keep undisturbed as
possible I'm sure my support of this
bill will be unpopular with some of our
membership but I see it as an
opportunity we cannot ignore it will
hopefully just be one of the many pieces
of the puzzle we need to improve the
health of our Lake for future
generations to
come um we're grasping at straws for
anything um to reduce nutrients um
plantings along the road Route 153 is
about a mile and a half long on the main
New Hampshire border it's basically a
privately owned Beach um where water
runoff just spills things in so um our
membership
is upset by the whole thing the C of
bacteria blooms and we're doing anything
questions still have another couple of
seconds I timed it last night I wasn't
as nervous is there is there any uh any
questions by members of the
committee being none thank you very much
if you could if you had stuff stuff you
want to have to pass out yeah uh just uh
maybe give it to the end of the table
and then we'll just pass it uh it'll
just passed
down
okay in opposition to the bill Carl and
Aaron
Jagger
good afternoon hopefully get us close to
the uh okay good afternoon thank you for
speak Cloud okay are are you going
together or or do you want three three
minutes each we'll try to we'll try to
do this three minutes but we may go a
little over how about we go I'll go give
you five okay together that's sounds
good so we go ahead so we live on
Arlington Pond um Arlington Reservoir we
are in opposition of the will uh kind of
wanted to explain a few things my wife
and I moved to New Hampshire four years
ago we specifically researched lakes in
New Hampshire and the state itself to
decide for where we were going to move
and we bought our house on Arlington
Pond uh if we had seen this coming or it
was in place we would not be in New
Hampshire we would not be on this Lake
um so explain a little about Arlington
Pond it it is over 200 Acres of the Lake
it's a good siiz Pond but there is an
island in the middle of it if you take
500 ft on each side of the boat we have
eliminated wake Sports entirely on the
lake if there maybe there's a pin prick
of a spot but you sure can't drive a
boat around in a pin prick so you are
going to eliminate wak Sports entirely
on a lake that is one of the main
reasons we bought
here
um with that I would say at least 50 the
majority of the L lake has boats and
they do wake Sports of one sort or
another behind it you're going to
eliminate all that wake sporting on the
lake you're going to eliminate a lot of
people that are going to
move and you're going to eliminate a lot
of people that are willing to buy a
house on the lake so our Val property
values I would expect would be
significantly reduced with this um so it
this now leaves me with an expensive
lake house that I really can't use for
what I bought it for an expensive
wakeboarding boat that I really can't
use for what I bought it for other than
maybe the putt putts around the lake
it's it's kind of disappointing the bill
has no grandfather type clause and of
allowing us the people that have an
expensive lake house that bought up here
for this reason that bought a Bo boat
for this reason to continue to use it it
puts a limitation on as of July 1st
could you imagine putting a limitation
saying July 1st no motorcycles can drive
happen so going specifically to the bill
itself uh the Wake Sports definition
it's confusing it calls
out uh surfboard wakeboard hydrofoil and
then additionally it states or similar
devices to ride on or behind the
Wake what is that tubing water skiing
Barefoot skiing kneeboarding that's all
rides behind the wake uh so you are
eliminating anything to do with Towing
boat and then additionally it the limit
it says you can't do anything unless you
have a swim platform behind the
motor and I understand for wake surfing
that makes a lot of sense wake surfing
is probably 0 to 15 feet you're doing it
behind the boat so being away from the
motor very important for safety but
tubing water skiing wakeboarding all
that is 50 plus feet back of the boat I
we've been people have been doing that
for decades and decades without a safety
issue because you're not going to run
into the prop 50 fet back of the boat so
in that limitation now puts it
eliminates Tu being behind a pontoon
boat you know water skiing behind a
pontoon boat wakeboarding behind a
pontoon boat behind a fishing boat we
did a 13t fishing boat with a 25
horsepower motor when my son was small
he wakeboarded behind it you don't need
a big weight you don't need a big boat
for that
um let's see trying to think of all
these uh so one of the other ones people
ask how long a weight boards boats been
in
existence our boat is a
2004 20 years now it's been in existence
we use we use that boat that boat
nowhere near produces the wake that some
of the newer ones do if I'm towing
someone little kid I'm going to put no
ballast in that boat at all they more
than good at doing that uh and I can I
can raise my ballast up so you're
Banning you're Banning me with a 20
20-year boat that doesn't produce
anywhere near the size wake than the
newer boats what you should be doing if
you're going to do something with waves
ban the size of the wave is it you know
is it a is it a 4ft w wave that is it a
three-foot
wave just yep I'm going to pass the mic
so I just want to talk a little bit
about cyano bacteria because Arlington
Pond had a terrible year last year but
you know I'm on a committee that's
looking into that and the primary cause
is nutrients it's the phosphorus and the
nitrogen so control those you know look
at the primary cause our first blooms
were in May long before anybody started
any wak Sports and then the balloom
continued from the end of June through
October there were very few of any wakes
Sports going on during that time because
we had cyanobacteria in the lake if it
was only caused by the wakeboarding
boats it would have stopped we it
wouldn't have continued on for a 100
days so it bothers me that people are
blaming the ca blooms only on the
wakeboarding boats you really need to
look at the true source and control the
nutrients going into the lake not these
boats
specifically and and I just think in
general we need to look at enforcement
and hiring the proper number of Marine
Patrol to enforce the bills we currently
have don't put more bills on that there
have no way of enforcing anyway thank
much
I'll give that to the clerk thank you it
clerk
okay Rich
trer
operation something wake
sir good afternoon and thank you for
giving me the opportunity to address you
all my name is Rick tarder I am a
homeowner in Lichfield New Hampshire and
also in a cottage on lake winnisquam in
Tilton I am the Northeast representative
for operation wak surf a 501c nonprofit
organization our mission statement reads
our mission is to provide an
unforgettable and unique experience to
the First Responders and military
personnel who keep our communities and
countries
safe we do this by blending the healing
power of water camaraderie and
mentorship Via our compassionate coaches
by sharing our passion for wake surfing
and first with the First Responders and
military personnel both active and
retired we are now in our third year of
pulling heroes from New Hampshire and
around New England the impact H it has
had not only on the participants but
also on the coaches is truly amazing
over the last two years we have pulled
36 veterans First Responders and active
military over the course of the day
participants are taken out on volunteers
Centurion wak surf boats who is a major
sponsor of this organization we teach
everyone how to get up and eventually
surf behind our boats without the
Rope I can personally tell you when this
happens the excitement and happiness
that comes over our heroes faces is
truly
amazing allow me to share a couple of
stories with you from the events over
the last two years after a day on the
water with others who have shared the
same life experiences we gathered the
group together and asked them what the
day meant to them Chris an Army Ranger
who just rep returned from being
deployed overseas when asked when he was
asked what did you get out of the day he
replied with I am an Army Ranger
I am supposed to be tough and not let
things bother me over the course of the
last 3
years everything I do or see that I
always loved is now black and white to
me I am a ranger I am supposed to be
tough I have not seen color in three
years and today because of this event I
see color for the first
time Tom a firefighter from nashar who
after a day on the water stated while
sobbing I pulled a six-month-old baby
out of a burning house and could not
revive it while the baby's mother was
watching it tore him up he has never
told that story before and I can assure
you that after hearing these stories and
others who opened up there were 11
people standing around in tears all
because of a day on the w water wake
surfing the Salem Police Department and
the New Hampshire Army National Guard
who sent six officers and Four soldiers
this past to this past Year's Event
wants to send more this year as part of
their wellness program by creating a
500t rule and a depth requirement you
will be limiting lakes and rivers where
we can put on events like these and
eliminate the rights of others who live
on smaller Lakes I urge you all to vote
no on HB 1390 thank
you quite any questions from members of
the uh
committee he hearing
much Harry Bogel from the lon
preservation
committee
good afternoon chairman renzu and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Harry Bogel I'm the senior
biologist and executive director of the
lon preservation committee I thank you
for the opportunity to voice lpc's
support of House Bill 1390 to set more
appropriate and protective limits on
Wake Sports on New Hampshire Waters LPC
Works to restore and protect a healthy
loon population in New Hampshire through
through monitoring and research in
management and education with respect to
potential impacts to loons we emphasize
the following reasons that we support H
spill 1390 the first is that Lon nests
can be destroyed by wave action loons
are adapted to swimming and Diving and
not walking they move with difficulty on
land and therefore they always Nest
right at the water's edge waves from
boat weaks can watch over loon nests
causing them to fail in some cases
nesting is when loons are most
vulnerable and and despite our best
efforts over 40% of Lon nests fail in
New Hampshire intensive management of
Nest sites has been needed to continue
the hard one ongoing recovery of loons
which remain a threatened species in the
state we agree with a 500 foot or more
standard because it is supported by
reputable studies and I know that the
the national Marine manufacturers
Association study this is the fadal
study recommended a much lower standard
of 200 ft that deeply flawed study was
based on computer models that the
authors themselves stated are not
accurate at distances of more than three
boat lengths and of no value at more
than 100 ft from the boat their
unsubstantiated recommendation for a
200t standard is an outlier among other
wak Sports studies which recommend
minimum protective zones of up to 1,000
ft or more wakes sport studies that use
actual field measurements cite wave
heights and wave energy that are
significantly greater than other forms
of boating so for example water
environmental Consultants found that
wake surfing produced a greater than 7
in high wave even at 500 ft distance and
a 499 per increase in wave energy
compared to a cruising boat a wave of
this height and power would still swamp
many loon nests in New Hampshire which
are typically less than 6 in above the
water line so even a 500t protective
Zone will not protect all loon nests but
we recognize that we are trying to
balance our desire to recreate with our
loon need to procreate and 500 ft is
certainly better than other standards
that have been proposed we're also
concerned about shoreline erosion and
water quality loons are visual hunters
and they need clean clear water to catch
fish the potential for wake surfing to
increase shoreline erosion and turbidity
of our legs me to reduced ability of
lons and other Aquatic animals to find
Nest sites and food uh in testimony
today and also for an earlier bill I
heard lobbyists say that L are doing
fine in New Hampshire and the real
problem for L is lead fishing tackle and
I agree that lead tackle continues to
kill loons in New Hampshire but I do
want to set the record straight on a
couple of points we experienced no
growth in Lon Paris last year over the
year previously and we had a record
number of Nest failures including a
record number of failures from flooded
nests loons are facing many threats not
just one and wake sports are imp imp
acting the recovery of this threatened
and much-loved species so we support
efforts to provide these needed
protections for lakes and loons and we
support the standards proposed in House
Bill 1390 as a bare minimum to help
protect the wildlife and the lakes that
we value so highly in New Hampshire
thank you for considering lons and other
wildlife in your contemplation of House
Bill 1390 that is the end of my
testimony and I would be happy to answer
any questions any questions by members
of the committee yes Mr chair I I have
one for a question thank you and thank
you Mr vogle for your testimony um
several people that have testified
earlier are saying that the Senate Bill
431 would be an adequate bill for to
protect the Shor line um has the Loon
preservation committee taken a position
on that bill and if so what is it yes
thank you for the question um we have we
are absolutely in opposition to a 200
foot Bill we don't think that that is
nearly enough and in fact even a 500t
compromise Mr chair for a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question can you describe um why goons
nests would not be impacted by wind
driven waves and uh impacted by um the
waves of boats yes uh thank you it's a
very good question so um loons have been
tuned through evolution they're about a
20 million year old species um and so
loons know instinctively to nest on the
leeward side of islands and Shor lines
that are protected by by the prevailing
wind and waves that doesn't mean that we
can't on occasion have a nor Easter you
know come through and and wash out some
some loons um but they they are
definitely tuned in uh to the prevailing
wind and wave action by the time they're
nesting they've been on that Lake for a
month they know where the waves are and
where they'll they'll receive protection
from the waves unfortunately evolution
sports for for a
question thank you um as a person that
lives on a lake and has Lon Nest thank
you very much Canby Lake uh question is
how many times do people put out the
buoys to say to protect the Loon nest
and how many of those do you actually
put out across your Lakes cuz I know I
have have those buoys underneath a set
of steps at my house right now each time
loons lay eggs sure thank you for the
question so if you're referring to our L
nesting area signs so um we put those
signs out in on quite a number of lakes
in fact more than one out of every two
chicks that are hatched in New Hampshire
come from a nesting site that's
protected by those uh signs and rope
lines so um we work with Lake owners you
know to decide whether or not to put out
those signs some people think they just
bring more attention to lons other
people are absolutely wanting to have
those those signs and rope lines so if
we feel that they're Justified and if we
can find uh that Lake users and and Lake
residents are are in support of that
then we'll absolutely put those signs
up for a follow up thank
you um the follow question is what's
your recommended distance when those
signs are out that you give voters and
residents on the lake yeah uh thank you
it's that's another good question so we
typically go by the loons themselves um
and and so as we approach a loon that's
sitting on a nest we look for any signs
that that loon is is beginning to react
to our presence often that's just like
craning the head low across the lake at
that point we know that we're within
that that distance that's impacting that
loon we're we're invading their personal
space will typically back up another 10
or 20 feet from that and drop the sign
right there so our idea in doing this
always is that recognizing that Lakes
are a public resource we don't want to
deny people the use of that public
resource for any more water or any
longer period of time that is necessary
successfully thank you very much thank
you hearing no other
much Shane uh Shane
Corey
in opposition three
minutes thank you very much Mr chairman
committee for listening to me my name is
Shane Cary and I oppose House Bill 1390
I live in boat on pakway lake with my
wife and two kids who enjoy recreational
water sports I had the pleasure of
serving on House Bill
137 um which we did a study on Wake
boats and I believe that we need to
continue on the education on wakes
Sports not a
band um there's many stories out there
education is our number one thing that
we need to do these setbacks that we're
proposing with this bill will confuse
voters cause safety concerns this bill
will tax Marine Patrol officers which
are already short staffed this house
bill 1390 will make it hotter for Marine
Patrol to enforce the current laws that
are already in place and believe me
education is what is needed if you look
out there in the Boating
industry this bill would be bad for
tourism industry as well this bill will
cause vacationist to seek other Estates
to boat in which would affect small
businesses small business depended on
the summer tourism and this bill will
turn tourists away from this great
state this could result in an annual
loss of $1.4 billion from recreational
boers please do not pass this bill it's
too extreme for this great state and
will affect more than just water sports
time thank you very much for quick
presentation is there any questions by
members of the Committee hearing none
thank you very
McDonald
you
my name is David MacDonald I'm the
Harbor Master or I was the Harbor Master
at the Oakledge homeowners association
on fisers Bay on Lake snipe from 2007 to
2022 I retired this year I think I aged
out um I'd like to talk about some real
differences that I've seen in the
maintenance of our property there having
been there for a long time
at Oakledge we have 30 Mings and we have
two fixed docks one of the fixed docks
has five connecting floating docks
connected by Steel uh uh fabricated
connectors uh we have impacts that we
see on the connectors we have impacts
that we see on the chains and we have
impacts that we see on the moing balls
first of all the chains
um the last several years we have been
replacing more and more chain for
example in
2018 to
2020 3 years we averaged around 39 ft of
replaced
chain
2021 and
2022 we averaged over 100 fet of
replaced chains now what happens in
fiser Bay is it's about 2,000 ft wide
but we get this going on around and
around and around and we're getting more
and more uh wake boats I've got five
okay of my 32 I've got five so I
understand that but those people aren't
the problem they've been
told now in addition to the problems we
got with the chains I have the moing
ball
uh in the last 4 years we've had to
replace 18 moing balls that's half of
what we got that's despite going from
half inch steel to 5/8 in
steel that's a problem and now there are
the dot connectors we have eight dock
connectors connecting the five
docks last year year or in
2022 we had to replace three of those
connectors each connector is fabricated
it cost
$600 that's really expensive and to go
through three in one year is
crazy normally it's one or
zero now what have we tried to do to
mitigate this we've gone to bigger
Hardware already now we're going to
stainless steel stainless steel chains
three times as much and stainless steel
going through the moing ball is another
50 bucks so it's it's it's getting
really expensive for us to maintain our
moing field and our docks in addition of
course we see the boats rocking against
the moing balls when these waves come
through and this isn't the the speed
boats with the uh water skiers this is
the wave boats and as preponderantly the
ones that just keep circling
around uh so we definitely are in in uh
favor of 1390 we think it's a good bill
it will definitely help something has
got to be done to mitigate the damage
not only to the Shoreline which a lot of
other people have been talking about to
the damage of our property so thank you
for
speaker see none thank you for your your
testimony next up against the bill
lysing Jody I couldn't hear you they're
out of the room but they're coming back
is that what you
said okay so we'll go to another one
Gerson we're making a lot of money on
the
machines pay for our salary here um
Brett
Nigro yeah I don't need it thank you
though uh good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen thank you for hearing my
testimony today uh my name is Brett
Nigro from Windam New Hampshire I reside
on kobitz Pond um disappointed to say my
daughters had to leave them just a few
moments ago they were excited to be a
part of this Democratic process and um
had to leave for for practice so um that
disappoints me as well cuz I wanted them
to see this uh through to the end um the
other reason I wanted them here is is
one of the core parenting principles
that my wife and I instill in these two
is to stand up for what they believe in
and to fight an injustice if they
believe there is one in a courteous
respectful and most importantly factual
manner we as a family and my friend
group that have joined me here today
strongly oppose this bill we feel that
it is a uh tremendous
overreach um for a perceived problem
that as many times you may have heard
that our studies on this side of the
bill don't support uh there's equal
equally as many holes that can be shot
into their proposed science the reality
is uh studies are bought and paid for by
someone and data can be manipulated to
produce whatever outcomes that the
agenda of the payer has in front of them
let's look at our friends at Google that
just manipulated the the skin tone of
people because that's the way that their
politics work so uh it's a little
frustrating to be a property owner um
I've been on my Lake Association for 12
years I'm one term removed from our Lake
presidency um intally knowledge of the
the the struggle between uh the uninform
Wake boo opposition and those of us that
perform wake boating um I could rebut
90% of the things that were said here
today but we have a time limit so I'm
going to focus my my testimony on the
education versus legislation component
put together just a a quick color slide
for you guys because I think uh you're
probably mostly non-voters thank you
voters rather and a quick picture could
demonstrate uh to you a lot easier than
a bunch of words um what's in being
circulated uh I'll wait for it to get
around the precursor to that is there is
a lack of Education this is a relatively
new activity uh one that's very
meaningful as you heard the passionate
testimony of a lot of folks on this Lake
I mean on this topic um and with that
education is in order and with some best
practices and some pragmatic and
reasonable approaches to that education
we can solve Andor mitigate the majority
of the concerns by the opposition if we
can get that passed around I can Hur
this up
um you know the the reality is the the
the Wake booat study that compared the
ski booat to the wake booat is
inconclusive it was one pass in each
Direction and two totally inop
incomparable boats throw a big V Hole uh
boat on there and you'll see much
different uh comparable waves and you
know just it goes back to my study
comparison so I'm not uh Choosing My
Words great at the moment but let's
let's get on to the slide what you have
in front of you is just an aerial view
of a wake booat uh that's producing a
wave so at the very bottom you'll see
the tail end of the of the boat itself
at the very top caned is a rider that is
surfing the wave and what I wanted to
point out to you folks that this is one
of many best traes that can help
mitigate Andor eliminate the the wave
energy being directed towards the shore
the way these boats are operated there
is a mechanical mechanism that yaws the
boat to the side uh unlike what everyone
is testifying here it doesn't tip it way
up and bring the propeller closer to the
bottom it yws it to the side it uses the
device to create the wave which
basically steals the energy from one
side of the boat and directs it onto the
other side and creates the wave to ride
on what you see on the left side is the
wash side of the boat okay and the wash
side is mostly air bubbles as a result
of the energy being stolen from one side
and put on the other side okay the best
way I can describe it in layman's terms
is you go to the beach the wave that's
coming off the ocean is much stronger
when it's a wall of water but by the
time it crashes and all the wave energy
is dissipated and the air comes up and
it tickles your toes there's nothing to
it so as a responsible wake booat
Operator by having my girls were here
cuz we had a demonstration plan for you
but if there riding on the on the left
side of the wave and therefore the wash
side is on the right side of the wave if
you put the shoreline on the right side
as you're going up the wave energy is
pushed towards the center of the of of
the lake same thing's true coming back a
responsible owner recognizes that you
just simply reverse the process and move
the energy towards the center of the
lake that's one of probably 10 different
best practices including that power
turning to pick up your Riders which
means slowing down and coming around in
the fair and reasonable manner so with a
little education and a little bit of
cooperation and I heard one of the
representatives there and I appreciated
the tone of cooperation and and
compromise we can come to something that
makes sense and I think the the Senate
Bill 431 bill is a great step in that
direction and if we double down on
education which includes and I put the
link on the bottom of my slide please
take a look at the current New Hampshire
boers guide there is not one mention of
any sort of best practices as it relates
to wake Sports they've been around for
close to 20 years why is that if it's
such a problem why has it never been
addressed let's address the problem at
the source as people are getting their
license and there's other mechanisms for
which to get the information out there
so what I'm imploring imploring that you
folks do is recognize that this is the
nuclear option that's going to a
prohibit me on cage Pond from using my
very expensive boat and depreciate my my
value but it's not just about me it's
about other families across the the area
they're going to be greatly impacted by
this and it may seem trivial or nominal
to some because it's a small percentage
of the boting population
but but B activity is a mentality that
you know is family oriented by its
nature these are valuable times raising
kids in difficult times and I can get
them captive on a boat for two hours
without a scream and and and do the same
thing when I'm skiing to New Hampshire
Staples that gives me the ability to be
a good father and please don't take that
away from us there's many many many of
us that are out there doing the right
thing and a couple bad people that
created a wave so Dave bundell got
knocked off his chair
we don't need to do legislation let's
start with a reasonable bill with
reasonable educational methods and let's
let's see where it goes you can always
go up we're never going to be able to go
down please vote no on this Bill thank
you any questions for the speaker uh yes
I do Mr chair go ahead go ahead thank
you and thank you for your testimony um
you mentioned that there are some
studies that were bought and paid for
and we've got dozens to go through can
you li list any or specific ones that
sure the Minnesota study that the the
gentleman uh referenced earlier where
there was a competition Skibo going in
One Direction and a wake booat come in
the other and it was you know a
percentage differential in terms of wave
uh wave strength U that bill that that
study had boats going two passes one
this way one that way very quick
measurements it wasn't a very wellth
thought out study and it didn't use a
variety of different boat types it used
a competition ski boat was a flat hle
that skims across the water designed
specifically to make no wave at all so
that the skiers can ski back
effortlessly at very high speeds it's a
very different mechanism than anything
else including your little cabin Cy or
any sort of vhole boat that may be uh
traversing our our waterways so the
study on its face it's like I'm picking
the extreme to to validate my my
position on the Other Extreme it's it's
just not a good study it it it shouldn't
impact your your position on this bill
what should is how this affects New
Hampshire families and you could tell by
how enraged I am at the moment this imp
impacts my family greatly okay so just
that one steady let's talk about them
all if you want we can run through them
one by one there's not enough
information to Warrant an outright ban
on I don't know what the number is 25%
in New Hampshire Lakes on my Lake it's
going to put it in a 177% section in the
center we have approximately 20 W wake
boats on our on our Lake several of them
are here today because they care enough
to be here we're responsible fathers I'm
53 years old I have two kids I've
probably taught 30 to 50 kids how to
wake surf We Gather as a community it is
a community sport yeah are there are
people that are bad drivers sure I saw
probably three of them coming up here on
so don't punish the masses by the the
the poor actions of ref few and the
easily offended what I'm suggesting is
because of the newness of what's going
on here the newness of the sport and the
newness of the need for regulation for
which I support I'm not going to want to
create erosion on my Lake I've sat on
that board for 12 years the bigger
problem is is development and is rain
rainwater runoff that brings s sediment
into our Lakes our Lakes water quality
is is a disaster right now because of
the blasting associated with the moving
of 93 closer to our Lake and all the
storm water runoff that brings Brine and
salt that's what's the real problem in
our Lake if you want to do something
with 500 ft why don't we ban fertilizer
use on our lawns in 500 ft our water
quality guy was just here he' support
that even though he's firmly against you
know in support of this bill there are
better ways to spend your time and ours
for the betterment of our Lakes than to
press the nuclear button this is very
very concerning to me as a culture on a
national level the first
reaction is to label restrict in an
effort to ban you see it on regular
media social media written print it's
it's always the extreme and I'm
suggesting as New Hampshire residents
that we're different we don't need to go
to extremes we have to have trust in our
residents to come up with a plan that
makes sense and a plan that is something
that we can all adopt and if everyone
feels a little pain and we come to a
compromise well I'll be in a better
place but I promise you if this bill
goes through the pain is lopsided it's
unjust and there will be huge rep you
know repercussions my property value
will plummet immensely there's two lakes
in my town one doesn't allow motorboats
the other one does there's a 30 to 40%
pricing differential between between the
two lakes in the same town same school
system same awesome amenities that
Windom offers the price differential is
immense why is that because families
gravitate on their boats and this is how
we raise good respectful confident young
adults that's going to lead this country
going
forward we lose this I lose them to
screens I lose them to all the outside
influences we need this we can be
responsible we want the protection of
our Lakes as well this talk about the
Wake boats causing the sett issues
that's just not accurate you can't
produce a reasonable size Surf Wave in
shallow water you can't you're
displacing water the only way to do it
is in the deep water I'm sorry the New
Hampshire Lakes lady went on forever so
I'm going to take my time if you don't
mind ma' well I actually was just going
to ask you if you could wrap up your
answer cuz it looks like you're taking
another 10 minut to make but I need to
refute this point the sediment caused by
wake boats because they are occasional
use and they're and they're operated by
reasonable older adults that take take
Direction fairly well aside from the
time limit um that you'd have to make
waves in deep water or it doesn't work
so this this concept of us going in
shallow water is ridiculous it doesn't
work the science isn't there you want to
talk about science you have to be in the
deep water so just please hear my words
this is a a bigger issue than it may
appear on its face you're impacting
families across the state and I implore
you to vote no and embrace education and
embrace that other bill with a 200 foot
setback and let's see what that takes us
and they can come back in another two
years and we can have this discussion
you in support of the bill Valerie
starbu
Valerie oh
and and and by the way the next person
up will be
Alexa and Amy lysing so be
ready they left they had left the room
and did they come back yet Jody
Alexa they're here
okay okay you can hear me okay thank you
first of all
committee Reps for your service to New
Hampshire it's a big job and I thank you
I'm here today to speak in favor of HB
1390 and I'm going to attest to and
speak to things that I have personally
observed living on the lake for Summers
for my 74 years and the last 27 years
full-time on the lake and this is Lake
spafford I have personally seen the
damage that wake surfing has had on
spafford Lake's natural habitat from the
huge wave it produces sit on my front
porch and watch it happen as Lake
spafford loon monitor I have seen
firsthand and waves from the wakeboard
boat sweep up and over the lon nests
containing eggs shocking The Loon
sitting in the nest and throwing her off
um I am the one at the lake who I'm loon
Monitor and I put out the buoys I
therefore increased when I saw this and
noticed it because it was on the island
and the boats um think that because
there is no building on the island and
very not that much use that they can
come closer to the island and I moved
the buoys out farther to about 100 ft to
know problems for the rest of the people
on the lake I have seen firsthand waves
from these boats Pummel the shoreline
and eat away at the soil around
vegetation and Roots I have seen
firsthand kayakers going fairly close to
shore within a 100 feet um that were
placed in Jeopardy uh because these
boats have come too close uh I have
witnessed outbreaks of CYO bacteria for
several years which may be may be
attributed in some part to deep wave
action loosening the masses on the
bottom of the lake I know it's not the
root cause but I think it contributes to
the uh PL the masses coming to the
surface and then floating into
Shore the the bill is very important and
I would it would not prohibit the sport
on many of our larger Lakes including
Lake spafford we have plenty of acreage
almost 900 acres and there's plenty of
lake that could support wake surfing
sports but there um it may prohibit the
sport on some smaller Lakes but those
Lakes can be in serious Peril if we
continue to ignore the facts and the
science behind the damaged oversized
that oversized waves can
cause as I said I have summered on
spford Lake my whole life and the last
27 years full-time to my
dismay I have seen our
Waters become increasingly unhealthy due
to overuse overbuilding and under caring
I'm sad to say that we are not alone I
don't know of any New Hampshire lake
that is healthier today than 25 years
ago and if there is one I love to know
what it is why we have taken several
measures to protect our Lakes like the
Shoreland protection act thanks to the
legislative body for approving that but
as new threats appear we need to address
these as
well understandably we may be timid
about taking necessary actions to
protect our New Hampshire Lakes because
it can upset and does upset some people
who may be adversely impacted however
don't we we have an obligation we
collectively have an obligation to make
those hard decisions if it's the right
decision you not only represent people
but you represent the habitats that do
not have a
voice those of us who use our Lakes
today are here but for a very short time
we all need to think first of the
lakes's long-term health and rather than
our own personal interest we should all
be stewards of our beautiful lakes and
work to fix issues quickly and
definitively please move this bill
forward as one action to bring help
bring our Lakes back to Good Health
before it's too late our next
Generations are counting on us and as a
side note I live right on the shoreline
with very large windows I have never
ever seen 4ot natural waves on Lake
spford for the last in the Summers seven
74 years well let's just say 60 years
starting when I was 14 I have never uh I
haven't even seen 3 foot natural waves
with huge white caps but never three to
four feet We Can't Stop natural erosion
from these waves and weather but we can
minimize
man-made
damage
questions any questions the members of
the committee
lensing and
also uh Michael Jess jessus uh from
stiede you'll be up afterward right
afterwards so be
prepare hi thank you so much for
listening and giving us all the
opportunity to speak my name is Alexia
montoo and I'm up here to oppose this
bill um for many years I wasn't
particularly interested in water sports
I never really enjoyed it I had tried
water skiing I tried kneeboarding but
none of it I really liked none of it
really clicked for me until I did wake
surfing
um uh I always felt like it's easier to
communicate with the driver um since
you're not as far away from the boat
like that makes it easier um there's
like a way uh lower risk of in of injury
because when you fall it's very tame and
I also feel like it's just a very tame
sport overall for any age and anybody
coming from any athletic background um
so I feel like I've also never heard
anyone complain about um our behavior on
our River we're from Bellamy River in
Dober New Hampshire um about my mom or
my stepdad um and how they drive we
always stay away from the shore so my
family my friends and myself will be
deeply disappointed if this passes so
thank
you we also wanted to talk about the
fact that we really care about the
environment the past two years we have
been working with the living Shor line
on Great Bay we actually applied for the
grant to help with the shoreline erosion
on our property we have spent thousands
of dollars on Plants um to prevent the
erosion and as a boat owner um we
realize it's not from the boat and would
not have the boat and be spending the
money in our yard if it was caused by
the boat that would be
counterproductive so
[Music]
we after applying for the um Grant we've
been working with Dees and
was I'm going to read this so this was
from the Great Bay living Shoreline
project site
profile erosion at the site is likely
driven by
inundation and Ice scoring boat wake
pressure is unlikely to be causing the
erosion and the bank is not shaded an
existing seaw wall is damaged mod lawn
spots the salt marsh on the landward
edge abundant native micro algae on the
seaward Edge contributes to suitable
conditions for a living Shoreline but
unfortunately because of the cost of
fixing the shoreline we are just going
to continue planting different plants
but as boers
were very cautious and we care about
other people's properties and this bill
will really affect us and nobody today
well are there any questions by members
of the
Committee hearing or seeing none thank
you very much thank
jenus and you'll be followed by Dylan
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is Mike
Janis from sunap and I I will try to be
very brief and given the amount of of
time you've been here but also the fact
that many of the issues that I was
prepared to speak to have been spoken to
by others but I do want to to raise a
few issues so so first I I am a kayaker
who believe it's increasingly unsafe the
kayak on Lake sopy during the middle of
most days it's not even weekend days
it's weekday and this has been an
increase over the last uh several years
uh I understand the passion uh with
which wake Sports enthusiasts come to I
was particularly uh moved by the
discussion earlier about how we help our
veterans and other people through wake
Sports I think it's I think wake
sporting undoubtedly is a great activity
I don't do it but I have witnessed the
the safety issues I've experienced the
safety issues I've witnessed the
shorland erosion issues and with the
rights that we all have to use the lake
come
responsibilities the the
industries um suggested guidelines come
nowhere close to meeting the
responsibilities to Public Safety and to
the natural environment but you've heard
a lot about that I want to touch on a
couple things that uh were were briefly
touched on by by the speaker from Lake
spford uh but they actually have a
couple of other elements so first of all
she brought up the Shoreland protection
act
uh which was passed 15 17 years ago
something in that time frame I don't
know how many of you would have been uh
in the legislature at the time I'm sure
you heard from a lot of passionate land
owners how dare you tell me what I can
do to develop my property and yet the
legislature recognized the balance
between private rights and public
obligations and impose what I believe
living on a lake and having experienced
the shorel protection Act is a very
reasonable set of conditions to put on
the the owners of property restricting
their rights for the common good and I
think that's been a good act we could do
more with it the second point I would
make though and and this is not covered
um directly in the well it is covered in
the testimon I'm sorry is the other
aspect of the Shoreland protection act
is that unfortunately Dees doesn't have
a lot of resource to to uh enforce it
they enforce it by issuing permits and
they do lots of research about granting
you a permit but they don't do much
follow-up work afterward enforcement is
self enforcement much as it is on our
Lakes when we don't have Marine Patrol
and yet enforcement takes place because
people do obey the laws and obey the
permits they're given and if you change
this law as as we're recommending it
will be uh um uh followed by most wakes
sport uh enthusiasts who want to follow
the law this is not going to be a burden
on Marine Patrol they don't have the
resources to to um um uh follow up
anyway I'll make one last point and then
the question that representative Darby
has asked on a number of people about
four foot waves I'm sure we've had some
waves like that during very big storms
you know I don't want to say we haven't
when I first moved to to Lake sunap 15
years ago though we wanted to build a
permanent dock at our property but
you're not allowed to build a permanent
dock anymore on the Lakes unless you're
able to show um wave evidence through an
EST installation of a wave pole with
cameras that show you have sustained
high wave activity over 4H hour periods
multiple times a year we put in the wave
pole we put in the camera we could not
prove the wave activity at my location
if I put a wave pole out there today it
would easily match the stand meet the
standard of Dees the wave activity is
that high and that constant thank you
very much for for your work on this very
important effort I'd be happy to take
any
questions any questions by members of
the committee yes Mr
chair more question thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question you
mentioned I think briefly that you felt
unsafe kayaking on on Lake santap which
is a pretty large lake with lots of Coes
can you um give me add some color
provide an example of how you felt
unsafe well it you I stay relatively
close to shore I don't get out into the
middle of the lake because that that
would be crazy even you know before the
the the increase in Wake booat activity
uh but but you don't see these waves
coming and they are powerful and they
are high and they knock me for a loop
you know and it's it's unlike I I I
agree with the comment made by Tu about
tubers I hate tubers I'm not a problem I
don't have a problem with jet skiers out
there while I'm kayaking tubers cause
lots of of problems too but most other
boating activity does not cause the the
problems that that you know when it's
coming from a wake boat you look then up
and you see the boat at a distance it's
long path the wave knocks you and and I
have been almost knocked in the lake on
multiple occasions
any other
questions see none thank you Mr chairman
thank you very
much Dylan Carr followed by Steve
Windgate so Mr Windgate be PR
prepared how's it going my name is Dylan
Carr I live in Alton Bay New Hampshire
and uh I own a
surfboat um I bought a Surf Boat about a
year ago I'm 27 years old I'm I'm a very
responsible Surfer and I think that a
lot of the issues um spur from lack of
Education um I work in the Marine
industry and we see many different
things with surfboats uh really a lot of
negligence but uh education is key in
this case but there's two points that I
really wanted to bring up um the first
being CYO bacteria
and if you look at the cdc's website it
says that the number two leading causes
are fertilizer and in septic
systems I don't understand how surfboats
can
be you know I just don't understand how
surf boats are even associated with that
and sorry I'm a little nervous
here uh the second one is shoreline
erosion so I have a side business where
I fly drones and one of the very first
properties that I surveyed back in 2019
is on Lake wiip pasak um more
specifically in Tuftonboro it's a high
traffic area um and I've monitored this
home for the last five years over the
last five years there have been no
notice noticeable signs of erosion and I
know this because I create what we call
a Ortho which is a 2d map and we're able
to reference the height of the lake and
landmarks to determine exactly where the
shoreline is and in this specific
scenario which is a hot spot for travel
and wake surfing there have been no
signs of
is there any questions by members of the
uh
committee seeing none thank you very
much
uh
y okay they're up good
wow it's been a long
day telling me thank you very much for
testimony um I'm from uh
Tuftonboro Winter Harbor Lake
winaki I go back to uh 1948
y my grandfather originally purchased
900 Acres uh sorry 9900 ft of shorefront
and our uh family has developed maybe
200 feet so we have 700 feet
of what should be natural Shoreline but
it's uh suffers from erosion uh
shoreline erosion and I I think uh the
variable has been ever
increasing uh W boat wakes and ever
increasing boat size and boat
power in those early days uh my brothers
and sisters and I would be out playing
and if we'd hear a boat we'd run out to
the shore to see who it was and we
usually know because it there weren't
there many boats power boats at that
time and so things have changed a lot
time in 2021 a period of a group of uh
volunteers under the supervision of uh
New Hampshire Lakes uh monitoring
program conducted a study of effects of
boat wakes on water quality samples were
taken when boat activity was both low
and high the study concluded that 43%
increase in turbidity that's cloudiness
that you see in the water uh increased
on days of uh heavy boat activity and uh
30% increase of phosphorus on high
boating activity days and when we looked
at the information in detail we actually
saw a lot of
resilience in turbidity and phosphorus
on moderate boat days Boat Boat use days
it seemed to be on heavy days with a lot
increases wake boarding closer to shore
like 2 250 ft and on my proerty property
is
dramatic uh waves break over the
shoreline violently wash organic matter
and mineral soil into this
Lake um my dock is flooded and my boat
crashes against it my sailboat on a
mooring rocks violently and I've had to
repair the rigging several
times we can't go back in time but we
can find solutions for the future with
different Lake interests are in Conflict
we should be able to find a way get
along we have the responsibility to seek
compromise which maximizes the benefits
for all in this case 500 ft makes all
the
difference there's an old
saying a place for everything and
everything in its place it's a place
for uh wake Sports is 500 ft
out there's still plenty of room out
there on the appropriate size lakes and
ponds for that activity and it'll
protect the
shoreline
I I'd like to point out that uh my long
76 years of experience on Winter
Harbor uh I have been through hurricanes
uh and several tropical storms and I
watched the
waves and on Winter Harbor which is the
size of a moderate sized Lake narrow
opening out into the greater part of
winaki the waves are maybe 6 Ines to a
foot high doesn't compare with big Boke
wakes and it doesn't even come close to
uh wakeboard L wakes I've also seen a
lot of responsible wake boarders out
there they tend to stay out in the
middle of the area they also pay
attention the ones that have the
diverters on their boats they pay
attention to which way they're going and
then there's a lot that don't thank you
for your
time thank you very much is there any
questions by members of the committee
hearing none thank you very
F I think it's I think it's f e r
y
conquered okay he would have been
opposed to the bill all right
uh Mark Murphy this is in support of the
bill
uh Mark Murphy in supported okay and
also Bill Bartley be you're on you're on
after M Mr
Murphy hi uh my name is Mark Murphy I'm
a Plymouth New Hampshire resident um I
also own Waterfront I'm Lake wiip
um little history on me I learned to
wakeboard over 30 years ago
uh so far back in fact that it was
referred to as scarfing a name that's
disappeared into history I have no
opposition to the sport itself um I was
in the chamber earlier this morning to
oppose the restrictions on personal
watercraft uh I lean towards the
libertarian to be honest with you right
now I'm here to support this bill the
difference between the PWC Bill and this
one to me is simply put one person's
freedom to recreate in the way they wish
should only be limited when it infringes
on another person's rights in this case
these boats specifically designed to
throw large wakes do in fact or can at
least infringe on Waterfront owners
rights to protect their property
especially if you're in a Leeward area
where wind driven W uh waves may not be
so much of a problem these boats can
create that problem those shorelines are
less Rocky more soil and have the
ability to be eroded easier these boats
if they oper operate in those areas can
cause damage there no other type of boat
is designed in such a way to maximize
its wake and thereby maximize its damage
to the Shor line and that's what makes a
wake boat different than other boats so
if we talk about why we should look at
one segment of the Boating population
these are boats literally designed to
maximize their wake and the resulting
damage to the Shoreline I believe is
real so much of my Shoreline is Leeward
not affected by Major winds the
prevailing Northwest winds
so I don't see as much damage from wind
on those parts of the shoreline I can
see that damage from these boats and I
don't feel that my rights as a property
owner should be put in Jeopardy because
other people wish to recreate close to
my Shoreline with a boat designed to
maximize their wake I would also note
that I don't have another remedy at law
to prevent this tor of damage I can't
sue the individual Boat Owners or
anything not that I would but the point
is there's no other way for me to to
prevent this sort of damage to my
property this erosion uh historically
this chamber's job has always been to
protect the rights and freedoms of the
residents of the state I would ask the
committee in this case to consider the
landowner rights and thus support the
bill that restricts but does not ban the
use of wake Boats open it to
questions any questions by members of
the
Committee hearing and seeing none thank
you very
and followed
by oh man
near anyway okay you're up after after
him Mr Speaker members thank you not I
will be brief
sorry I will be brief 2 minutes 4
seconds go hope you get brownie points
for the opposition for that your time is
running I'm lucky enough to own
waterfront property on Barn in uh on
Half Moon Lake in
Barnstead wake surf boats do not
directly cause erosion any
evidence is anecdotal all boats and Jet
Skis can cause wave
generation there are no scientific
studies specifically focused on wake
surf boats causing
erosion most of the waves or wakes on
these Lakes is caused by wind typically
late morning to midday the wind is
generated by the different temperatures
of air in land the larger Lakes will
have bigger waves because more energy is
generated over the larger
surface boating will increase the waves
and wake typically the tubers and jet
skis enjoy this surfing and skiing does
not like wake it's no fun being out
there in a wake surf boat or a ski booat
in the middle of the day nobody is those
boats are all on the docks
waiting it out because in the middle of
the day between the wind and the boat
activity there's just way too much wake
we're not out
there ice wind and fluctuating water
water levels cause the most erosion on
these Lakes you have natural Shor lines
and you have engineered Shor lines
engineered Shor lines will see the most
damage for obvious reasons I have 75 ft
of natural Shoreline a Sandy Beach the
ice in the winter does the most damage
some some years our beach is small some
years it's big it changes we love our
beach as a waterfront property owner I
have a huge investment in the health of
our Lake as a family we enjoy fishing
tubing skiing surfing sailing and
swimming on our Lake we have over 20
years and into our second generation we
cherish our time together on this Lake
picking on one group of people who are
using using our Lakes for recreation
doesn't sound like the New Hampshire
that I know and love to the people who
want to regulate wake
surfing the Lakes belong to everyone we
all need to share it we all need to care
for it let's be good neighbors and share
these legs thank you very much for your
time any questions by members of the
Committee hearing and seeing
n thank you very much now we're down to
the fantastic
five Mr Jay
okay thank you and you'll be followed by
Mark Cullen so be prepared thank you
very much to one and all for allowing me
this opportunity to speak one big
difference in my presentation that I've
noticed throughout the day listening to
everybody closely and watching Everybody
closely and that is all the observations
up to this point have been from the
water surface up all my testimony and uh
information that I can share is gathered
from my own two eyes from the surface of
the water down I'm a commercial diver um
and I guess I can just I've cut this
down quite a bit for everybody
say I'm here to speak about the pristine
clear sparkling fresh waters of New
Hampshire Lakes but unfortunately I'm
not entirely in a position to do that
rather I'm here to dispel you of that
sparkly myth and to inform you that our
Lakes are closer to an emergency 911
call I also hold faith that after you
hear my observations as to the condition
of New Hampshire Lake qu water quality
you'll cast your vote to strengthen our
state legislature and help us do our
part in preserving Lakes we all love my
name is Jay whitehair I live in norwi
Vermont I support House Bill
1390 and I wakeboarded full confession
many times and I very much enjoy it I'm
not a scientist however I do have
qualified underwater experience that I
want to share here and I'm committed to
preserving the pristine Waters of New
Hampshire I grew up in New Hampshire and
spent much of my life exploring enjoying
and working on its Waters it's not
uncommon for me at this point to spend
up to 6 hours a day under the shallow
water waves harvesting invasive aquatic
weeds I'm currently a public safety
service diver with the town of Hanover
New Hampshire and I operate expedited
dive Services LLC a short notification
emergency dive
program I've retrieved Hazmat materials
for the state of Vermont Dove to observe
recover petroglyphs for the Aban action
and Bellow Falls I retrieve boats that
have sunk vehicles that have slipped
through the ice cars off of boat ramps I
SCU a metal detect underwater evidence
searches I do evidence searches and with
the retrieval of submerged and once in a
while work on the retrieval of submerged
human
bodies I remove Waterfront swim hazards
by gathering drug use Sharp Fish Hooks
Fish lines and various entanglement
hazards I've been referred to as simply
a janitor of the
deep it's not flattering but honorable I
guess I spend a lot of time underwater
observing from my underwater experiences
I can tell you this New Hampshire lake
crisis okay what's out of sight below
ignored I regularly observe these big
wave wakes Dow drafted propeller
thrusting which create massive bottom
scrubbing turbulence along Our Lake
shorelines this turbulence disturbs and
redistributes nutrients algae and
vintage pollutants off the lake bottom
and hangs as as suspended particles in
the water column it's a wellknown fact
that these suspended particles gather
warmth from the Sun and in turn heat the
water itself thereby encouraging more
biomass growth such as I'm shaking so
much cyanobacterial growth blooms and
invasive plants the effect they
magnify the effect can magnify itself to
the extent that the sunlight is blocked
completely Darkness prevails and the
environment becomes unsustainable for
healthy plant and wildlife habitat I'm
already
done did you wrap up if you want to wrap
up go right just do do it in in
short the sediment created from down
turbulence thrust ing in Shallow Waters
brings up particles I see it all the
time when I'm diving all the time I'm
working on the shores 15 ft and less up
to the Shoreline I get knocked over by
big waves I'm a sailor I was apprenticed
in Bo in Booth Bay Main in 19 882 I've
been through the full gamut of boating
and boat building I understand these
boats they're causing a lot of damage to
our lakes and it's up to the
responsibility of this group here please
to understand understand that and to not
so much cater to the financial gains of
a lot of these big companies selling
very expensive boats thank you very much
for your time any questions any
questions for by the members of the
Committee hearing and seeing none thank
you very
much Mr Cullen and you'll be followed
by uh is it Betsy
chrone okay
you thank you for the opportunity to
speak today my name is Mark Cullen from
londondary New Hampshire and Bradford
New Hampshire I'm fortunate enough to
own lake property on beautiful Lake
Massa secum I don't know if any of you
guys know it but it's it's a beautiful
Lake I've been my family's own property
on the lake for more than 40 years okay
Lake mum is small
right it's got a really shallow end
there's two rivers that flow out on this
lake so it's really shallow if you could
look at picture one you see the red
outline of the lake that's the loss of
wakes sport real estate that you would
lose so that would force boats in a
small narrow channel where the Deep part
is the first concern is with Bo of
safety right by compressing the wakes
sport area in such a small area creating
congestive
points for boat kayakers you know
swimmers boers will have a narrow area
to navigate creating danger to the
public now that's a real issue right if
you look at that picture you can just
see that that is compressed you lose 75%
of the lake moved all those wake boats
into 25% of the lake right if you look
at the next picture you see that a
spanned across Lake mum is
1,398 feet if you lose 500 feet on both
sides of the lake that get you 398 ft
now these ski boats right I have a ski
boat so I know it's not a wake booat
it's not weighted in the back but it's a
ski booat it's a big engine with a shaft
that goes right to a brass propeller and
a Rudder okay but to to turn that boat
in that small area is dangerous you
won't be able to do without breaking the
law
you you cannot especially if there's
kayaks in there paddle boats in there
whatever it's danger it's going to be
dangerous to the public on a small Lake
like this it is going to be
is shoreline erosion right that's been a
big topic to everybody today right so
this will increase the damage in that
area right right now I don't see any
damage in that area if you look at
picture three that little starage where
my lake property is right across from
where that zone would be right right now
I don't see any damage on Shoreline but
if this passes I definitely will because
all that boat traffic will be right into
that narrow channel just moving back and
trying to get back into that channel
back and forth back and forth into a
small
area concerned about the increased
weight splits such that in confined area
will affect Wildlife you know I heard a
lot of talk about the loons right our
Lake uses those signs when the loons are
nesting right and everybody is
respectful for that right we we slow our
boats down we go to no wake in that area
just because the loons are nesting and
the only reason why I do that it's not a
state law it's a sign that says the the
loons are nesting so we respect that
right we slow down right A lot of people
on this Lake small Lake respect the
people's property we know what to do we
know not to go within 150 ft even 150 ft
and just scream up and down the
shoreline putting huge wake onto the
side of the shore we know not to do that
right so a lot of this is just just
being good neighbors right
um yeah it's uh you know a lot of ice
damage a lot of the shore damage I see
at the lake being there 40 years is ice
ice damage just ripping up the shore
when the ice comes in you know like I
said I don't see I haven't seen any
shore damage
from at this point as the law not being
changed so within 150 ft off the shore I
haven't seen much damage right I'm a
little worried about this law if this
area so thank you for your
time any questions from members of the
committee seeing
srone and followed by Brett uh
[Music]
Nigro
huh he went where oh he says he went on
oh he went already yeah oh
okay oh I thought he put in two cards is
this good y go right down um my name is
Betsy cetron and I'm a resident of New
London and I support Bill
1390 I
segue a little off of this the 4 foot
wave I grew up on the ocean I grew up
sailing on the ocean I know 4 foot waves
I've been at Sunapee for 44 years I love
the water I race a sailboat I paddle
board kayak I drive a boat for my kids
to water ski and Tube the only 4 foot
waves on sunap are made by wake boats
however with the this legislation
the area where the Wake boats are most
likely going to be doing their thing is
where we want to be out sailing and we
are certainly willing to share our
recreational area with the wake booat
people doing it
responsibly I was sitting on the shore
on a very calm day
5:00 sun was kind of sinking Sandy Beach
nothing going on I'm reading a book my
feet are in the water all of a sudden my
butt gets
wet where'd that come from well th feet
away there's a little map you have
there's a wake booat with some kid who's
trying to wake booat and he went about a
100 yards and fell and so they circled
around so now I'm watching and this wave
and I kind of describe it as a tsunami
type of wave because it's coming out of
nowhere I am on the Eastern Shore so I'm
very used to w waves and I watched this
eight times this kid too bad didn't get
up and get to really go further but it
did create this random wave so in
response to all of this I looked online
and they were saying that a fully
developed wake surfboat wake of 4 feet
this is quoting from
Google typically fipy developed 72 feet
from the boat the wave would still be
the 4ft wave at 430 ft would still be 2T
high so a two I'm
5T so if that wave at uh 500 ft
is going to be a big wave could knock me
down on the shore my sailboat is mored
150 to 175 ft off the shore as are other
rafts my concern is if a three or 4 foot
wave comes and hits my boat broadside
because it's not the wave isn't coming
with the weather it's coming from the
wave booat it could do considerable
damage to the boat kids on a raft could
get thrown off um and they could all get
hurt
um the other question I have and I don't
have an answer for this is in the ocean
they say a 4ot wave that's 4ot mean so
the trough it's 4 foot down and 4 foot
up so I don't know if this is you know
what the Wake boats are really creating
in the lake is this but I'm in support
of this bill to try and keep the waves
further from Shore to
protect kids kayakers
paddlers um boats that are anchored and
so forth thank you for your time thank
you any questions by members of the
committee seeing
none hearing
Morgan
here she was at the parking meter when
you called
her
huh no
testify did he
testify if how in Elizabeth there's one
that went to the parking to the park oh
I wasn't aware of
that
huh I have not got a ride the card then
can didn't see
one
not
speak two of us two I
mean
well all right let's let's not go let's
not overthink this
folks
found good afternoon soon to be good
evening we've all been here a long time
um and a lot of my points have already
been spoken to but I've stuck it out as
long as you guys have so we're going to
go for it my name is BU gersen and I've
lived on Lake walki Wan in Meredith New
Hampshire for the past 35 years I'm
speaking in opposition of HB 1390 for
the following reasons first the proposed
bill will effectively eliminate the
legal use of wake boats on dozens of
midsize lakes in New Hampshire including
ours Lake wwan spans 950 acres and has
plenty of Open Water for multiple boats
to do multiple activities while staying
at least 200 ft from Shore and from each
other
but we have one big island in our Lake
Which is less than 1,000 ft from Shore
so this bill with its 500 foot setback
on each side of the boat will restrict
wake boats and wake Sports from using
all the Open Water both in front and in
back of the island because we will not
legally be able to travel past the
island similarly while our lake is an
average of 40 ft deep there are spots
near the center of our Lake that are
less than the proposed 20ft depth
minimum having to avoid these parts of
the lake will increase the number of
repetitive passes in certain sections of
water rather than minimize them and it
will create dangerous situations for all
boers second the proposed legislation
applies both to a type of boat and
several specific activities related to
water sports
but wake boats are used for many
activities not just wake Sports we use
our boat for water skiing for wake
boarding for air chairing and for wake
surfing sometimes we have the ballasts
filled and sometimes we don't if this
bill passes some of our activities will
be regulated one way and others will be
regulated very differently it is
inconsistent and
unfair and unenforceable to be able to
apply rules to a particular type of boat
rather we should all obey the current
setback limits and respect all boers and
Shore owners to ensure safe enjoyable
Lake access for
everyone thirdly I've participated in
these debates over the past several
years and I have noticed that much of
the dissent regarding weight boats grew
originally from one group of people on
one large New Hampshire Lake many of
their complaints center around boats
blasting loud music repeatedly circling
the same section of water and not
respecting the current 150ft setback
limits from Shore or from other boats
these are clearly undesirable boating
behaviors but the offenders are not in
any way limited to wake boats in fact
pontoon boats account for a majority of
new boat sails in the state these boats
spend hours driving in circles
specifically trying to rough up the
water to create tubing Thrills they have
big parties on the pontoon boats and
they play loud music that can be heard
all the way across the lake none of this
disruption has anything to do with wake
boats or wake Sports yet the proposed
Bill does nothing to restrict this
undesirable
behavior in conclusion New Hampshire
Lakes are for everyone to enjoy safe
respectful boating is everyone's
responsibility
but rather than create new laws that
restrict one class of vote and ban wake
Sports on many of New Hampshire's public
Lakes the mission should be to educate
to enforce current laws and to set a
good example for all
voters thank you for your service to our
state and I respectfully ask you to
1390 thank you is there any questions
hearing and seeing none thank you thank
you very
much
Rob D D is
need I'm sure they're going to be lots
of
questions uh my name is Rob
denius I'm here to support
hb13
1990 which I believe would Implement
reasonable Common Sense regulations for
Wake
booting we live year round on Squam in
holderness during the summer months we
are often on the lake kaying swimming
and boating we own a powerboat and our
children are Avid water
skiers our section of the lake has some
of the heaviest usage by water skiers
and we understand and support boers
having fun on the
lake in fact several years ago one of
our neighbors applied for a permit to
install a permanent submersible water
skiing course the only one on the lake
right in front of our place the
department of the state that issues
permits for this activity gave us the
ability to object which we were told
would likely have resulted in revocation
of the
permit we did not object I mention this
because I would like those considering
this statement testimony to have some
context for our strong support support
of this
bill wake boating near the shore creates
impacts on the lake and those who use it
that are categorically different and
more severe than any other kind of
boating
activity more
specifically the erosion along sections
of our Shoreline and by the way it's as
an aside we live in the Northwest
Quadrant of Squam so we do not suffer
winds uh the prevailing winds are such
that we are in the Lee of those
prevailing winds the only winds that we
have on our Shoreline are direct East
Winds during a
storm and the erosion on along sections
of our Shoreline not fully protected by
large rocks has been visible and
obvious we are literally watching parts
of our Shoreline be eaten away after
just 3 years of heavy wake
boating we know this impact is
attributable to wake boating since since
the erosion occurred after wake boats
began regularly operating close to our
Shoreline in
2020 the wakes from these boats are so
large that we sometimes are unable to
use our dock the wakes are large and
powerful enough to lift sections of the
cedar decking that sits on top of the
aluminum dock frame completely off the
frame we are unable to have our
motorboat tied to our dock when wake
boating is in heaviest use
as the cycling of the Wake boats back
and forth in front of our dock creates
such violent turbulence and force that
the only reliable way to keep our boat
from crashing into the dock is to Moore
it on a
moing we are advised by the company that
handles most dock repair and
installation on Squam that the only
reliable way to keep our boat from
literally battering itself or our dock
to Pieces was to install a new moing as
whips would not be sufficient to to hold
our boat off the dock given the size of
generated during periods of heavy wake
booat usage we are unable to launch
kayaks from our shore or have our young
grandchildren Wade along the
shore the wakes from Wake booat cycling
back and forth 4 hours in front of our
dock are far too destabilizing to allow
it this is not the case when we have
occurring we have noticed that over the
past summer or two a few wake booat
operators in fact a number uh many many
of them have thankfully woken up to the
realities of the harms inflicted by
their boats and shifted their operation
away from the shoreline and toward the
middle of the
lake I have a hard time understanding
the basis for principled opposition to
this bill as I've seen responsible own
owners of these boats demonstrate
regularly that they can operate and have
fun with their boats in a manner fully
consistent with this
legislation I hope that legislators will
see through empty appeals to individual
rights and protect our Lakes our
greatest natural resource by voting in
favor of this bill if we can have both
Lake health and wake booting why
wouldn't we choose to have
you let me guess no
questions is there any questions by
members of the of the committee seeing
none thank you very much uh now was
who's is
missing is uh has not
spoken yes not gu not cuz I some I
thought we said there was someone named
named the Elizabeth but there wasn't
Elizabeth from the lake sopy Protection
Association she spoke already so so
we're all uh is there anyone who has not
speak if
not
I uh if you got fill out a card have
you'll get fill out after you speak just
ahead hi um thank you for letting me
come up my name is Linda shell I live on
Lake oichi I've been a lakeef front odor
for 20 years um and I just wanted to
address the Waterfront we have over 200
ft of
Waterfront a couple of winters ago they
decided to drop the water on Lake oichi
a foot under the ice as I watched my
neighbor's ice rank that had been
shoveled off travel from their house
past our house on the lake the ice
shifted that much I had icebergs on my
Waterfront this
High huge icebergs all over the
Waterfront our neighbor tree fell in the
lake and I just wanted to attest that
ice and wind are causing more damage to
our waterfronts than the Wake boats
especially if we boarding is done
respectfully thank you for your time
card they could get one out out front oh
she have them up you have them there
good see that there's no one uh else who
wishes to speak
oh pretty soon I'll have everybody
okay my name is Brendan Florio I live on
Lake oichi also not far from where the
Shel live um so
we I've been making some notes as I'm
listening I didn't plan to speak so
I some things come up other than the
science and the technology and the um
the the statistics that are thrown at
you I've been a boa my whole life I'm 73
years old been Bo since I'm
nine the first 30 some odd years I was
in the ocean and now 42 years here in
Region courtesy and Common Sense means
more than anything else that you could
put into
law I've seen the most unbelievable
ridiculous things going
on that could solve a lot of
problems I won't get into details but if
any of you have ever been on the water
yourselves traveling down the middle of
OPI which is not a big lake about a half
a mile wide from my house across the the
Lake when we're water skiing up and down
the middle which is what we always do we
stay away from the shoreline we have
enough common sense for that we don't
need to be regulated for that it's just
courtesy so many times I'll see a canoe
a kayaker just sitting in the
middle and giving us frowns or dirty
looks well they have a right to be there
and so do we but there's some common
sense about it there's plenty of Lake if
you see a water skier go by or if you
see a surfboat go by don't try to stay
in their Lane there's no law against it
but it just courtesy and Common Sense
I've seen it we have a slalom course on
the north end of our Lake how many times
we would travel to go up there to use it
and to be a person with no wind with a
sailfish sitting in the middle of it no
reason to be
there so my point is courtesy and Common
Sense goes a long way and that can
happen through the education part of the
earlier Bill we some of the others had
spoken
about and not to mention but I will
mention
that canoers and kayakers and I'm one of
them also we have a rack full of those
for us and our guests I'm not opposed to
any any use of
it but there's no registration fee for
any of those
boats we pay a fee for the boats we use
surfboats ski boats jet
skis but there's no skin in the game
when it comes to money to a kayaker or a
canoe or somebody with a
sailfish there used to be years ago from
what I believe origin registration fee
but there isn't any longer that might be
something the committee might want to
think
about
so to sum it up
courtesy and and Common Sense is what's
needed by Boat Owners all Boat Owners
kayakers canoers sailboat owners
sailfish and surfboat and water SK
boats that's what I have to say thank
you thank you very
much
no have no questions on
that uh we are we're ready to are we
ready to
adjourn CL hear hearing is
[Music]
closed